>>> YOU CAN SAY TEAM LOVE THEM
BUT THEY MIGHT HAVE THOUGHT
WON'T GET TO ROUND ONE.
>> WE SEE THE BIG BOARD AS WE
GET READY FOR ROUND NUMBER TWO?
BECAUSE TAMPA, MINNESOTA AND
TENNESSEE.
ALL THOSE GOING BECAUSE OF
TRADES.
TENNESSEE IN TAMPA IN MINNESOTA
EVAN WILLIAMS BECAUSE OF THE
GERMANE JOHNSON TRADE WITH THE
JET.
WE TALKED BEFORE ABOUT THE
NAKOBE DEAN BUT NOT DAVID OCHOA
VOTE.
WHO DO YOU THINK COULD GO TO
TAMPA BAY?
>> THE IDEA OF A WEAPON MAKES
SENSE AND HE WOULD OFFER THAT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU COULD GET
THE GUY IN THE SECOND ROUND AND
YOU NEED SOMEONE THAT WILL
PLAY.
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUARTERBACK
THAT IS ALREADY RETIRED I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU ARE GOING TO GET
ONE AND WAIT FOR.
>> I AM WITH YOU, FELLNER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT TRAVIS JONES
AND PLAY.
TODD BOWLES PLAYS BIG AND LAST
YEAR YOU COULD SEE IT ALL OFF.
IF THEY GO OFFENSE, DO NOT BE
SHOCKED IF THEY START THE TYPE
AND RUN EARLY.
>> WE HAVE NOT HAD A RUNNING
BACK OR TIGHT END DRAFTED AND
GRONK IS A FREE AGENT.
>> IT WOULD BE TREY MCBRIDE.
FIRST SIGNING OFF THE BOARD.
IS THE MOST PRO-READY.
HIS COT MAYBE THE BEST HANDS IN
THE U.S. HE IS GOOD AS A
BLOCKER AND HE IS THE SEE IT
SLEEPER CELL.
>> LET'S GO TO JASON KELCE.
WHAT A NIGHT, JASON KELCE HAD
LAST NIGHT.
STILL LOOKING COMFORTABLE AND
SWAB.
JASON, HAVE YOU CALMED DOWN
AFTER LAST NIGHT OR ARE YOU
STILL RIDING HIGH?
>> I MEAN I'VE CALMED DOWN A
LITTLE BIT OF ADJUSTMENT JORDAN
DAVIS DOWN IN THE FACILITIES
AND HE WAS THE SIZE OF THE
DOOR.
IN PERSON MEETING HIM WAS MORE
IMPRESSIVE THAN WATCHING THIS
TAPE.
I AM EXCITED TO DO BATTLE WITH
HIM.
>> NOW THAT YOU BRING IT UP,
WHAT HAS BEEN THE VIBE THE LAST
18 HOURS SINCE THIS ALL
HAPPENED.
WHAT TEAMMATES HAVE YOU TALKED
TO?
WHAT CULTURES HAVE YOU TALKED
WHAT THINGS ARE YOU HEARING
THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE?
>> OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE IS
EXCITED ABOUT ROUND, SOMETHING
WILL SURELY ENHANCE OUR
OFFENSE.
SO I THINK EVERYONE IS EXCITED.
EVERYONE HAS BEEN TEXTING AND
CALLING.
IT WILL EXPAND OUR OFFENSE.
MOOD IN THE BUILDING WAS VERY
POSITIVE.
>> JASON, APPARENTLY,
PHILADELPHIA WAS GOING NUTS
LAST NIGHT.
LET'S LOOK AT EAGLES FANS
LOSING THEIR MINDS.
[ CHEERING ] [ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH, MY GOD.
[ CHEERING ]
>> I AM THE HAPPIEST EAGLES FAN
ALIVE.
>> WE KNOW WHAT TIME IT IS IT
IS OUR SEASON AND ITS TREVON
TATE SETH SMITH SEASON.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY, BABY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I WOULD EXPECT NOTHING LESS
THAN THAT FROM PHILADELPHIA.
>> I LOVE IT.
WE WILL CHECK IN WITH JASON
KELCE THROUGHOUT THE DRAFT
WHENEVER SOMEONE IN THE
TRENCHES IS TAKING.
LET'S CHECK IN WITH AHMAD SAM
BROWN.
AND IN HUTCHINSON A TRADE FOR A
PERFECT COMPLEMENT FOR THE
CLUTCH KID, WHO ONLY CATCHES
TOUCHDOWNS TO WIN FOOTBALL
GAMES.
AHMAD ST. BROWN.
WE HAVE A LOT OF PLAYERS COMING
OF THE BOARDS TODAY.
WHO DID YOU WATCH FOR US AND
YOU ARE SO EXCITED TO TALK
ABOUT THIS GUY?
>> I WOULD HAVE TO GO WITH JEAN
MACHI FROM ALABAMA.
HE HAD THE ACL INJURY IN THE
NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP.
IT'S NOT THE FASTEST BUT
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT HE DOES
HIS SAVVY AND COMES OUT OF HIS
ROUTES WELL.
HIS GOOD AFTER THE CATCH TO
START AND STOP ABILITY, AS A
RECEIVER BEING ABLE TO START
AND STOP IS HUGE AND HE HAS
THAT I'M EXCITED TO SEE HIM
COME OFF THE BOARD TODAY AND
TALK ABOUT HIM.
>> AHMAD ST. BROWN BREAKING
DOWN THE WIDE RECEIVERS.
LEICESTER CHECK IN WITH THE MAN
THAT STOLE A MICROPHONE AND
THEN STOLE OUR HEARTS AND HAS
HIS OWN PODCAST.
HE WILL LIKELY TAKE OVER ALL
MEDIA COMPANIES FOR THE REST OF
OUR LIVES.
RICHARD SHERMAN, GIVE ME BIG
PITCHER HERE.
HE WENT TO SLEEP AND YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT YOU AND
WATCHED AN ADDRESS LAST NIGHT,
WHAT IS THE ONE THING THAT IS
STICKING OUT TO YOU.
>> I THOUGHT PEOPLE GET
DESPERATE.
I THOUGHT MALIK WILLIS WOULD GO
IN THE FIRST ROUND.
I THOUGHT PEOPLE WOULD WANT
CONTROL OF THAT FOR FEAR
OPTION.
THEY DIDN'T THE CORNER FROM
CLEMSON, I THOUGHT HE WOULD GO
EARLIER.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE TOP 15 OR
TOP 20.
I'M SURE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
EXCITED THERE.
HE IS A HECK OF A PLAYMAKER AND
THE IS A GUY THAT TAKES THEM
ALL AND IS A BIG TIME HITTER.
THAT'S WHAT STANDS OUT TO ME.
HE IS A HI-POINTE TURNOVER
MACHINE.
WHEN YOU THROW IN THE AREA
THERE IS A DANGER.
HE MOVED TO DB BECAUSE HE
COULDN'T PLAY RECEIVER OR HE
COULD NOT CATCH.
I WOULD EXPECT TERM TO GO
HIGHER.
WE KNEW WHO THE TOP TWO CORNERS
WORK BUT HE IS HIGHER.
>> MR. BOOTH COULD GO VERY
EARLY IN THE SECOND AROUND.
RICHARD SHERMAN, THE MAN, WE
WILL CHECK WITH YOU SOON
ENOUGH.
I AM SEEING ON TELEVISION RIGHT
NOW THE TAMPA BAY BUCKS ARE NOT
OFFICIALLY ON THE CLOCK BUT DO
WE WANT TO, ACTUALLY WANT TO
ASK A CORKED BAT QUESTION,
MULLETT LAKE.
WHERE DO YOU THINK HE GOES.
>> IS GOING TO BE SOON.
IT'S GOING TO BE REAL SOON.
THE VIKINGS, YOU DON'T PULL HIM
OUT HERE.
>> DID YOU HEAR MIKE ZIMMER I
SEE HIM PRACTICE EVERY DAY.
THAT WAS NOT A GOOD SIGN.
TENNESSEE.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY 37.
>> THEY REALLY LIKE DAVIS MILLS
BUT WHY NOT.
AND THEN THE BIG ONE I THINK
THAT WOULD BE EXCITING FOR
EVERYONE WOULD BE SEATTLE.
>> THEY HAVE THE BACK TO BACK
PICKS.
USUALLY YOU TRY TO MOVE ON AND
SPREAD YOUR CARDS.
I LOOK DREW LOCK ISN'T FIRING
UP.
MALIK WILLIS CAN.
>> CAN WE SEE SOME MALIK WILLIS
FOR THIS?
IF YOU GET ALL THE WAY TO 43?
>> ESPECIALLY WITH ARTHUR SMITH
AND WHAT THEY ARE ALREADY DOING
WITH MARIO..
I JUST WANT YOU TO TAKE ME
THROUGH.
I HAVE NOT HEARD YOUR STANCE ON
HIM, FELDNER.
>> IT IS A DEFAULT AND HE MOVES
THE POCKET AND I FAILED.
INVADE.
GET OFF ME.
HE IS NOT THE BIGGEST GUY BUT
HE DOES HAVE STRENGTH IN HIS
GAME AND THE ABILITY TO DELIVER
A HOT BALL.
THE BEST PLAY HE HAS ON FILM IS
AGAINST VIRGINIA TECH.
IT IS A HAVE ROLE AND HAVE PRO
GUY CLOSES IN AND SPINS OUT AND
DELIVERS A DIMED, 35 TO 40
YARDS DOWN THE FIELD, RIGHT AT
THE 1 YARD LINE AND THEY DROP
IT IN THE BUCKET RIGHT ABOVE
DEFENSIVE BACKS HANDS AND
THAT'S RIGHT WHERE THEY CAUGHT
IT AT THE GOAL LINE.
FOR ME RECOGNIZING THE VOID AND
COVERAGE PEOPLE KEEP CALLING
HIM A RUNNING GUY.
IT'S SILLY AND INSULTING.
THE BIGGEST THING FOR ME
WATCHING HIM PLAY AS HE
UNDERSTANDS WHERE SPACES ARE ON
THE FIELD.
HE KNOWS WHERE HE SHOULD BE ON
CAN HE RUN?
YES.
BUT WHAT HE DOES WELL IS THROW
THE FOOTBALL.
>> MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT HIM
IS STAYING AT THE SENIOR BOWL
AND SING THE DAY-TO-DAY
IMPROVEMENT WHILE WORKING WITH
THE NANAFALIA STAFF.
YOU SEE DAY ONE I MEAN1, GOD,
IS GOT TO BE UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU ARE ON THE PRACTICE FIELD
AND YOU ARE A QUARTERBACK
TRYING TO BUILD CHEMISTRY AND
DAY TWO WE STAND OUT THERE IN A
MONSOON.
NOBODY CAN GET A SNAP OR HOLD
THE BALL OR THROW THE BALL.
MALIK WILLIS YOU WOULD THINK HE
HAD THROWN IN THE DOME.
HIS THROWS WERE GREAT.
HE IS CONFIDENT.
PEOPLE LIKE HIM.
HE CAN MAKE PLACE OUTSIDE OF
THE POCKET.
THE GREEN LIGHT COMING ON VERY
HEAVY PLAY ACTION OFFENSE THAT
YOU COULD CUT THE FIELD AND
HAVE WITH HIM AT THE NEXT LEVEL
AND SIMPLIFY THINGS EARLY.
>> YOU TOLD ME THE PITTSBURGH
STEELERS ONLY DRAFT GUYS THAT
THEY GO TO THE PRO DAYS.
THEY WERE VERY PRESENT AT MALIK
WILLIS' PRO DAY.
HAVE YOU HEARD HOW THEY ENDED
UP AT KENNY PICKETT?
>> I HEARD FIVE DAYS AGO THAT
IT WAS STARTING TO GRAVITATE
TOWARD KENNY PICKETT.
MAYBE IT WAS THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE NOT AS SOLD ON MITCH
TRUBISKY BEING.
KEPT THE SEER WHERE KENNY
PICKETT COULD COME IN AND GIVE
YOU MORE LIFE AND MORE JUICE
THAN MITCH TRUBISKY CAN.
EVERYONE KNOWS MALIK WILLIS,
EVERY QUARTERBACK GOING, THEY
SHOULD GET AN NFL REDSHIRT
HERE.
I DON'T FEEL THAT WAY ABOUT
KENNY PICKETT.
I THINK HE CAN COME IN AND PLAY
IT FOR PLAYMAKERS AND HE CAN
DISTRIBUTE THE BALL TO THEM.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS THE
RIGHT CHOICE.
I THINK THE UPSIDE WAS
INTRIGUING WHEN YOU HAVE A
BRIDGE STARTER.
>> HOW MUCH BETTER IS MUCH TOO
BUSY THAN KENNY PICKETT RIGHT
NOW?
>> I WOULD SAY HE IS NOT BETTER
THAN KENNY PICKETT RIGHT NOW
HOW DID WE GET HERE WITH MITCH
STRAVINSKY.
YOU SPENT A YEAR IN BUFFALO?
>> YES.
>> THAT'S WHAT ALWAYS HAPPENS.
>> STEVEN ORLEMAN STORMED OUT
AND HE WANTED TO SEAN WATSON.
>> THAT TOO.
>> LEE CIRCLE BROADWAY BACK
AROUND AND IS GOING TO BE THE
STARTERS FOR THE STEELERS BUT
IF WE DON'T THINK IT'S A HUGE
GAP, THEN WHAT? WE HAVE AN OPEN
COMPETITION.
IF YOU HAVE AN OPEN COMPETITION
THAN WHAT PLAY FOOTBALL.
>> LET'S GO INTO YOUR NOTEBOOK.
ANYTHING ELSE YOU ARE HEARING
BEFORE WE START KICKING OFF
AROUND TWO?
>> BREECE HALL WILL BE A HOT
NAME.
ONE OF THE BEST RUNNING BACKS
IN HIS CLASS.
THE ABILITY TO BE A PASS
CATCHER TEAMS IN THE TOP 40-
YARD WARNING.
IT'S OKAY TO TAKE A RUNNING
BACK BECAUSE WE THINK THE SKY
CAN BE SPECIAL.
TRAVIS JONES IS IN THAT LIGHT
AS WELL AND YOU WILL SEE A HIGH
WIDE RECEIVER BUT BOY, THEY
HAVE KATIE ALONG WITH NICK AND
GUYS LIKE THAT IN SAM WILLIAMS
AND MY JASON SANDERS, ANOTHER
PAST DAY.
THOSE ARE THE BIG NAMES.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
MOVEMENT IN PHONE CALLS FOR
TEAMS WANT TO GET IN THE TOP 40
WE HAVE THREE GUYS LEFT.
>> HOW MANY FIRST ROUND GRADES
DO YOU HAVE LEFT?
>> ONLY A HANDFUL.
>> I WAS LOOKING AT MY SHEETS
AND USING SOMEONE ELSE'S BIG
BOARD IN THE FIRST 23 ALL WENT
OFF WE DID NOT HAVE A SUPERHIGH
GUY FALL.
>> THREE FIRST ROUND GRADES
LEFT FOR ME AND I ONLY TAKE 24
THIS  YEAR.
FOR PEOPLE AT HOME WHO SAY THAT
OUR DON'T YOU HAVE 32?
THAT'S NOT HOW YOU DO IT.
YOU NEVER HAVE A DRAFT WHERE
EVER FIRST ROUNDER FOR EVERY
FIRST ROUND PICK THAT'S NOT HOW
IT WORKS.
>> I WAS GOING TO MAKE THE JOKE
YESTERDAY THAT HERE ARE THE
POLICE TO REPORT.
WE WILL SAY FOCUS TO TALK ABOUT
FOOTBALL.
WHEN I GREW UP TALKING ABOUT A
JASON ALDEAN CONCERT INSTEAD.
I'M WATCHING ON NFL NOW AND I
THINK IT'S CHRIS ANGEL SPINNING
AROUND WEARING LIKE A LEOTARD.
JUST WANT TO SAY, SORRY,
FELDNER.
LEOTARD RIPPED AND WE CAN DO
IT.
LET'S FOCUS ON TAMPA BAY.
TAMPA BAY 13 AND 4. LOST TO THE
RAMS IN THE DIVISIONAL ROUND.
WHAT A SEASON.
BRADY RETIRES, HE COMES BACK.
BRUCE ARIANS GOES TO THE FRONT
OFFICE BECAUSE THERE'S AN ISSUE
BETWEEN TOM BRADY AND BRUCE
ARIANS.
CAN I GET RICHARD SHERMAN
REALLY QUICK.
RICHARD, DID YOU EVER NOTICE
ANYTHING BETWEEN TOM BRADY AND
BRUCE ARIANS WILL BE ARE
HEARING ALL THE STORIES ABOUT
THE RELATIONSHIP OR IS THIS
JUST A MEDIA FABRICATION.
>> IS A LOT OF SPECULATION.
BRUCE AND HIS GROUP HAVE BEEN
TOGETHER FOR A LONG TIME.
HE'S 70 YEARS OLD.
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A TIME
WHERE IT'S TIME FOR HIM TO BE
WITH HIS FAMILY AND GRANDKIDS
AND INVEST LESS TIME IN HIS
FOOTBALL AND I THINK IT'S JUST
ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS WHERE IT
CAME AT A TIME WHERE HE FELT
LIKE HE HAD TO DO SOMETHING TO
KEEP HIS STAFF.
HE IS KNOWN THOSE GUYS 20, 30,
40 YEARS.
FROM COACHING THEM IN COLLEGE
TO BRING THEM ON THE COACHING
STAFF.
THE MEDIA NEEDED SOMETHING.
THEY HEARD SOME CONVERSATION OR
SOMEONE HAD A CONVERSATION WITH
TOM WERE MAYBE SOMETHING WAS
SAID AND DONE THEY SPECULATE
THE REST OF IT.
YOU NEVER FIND ENOUGH TRUTH.
>> DID YOU THINK TOM WOULD STAY
RETIRED?
OR WERE YOU THE ONE THINKING I
DON'T THINK HE'S DONE.
>> NO, HE WAS NEVER DONE.
I COULD NEVER BELIEVE HE WAS
TOTALLY DONE WITH FOOTBALL.
HE HAD AN OUTSTANDING SEASON
LAST YEAR AND WAS UP FOR THE
MVP TROPHY.
I THINK OF HIS ARM FELT LIKE IT
THROWN OUT THEY CAN'T DO IT OR
A CAT MOVING HIS BODY IS ACHING
AND HE TAKES GREAT CARE OF HIS
BODY.
I DID NOT SEE HIM SITTING DOWN.
HE WAS STILL HUNGRY.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE DIDN'T PUT US
IN POSITION.
FORTUNATELY, COOPER KUPP AND
MATT STAMFORD HAD OTHER PLANS.
I DID NOT THINK HE COULD LIVE
WITH THAT KIND OF A TASTE IN
HIS MOUTH.
>> GAPPA, A DOMINICAN TO OUR
FREE AGENTS.
WE DON'T KNOW IF GRONK IS
COMING BACK.
JAMEL DEAN AND SEAN MURPHY
BUTTON WILL BE FREE AGENTS
AFTER THIS YEAR.
LAVONTE DAVID WILL BE FREE
KNOWING THIS ROSTER, WHAT
POSITION DO YOU THINK THEY GO
IN HERE ASK ALSO GOING TO THIS
TEAM?
>> I THINK THEY GO CORNER.
LIKE THE SAID IT'S A FABULOUS
ATMOSPHERE.
IT WILL GIVE THEM TIME AND SEE
WHAT THEY CAN GET IN THIS
DRAFT.
AT ANY POINT IN TIME THEY ARE
ALWAYS OPEN TO HAVE THOSE GUYS.
>> .
>> AND YOU ARE CIRCLING THE
BOOTH.
>> NO QUESTION I'M CIRCLING
I DON'T THINK THEY NEED HIM TO
PLAY THIS YEAR.
LIKE EVERYONE SAW AND I
EXPERIENCE, TEMPER HAD A LOT OF
INJURIES IN THE CORNER SPOT.
AND REALLY GOT STRETCHING.
SO I THINK HAVING BOOTH IN
THERE AND IN THAT ROOM TO BACK
THOSE GUYS UP, COMPETE FOR A
STARTING SPOT, GIVES THEM THE
DEPTH THEY NEED GOING FORWARD.
>> AWESOME.
>> RICHARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> I WILL ADD ON.
THEY WILL HAVE A LOT OF FREE
AGENTS ON THE BACK AND IN 2023.
THE DONE A GOOD JOB KEEPING
THEIR GUYS.
TODD BOWLES, NOBODY TAKES CARE
OF THE SECONDARY MORE THAN HIM.
>> BOOTH IS A GUY THAT I MARKED
IN THE FIRST RUN A LOT.
THE VALUE TO GET DOWN HERE IS
UP THERE.
>> IF HE WAS ABLE TO TEST HE
HAD A GOOD SHOT OF BEING A
FIRST ROUNDER.
GOOD ATHLETE.
I BELIEVE HE'S HAD A HAMSTRING
ISSUE AND HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
TEST.
THAT KEPT HIM OUT OF THE FIRST
ROUND.
>> THE KID IS GOOD.
I LOVE THE WAY HE SHOOTS.
HE WILL TAKE THE RISK TO COME
INSIDE UNTIL SPRING.
I LOVE THAT ABOUT HIM.
HE DOES NOT MISS WHEN HE MAKES
THOSE DECISIONS.
I LIKE THE WAY HE CARRIES
UNDERNEATH WHEN HE IS IN
COVERAGE.
HE HELPS YOUR SAFETY TO YOUR HE
RALLIES TO TACKLE.
ANOTHER THING I FIND
INTERESTING.
FINDING THE BALL TO THE
RECEIVER, WHEN HE IS FACEUP
HEAD-TO-HEAD HE IS ABLE TO TURN
AND LOOK FOR THE BALL.
IT IS NOT THE SAME AS WHEN
YOU'RE BACK IS TO HIM.
HE IS STILL FACE-TO-FACE WITH
THOSE GUYS AND ABLE TO MAKE A
PLAY.
>> HOW MANY CALLS YOU THINK
THEY ARE GETTING?
>> BUT NOT FORGET THAT THEY
MOVED OUT.
AT SOME POINT YOU WANT TO MAKE
A PIT.
>> THAT IS WHAT IS INTERESTING.
ALL THESE TEAMS TO START THE
SECOND ROUND MOVED OUT.
TEMPER, AND TENNESSEE TRADED
DOWN.
TAMPA, MINNESOTA, THEY HAD
THEIR PICK.
WE SEE TENNESSEE, THEY WENT
WITH BIRX.
DO YOU THINK TENNESSEE GOES FOR
ANOTHER WIDE RECEIVER?
>> I KNOW THAT BROUGHT IN
ROBERT WOOD, OBVIOUSLY.
>> BUT THEY NEEDED A WIDE
RECEIVER WHEN THEY HAD A.J.
BROWN.
ROBERT WOOD IS COMING OFF AN
ACL.
I LOOKED IT UP TODAY.
MAKING $39 MILLION?
>> YOU CANNOT DO ANYTHING THAT
CONTRACT.
>> NO.
BUT THE SIXERS GOT RID OF BEN
SIMMONS.
YOU CAN GET RID OF BOMBS.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
SKYY MOORE WERE ANDERSON?
>> BUT IF YOU WANT TO WIN NOW
IS GEORGE THE ONE YOU ARE
PICKING?
>> SAME QUESTION WITH KRISHAN
WATKINS.
>> IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE
THINGS WHERE THEY ARE IN THE
WHEN NOW MODE.
>> NUMBER ONE TEAM IN THE NFC.
>> HOW MANY MORE YEARS OF PRIME
DERRICK HENRY ARE WE GOING TO
HAVE LOT.
>> THEY ARE WIN NOW MODE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY CAN GET,
WHO IS PROBABLY THE BEST
RECEIVER ON THE BOARD, IS
GEORGE PICKENS.
THEY CANNOT TAKE THE CHANCE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> THE PICK IS AN AND WE WILL
WAIT TO SEE WHO OUR HERO IS ON
TWITTER.
WE ARE GOING TO DO OUR BEST TO
STAY AHEAD OF IT.
RUNNING UP IS GOING TO BE LOGAN
HALL, DEFENSIVE TACKLE WE
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE IS GOING TO BE A
POSSIBILITY OF CHANGES UPFRONT.
THAT'S WHERE THE BUCCANEERS GO.
LOGAN HALL.
FIRST PICK OF THE SECOND WORLD
6'6", 283.
A PRETTY GOOD ATHLETE AND THE
FIRST PICK FOR THE TAMPA BAY
BUCKS.
WHAT DO WE THINK, CONNOR?
>> I LIKE THIS.
SOMETHING FELDNER AND I TALK
ABOUT A LOT.
A TWEENER LUKE MBETE TO QUIT
HER GUARDS AND CAKE OUT THE
FIVE TECH.
HE WILL GET A CHANCE TO BRUSH
ON THE OUTSIDE AND USE THAT
POWER AGAINST ATTACKERS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT LOGAN HALL A
GOOD TESTER.
SIDELINE TO SIDELINE CHASE
SPEED.
THE THING I HEARD ABOUT THE BOX
IS WE ARE USED TO SEEING THEM
GETTING DEFENSIVE TACKLES.
THEY WANTED SOMEONE WHO CAN FLY
AND DISRUPT THE QUARTERBACK.
LOGAN HALL A NICE PLAYER FOR
THIS DEFENSE.
THIS IS A B+ QUICK.
>> FIRST ROUND PLAYER.
A PLUS.
>> WHAT YOU LOVE ABOUT THIS
GUY?
>> HE'S A SHOOTER.
HE CREATES PENETRATION ON HIS
OWN.
HE MAKES HIMSELF SKINNY AND
THAT CAUSES HIM PROBLEM FOR
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
I WANT TO HEAR JASON KELCE TALK
ABOUT IT.
WHAT TO DO WHEN YOU WANT TO
CLOSE DOWN AGAIN OR MOVE A GUY?
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS KID IS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
HE HAS GREAT VISIBILITY AND CAN
PLAY OUTSIDE AND INSIDE.
YOU TALKED ABOUT SHOOTING THE
GAP, MICHAEL.
HE'S GOOD AT DIPPING THE
SHOULDER AND GETTING INTO THE
GAP.
ONCE HE PIERCES THE GAP IT'S
OVER.
I CAN SEE THE SKY PLAYING DOWN
OUTSIDE LIKE A DEFENSIVE END
POSITION SLIDING DOWN SECOND
DOWN, THIRD DOWN OR EVEN JUST
TRYING TO CREATE DISRUPTION
INSIDE.
YOU SEE HIM IN THE BACK OF THE
LOT.
HIS THE GAP SWELL.
A SOLID PLAYER THAT FINISHES.
HE REMINDS ME OF ERIC OLMSTEAD
OUT OF SAN FRANCISCO.
>> A LOT OF LINCOLN PLACE BIG.
>> LET'S GO ONE TO BRING IN
RICHARD SHERMAN.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT WITH THEM
GOING BROKEN WITH THE LOGAN
HALL.
>> SOMETIMES HE HAS FIVE DOWN,
SOMETIMES THREE.
YOU SAW WITH JOE TRYON LAST
YEAR.
SOMETIMES YOU SEE THEM MIND
OVER THE CENTER OR 10 YARDS
DEEP OR OUTSIDE OVER THE
RECEIVER.
THOSE KIND OF LOOKS AND THAT
KIND OF VERSATILITY KEEPS THE
OFFENSE ON THEIR HEELS
CONSTANTLY AND THIS IS ANOTHER
PIECE TO PUT IN HIS PLACE.
HE MAY BE AN A THREE OR FOUR OR
A NINE AND THAT'S WHAT TODD IS
LOOKING FOR AND YOU CAN CHECK
AND YOU CAN SEE ON THE OUTSIDE.
THIS IS GREAT PICK AND A LOT OF
FUN FOR THE GIG.
>> LOVE IT.
RIVER TRADE FOR THE SECOND PICK
OF THIS ROUND.
PACKERS GIVING UP 22ND ROUND
PICKS.
53 AND 592 UP TO THE VIKINGS
34.
>> . AND YOU ARE THEY TAKING?
CHRISTIAN WATSON, A WIDE
RECEIVER.
THEY HEARD ALL THE MEANS.
KICK RETURN AND FOUR TOUCHDOWNS
OF 65 YEARS.
NORTH DAKOTA STATE.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF THE NEWEST
RECORD?
>> OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SIZE AND
SPEED.
AN ELITE TESTER.
I THOUGHT HE HAD A NICE WEEK IN
MOBILE CHRISTIAN WATSON PLAY
STRENGTH IS AN ADJUSTMENT.
IT'S NOT A SUREFIRE ANSWER AND
I LIKE IT AS A LONG-TERM PICK
AND I THINK YOUR TWO HE WILL BE
UP TO SPEED LEGO A- AND I LIKE
THE AGGRESSION AND FOR ME 30
NINTH ALL AND IT CHECKS OUT.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A
LETTER B+.
LISTEN.
WE KNOW AARON RODGERS IS HARD
ON HIS WIDE RECEIVERS.
IN TAKING THAT NEXT STEP IS A
BIG ASK.
GOING UP TO LEVELS.
HE IS GOING GARCIA IN THE NFL
WE'VE SEEN THEM TRYING TO DO
THAT OR TRYING TO DO IT AND
LET'S BRING IN AHMAN ROSS ANNE
BROWN.
THIS IS A GUY FROM A SMALLER
GROUP SCHOOL GOING TO A BIG
SITUATION.
WHAT DID YOU SEE FROM HIM ON
TAPE?
>> HE IS A BIG DEEP THREAT GUY.
THEY LOST MARK WAS TO THE
CHIEFS.
DEEP FOUR, RAN SUB 24.
WATCHES STAY.
NO ONE CATCHES HIM.
THE ONLY QUESTION I HAVE IS
WHAT COMPETITION HE WAS GOING
UP AGAINST IN COLLEGE.
SOME TVs MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
THE BEST.
GOING TO SEE PEOPLE LIKE
PATRICK PETE ON THE VIKINGS.
JEFF OKUDAH.
THESE GUYS ARE ELITE CORNERS.
IT WILL TAKE TIME TO ADJUST AND
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN MAKE THAT
TRANSITION.
>> AHMAD ST. BROWN CHIMING IN.
THE BIG PLAYER OR GREEN BAY.
CHRISTIAN WATSON OUT OF NORTH
DAKOTA STATE JOINING THE GREEN
BAY PACKERS.
WE ARE KEEPING IT MOVING.
TITANS STAY WITH THEIR PICK.
GOING ROGER MCCREARY WITH THE
35TH PICK.
RAJEEV FRANK CURRERI DOUG KYED
JORDAN SCHROEDER RAY KING THAT
ONE.
ROGER MCCREARY FIRST TEAM ALL-
AMERICAN AND SEC.
SIX INTERCEPTIONS IN HIS
CAREER.
DESCRIBE IS THE ALPHA BY THE
SECONDARY BY FORMER DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR DARREN MASON.
WHO DID THEY GET?
>> I THOUGHT HE PLAYED WELL
WHILE AT AUBURN AND HE GETS TO
MOBILE AND HE GOES IN THE SLOT
BECAUSE OF LENGTH OF ARM TO BE
FAIR TO ROGER MCCREARY, VERY
STICKY AND COVERAGE WHERE HE
PUTS HIMSELF IN POSITION
DESPITE LIMITED LENGTH. SO FOR
THE TITANS HERE AND I YOU MIGHT
BE KICKING INSIDE OR MAYBE YOU
ARE COMFORTABLE WITH A READ
TRUST THE TAPE AND INSTEAD WE
PLAY HIM ON THE OUTSIDE THEY
NEEDED HELP IN THE VALUE ITEM
IS 54TH OVERALL PLAYER TO THE
PLATEAU.
A LOT OF GUYS ARE SIMILAR.
THIS IS A B A LONG-TERM NUMBER
TWO AND MORE LIKELY NUMBER TWO
CORNER AT A KEY SPOT.
>> THEY HAVE TYLER MYERLY AND
KRISTIAN FULTON ALREADY.
HE WILL GET TO LEARN AND GET TO
PLAY AND I REMEMBER EARLY THEY
WERE LIKE WE WOULD NEVER DRAFT
A CORNER AND THEN THEY GO GET A
CORNER AND HE'S REALLY GOOD
CORNER.
I LOVE McCREARY.
WHEN I WATCH THEM PLAY I SEE
THAT STICK-TO-ITIVENESS AND
WHEN YOU COME TO IT THAT MEANS
YOU GOT YOUR PLASTER UP AGAINST
THAT WIDE RECEIVER.
IT DOES NOT MATTER HOW LONG
YOUR ARMS ARE WHEN YOU ARE INTO
THE  BODY.
>> IT IS INTERESTING WITH THE
ACL'S INJURY LAST YEAR.
RICHARD SHERMAN, WHEN YOU SEE
McCREARY ON TAPE, WHO DOES HE
REMIND YOU OF?
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIS
ADJUSTMENT IN YOUR ONE?
>> I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
FINE.
YOU MENTIONED THE INJURY
CONCERNS WITH CALEB FARLEY.
THEY PLAY A LOT OF MAN-TO-MAN
IN YOUR CORNERS HAVE TO PLAY
100% OF THE SNACKS.
HE'S PLAYED IN THE SEC AND
PLAYED AGAINST THE BEST.
USING THE RECEIVERS OUT OF LSU
AND GEORGIA.
HE HAS COMPETED AGAINST ALL OF
THEM AND TELLS HIS OWN.
I DON'T HAVE A TRUE COMPARISON
RIGHT NOW.
HE IS KIND OF BULKY AND WELL-
BUILT CORNER AND AGGRESSIVE.
PEOPLE MAKE A LOT OF COMMENTS
ABOUT ARM LENGTH.
YOU CAN HAVE THE LONGEST ARMS
IN THE WORLD AND NOT BE ABLE TO
PLAY.
YOU CAN HAVE GREAT ARMS BUT NOT
BE STICKY IN COVERAGE.
CAN THE GUY PLAY.
TURN ON PLAY.
THE CONCERNS MOVING INTO THE
SLOT IS JUST DIFFERENT.
A GUY PLAYING ON THE EDGE HIS
WHOLE CAREER IS IN GOOD TO BUMP
INSIDE AND SAY HEY, THIS IS THE
SAME THING.
IT'S NOT THE SAME THING.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE SIDELINES.
I STILL THINK HE'S AN OUTSIDE
CORNER.
>> RICHARD SHERMAN, WHEN YOU
TOOK OVER THE NFL PEOPLE WOULD
DRAFT LONG CORNERBACKS.
HE'S JUST LIKE RICHARD SHERMAN.
I SAID RICHARD IS A ONE OF
FOUR.
RICHARD WE HAVE A TRADE WE HAVE
TO GET TO.
THE JETS HAVE TRADED UP WITH
THE GIANTS KEEPING IT IN NEW
YORK.
38 AND 146.
A FIFTH-ROUND PICK TRADING UP
AND BREECE HALL.
I'M GOING TO LET YOU GO, BRO.
I WANTED TO SEE MORE MICHAEL
CARTER.
THE JETS TRADE UP TO TAKE HIM.
>> A WORKHORSE.
THEY LIKE MICHAEL MCWHORTER.
THEY GOT HIM IN THE FOURTH
ROUND LAST YEAR WE WERE MAYBE
YOU ARE ONE BE AND BREECE HALL
EVERY DOWN, PASS CATCHER, DEUCE
MCALLISTER, VERY SIMILAR
MEASURE BOTH IN THE SAME DEAL
AS A RUNNER.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
TO NOTE 61 TACKLE BREAKER
EXCELLENT OUTSIDE BIRTHS AND
MOVES IN THE OPEN FIELD.
THE NATURAL FEEL IN MICHAEL
SOWERS OUTSIDE SCHEME IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO TAKE
AWAY HERE AND THEY NEEDED A GUY
THAT COULD BE ON THEIR OUTER
DOWNS AND CATCH THE BALL AS
WELL.
YOU SEE THE BREAKAWAY SPEED.
THE JETS OFFENSE HAVE NOT HAD
BIG PLAYABILITY.
YOU THINK ELIJAH MOORE WILL
TURN THE CORNER AND HAVE A BIG
SECOND YEAR.
YOU ARE SOMEONE IN THE
BACKFIELD SPENDING A LOT OF
RESOURCE.
MICHAEL CARTER GOT INJURED LAST
YEAR AS WELL.
YOU NEEDED ANOTHER RUNNING
BACK.
>> THIS IS ONE OF MY BEST
PLAYERS AVAILABLE.
FOR BREECE HALL AT NUMBER 30.
I DON'T LIKE TAKING RUNNING
BACKS IN THE FIRST ROUND.
AFTER THAT I DON'T CARE IF THEY
ARE READY GOOD ENOUGH PLAYER.
THIS WAS B+.
IF MICHAEL CARTER GOT HURT
AGAIN, THEY DON'T HAVE ANYBODY.
>> I WATCH THEM LAST YEAR AND
IT WOULD BE A LITTLE COMMON OR
JOHNSON.
THERE WAS NO IDENTITY.
THIS IS YOUR IDENTITY.
IS HE A FELDNER BACK?
I THINK THE ONLY BE REASON THEY
DIDN'T GO IS THERE STOCK IS
DOWN.
HE WILL STEP UP AND STINK HIS
NOSE IN IT WATCHING HIM RUN THE
FOOTBALL.
HE COMES TO THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE AND HE WILL PRESS
HARD AND ONCE HE FINDS THE SPOT
HE STICKS HIS FOOT IN THE
GROUND AND GOES.
>> MICHAEL FORD OFFENSE WHICH
COMES FROM KYLE SHANAHAN IS
PERFECT.
>> EXACTLY.
WE TALKED ABOUT SEEING IT ON
FILM.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM BREAK TACKLES
AND USE THAT BUILD UP SPEED AS
YOU CALL IT.
IS NOT GOING TO A PURSUIT BUT
IF YOU BLOCK IT UP RIGHT AND HE
BREAKS A TACKLE, THE NEXT THING
YOU KNOW HE'S RUNNING PAST
SAFETY WON'T WANT TO TACKLE THE
HE'S GOT SOME SIZE TO HIM.
>> 4-3-9.
>> WHAT IS YOUR GRADE?
I'M GOING WITH A A. HIS BEST
RUNNING DRAFT.
YOU GOT HIM COUPLE OF PICKS.
I MENTIONED PASS, YOU CAN CATCH
IT OUT OF THE BACKFIELD AS
WELL.
ZACH WILSON WILL FALL IN LOVE
WITH THIS.
>> RIGHT, THE DRAFT IS MOVING
RIGHT ALONG.
THEY HAVE NOT ANNOUNCED THAT.
BUT LET'S GO TO TEXANS.
FAILURE SAFETY COME JALEN PG IS
THE PICK.
CONSENSUS, FIRST TEAM ALL-
AMERICAN.
12 DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
THE ONLY SPF PLAYER OF THE YEAR
WITH THREE FORCED FUMBLES AND
TWO INTERCEPTIONS.
AND HE STUDIES TAPE.
A SAFETY FOR THE TEXANS HERE,
CONNOR.
HOW DOES THE VALUE STACK UP?
>> FOR AN OVERALL PLAYER AND
SECOND ROUND, GREAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT PETRI HE
REMINDS ME OF JORDAN WHITEHEAD
WHO JUST GOT A LOT OF MONEY TO
THE NEW YORK JETS.
HIS PHYSICAL, HE CAN PLAY IN
THE SLOT IN THE BOX.
HIS BACK GOOD RANGE AND SPEED.
HE GETS TO THE SENIOR BOWL AND
HE WAS THE BEST SAFETY AND
COVERAGE.
HE IS GOOD MAKING A PLAY ON THE
FOOTBALL.
HE HITS LIKE A TON OF BRICKS.
I LIKE JALEN PG A LOT.
THIS IS A FOOTBALL TEAM WHO
LOST JUSTIN REID TO KANSAS
CITY.
WHEN YOU LOSE JUSTIN REID THIS
IS YOUR FOR SUREFIRE.
I'M A BIG PETRI FAN.
THIS IS A LETTER A- FOR ME.
I THINK HE WILL HAVE A GOOD
CAREER.
>> YOU FIST PUMP.
WHY?
>> . IT'S A QUESTION.
HE PLAYED IN THE BIG 12 PASS
HAPPY AND ABLE TO COVER.
I LOVE THE WAY HE STICKS THE
GUYS.
I LOVE THE WAY HE SHOOTS.
HE WILL SHOOT THE GAP TO THE
PLATE WITH THE SCREEN GAME AND
CHECKING ZONE, HE WILL COME
DOWN AND DESTROY.
THE HEAD ON MIMS FROM OKLAHOMA
WAS A NIGHTMARE KILL SHOT.
I HAVE TO GIVE IT AND A. I LOVE
THE WAY HE PLAYS.
>> LOVIE SMITH HOLDING OUT THE
SECONDARY THE EXTREMELY EARLY
ON, NO JAY LEE PETRI.
LET'S ASK OUR SECONDARY
SPECIALISTS, RICHARD SHERMAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
SAFETY, PETRI?
>> I THINK IT IS JUST WHAT YOU
SAID.
A CARBON COPY OF JORDAN
WHITEHEAD.
HE PLAYS FAST.
I'D LIKE WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THEY HAD ONE OF THE WORST PAST
EVENTS.
THEY ARE STRESSING THAT EARLY
AND OFTEN TO GET TO LEARN.
IF THEY WIN A FEW GAMES I DON'T
THINK THEY ARE EXPECTING TO
WIN.
THESE ARE CORNERSTONE PIECES
AND HE WILL DO A GREAT JOB
REPLACING WHAT JUSTIN REID
COULD DO.
YOU HAVE A HARD TIME REPLACING
THAT LEADERSHIP.
DRAFTING A CORNER WITH THE
NUMBER ONE PICK WITH STINGLEY
AND A SAFETY TO GROW TOGETHER
IS THE BEST THING YOU COULD DO
WITH THE SECONDARY.
>> IN 2021, THANK YOU RICHARD
SHERMAN, JALEN PG PLAYED 431
COVERAGE SNAPS.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY PENALTIES
HE'S HAD?
0. THAT'S PRETTY DARN
IMPRESSIVE JOINING THE TEXANS
ON LOVIE SMITH.
THE GIANT TRAY DOWN AGAIN.
THE FALCONS MOVE OUT FROM 43 TO
38.
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS THE
FALCONS FELT THE NEED TO JUMP
THE SEAHAWKS.
BECAUSE THE SEAHAWKS ARE
SITTING THERE WITH TWO.
WE TALKED ABOUT MAYBE THIS IS A
QUARTERBACK AND MAYBE THE
FALCONS WANT TO DO THIS FOR
BOTH OF THOSE TEAMS HAVE
OFFENSES IN WHICH THEY LIKE
MOBILITY AT THE QUARTERBACK
POSITION ARTHUR SMITH AND WHAT
PETE KELICH HAS BEEN DOING.
I HYPED IT UP.
IT IS ARNOLD.
>> DYNAMITE PICK OF THE
SELECTION.
>> THE FALCONS PLAY UP TO GET
THE SECOND TEAM ALL-AMERICAN.
RECIPIENT OF THE 2021 IRON LION
AWARD FOR STRENGTH-AND-
CONDITIONING COACH.
ADDED TACKLE FOR A LOSS AND ALL
THAT ONE GAME.
WHAT ARE THEY GETTING?
>> A COMPACT STANDUP SPEED
PRESSURE.
YOU CAN CROSS YOUR FACE, INSIDE
AND FLATTEN INTO THE POCKET.
HE IS STRONG, STOUT AND
EXPLOSIVE.
THE TESTING METRICS GOT HIM
OVER THE HUMP.
HE WAS A TEMPLE PLAYER.
TRANSFERS TO PENN STATE.
WE KNOW WHAT EVERYONE DOES IN
THAT PROGRAM.
HE HAD STRENGTH TO DRIVE
TACKLES BACK INTO THE POCKET
AND HE HAS ENOUGH QUICKNESS.
YOU SEE THE TESTING NUMBER 6-9-
3 COHEN.
30-INCH VERTICAL FOR
EXPLOSIVENESS IS AN EXCELLENT
NUMBER.
FREAKISH.
LONG ARMS HELP HIM WIN.
I LOVE HIM.
HE IS A TOP 30 PLAYER FOR ME.
THIS FALCONS TEAM IS A A FOR
ME.
>> IT IS INTERESTING THAT THE
TWO TEAMS JOHN ABRAHAM TED IS
THE JETS AND THE FALCONS.
>> AND NO ONE DID ANYTHING
AGAIN AFTER THAT.
>> WHEN YOU MENTIONED JONATHAN,
I SEE A LITTLE BIT OF A POOR
MAN'S PERSON.
I THINK HIS HANDS ARE HEAVY.
HE'S GOT THESE HEAVY AND OF
STONE.
>> HE JUST CLUBS PEOPLE?
>> HEAVYWEIGHT FIGHTER.
>> THAT'S WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE FOR ME.
HE IS SO STRONG PHYSICALLY HE
WILL MAKE YOU TIRED.
YOU AREN'T GOING TO WANT TO
BLOCK HIM OR TO HAVE HIM PUT
HIS PAWS ON YOU.
WHETHER HE IS TACKLING YOU, YOU
DON'T WANT HIM LAYING ON YOU
ALL THE TIME AFTER HE TACKLES
GET THAT FULL EXTENSION WHEN
YOU ARE AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
HIS GOT THE ABILITY TO DO ALL
THESE THINGS.
THIS IS A A PICK.
HE IS GOING TO BE SPECIAL AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
IF YOU'RE THE FALCONS YOU HAVE
A WAY TO GET TO THE
QUARTERBACK.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE STOOD
UP AT PENN STATE.
IF IT'S ME, LET ME PUT HIS HAND
ON THE GROUND AND GO GET THAT
QUARTERBACK.
>> PICK-SIX, 250.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT WAS LAST
AND SACKS IN THE NFL.
THEY HAD 18.
THEY WERE 11 FEWER THAN THE
TEAM IN 30 FIRST.
>> THAT IS TERRIFYING, MAN.
BACK THERE WERE 19 TEAMS IN THE
NFL WHO HAD TWICE AS MANY SACKS
AS THE FALCONS.
THEY GET THE BIGGEST WIDE
RECEIVER AND A GOOD PRESSURE ON
THE OUTSIDE WITH HEAVY HANDS
WITH ARNOLD EARLEY KATIE.
THEY SCOOPED UP MORE PICKS.
CONNOR HUGHES NO RELATION TO
CONNOR ROGERS.
GETTING ATTACKS.
BEST RUNNING BACK IN THE DRAFT
TALKING ABOUT THE GUYS YOU GUYS
TOOK, BREECE HALL.
39 HIS CHICAGO BEARS.
THEY HAVE YET TO DRAFT.
THIS IS THE FIRST PICK IN THE
DRAFT.
OF COURSE, THEY GIVE UP THE
FIRST ROUND PICK TO THE GIANTS
LAST YEAR IN ORDER TO GET
JUSTIN FIELDS.
FIRST TIME SEEING HIM.
FIRST TIME WITH THE NEW GM.
RYAN POLES, NEW HEAD COACH.
MAGGIE BARE FOODS HAVE YOU
HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT THIS TEAM?
>> OBVIOUSLY A GREAT JOB.
GROWING BEHIND THE SCENES IN
KANSAS CITY AND NOW HE HAS HIS
SHOT.
YOU WILL BUILD IN THE FRONT
CENTERS.
LET'S SEE WHERE THEY ARE GOING
HERE.
>> KYLER GORDON.
>> THE OFFENSIVE LINEMAN, THAT
LINE IS TERRIFYING RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU THOUGHT THEY WOULD GO
BIGGER.
>> THEY ARE GOING WITH A
CORNERBACK.
THE FIRST PICK GO WITH THE
FIRST TEAM ALL PACKED CORNER
OUT OF WASHINGTON, KYLER GORDON
WITH THE 4-5-2. ZERO PENALTIES
THE LAST TWO PENALTIES.
A LOT OF SNAPS.
A CHILDHOOD BACKGROUND IN
DANCING AND KUNG FU.
JUST WANTED TO GET THAT IN
THERE.
CONNOR, WHERE DID YOU EXPECT
HIM TO GO?
>> RIGHT AROUND HERE.
42.
HE WILL BE A NICE CLEAR FOR THE
CHICAGO BEARS.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
OFFENSIVE NEEDS AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF JUSTIN FIELDS
RIGHT NOW.
IT DOES NOT LOOK GOOD ON PAPER.
LET'S MAKE THIS KYLER GORDON'S
MOMENT.
HE'S GOT A LITTLE MORE LENGTH
WITH EXCELLENT BALL SKILLS.
HE FLASHED A LOT AND PLAYED A
LOT OF ZONE AS WELL.
HE CAN GET HANDS ON YOU.
HE CAN TURN AND RUN DOWN THE
FIELD.
HE HAS VERY GOOD SWITCH.
HE HAS GOOD AGILITY.
THE INSTINCTS ARE CATCHING UP
HE'S NOT ON THE SAME LEVEL AS
MCDUFFIE IN TERMS OF INSTINCTS.
STYLISTICALLY HE REMINDS ME OF
CASEY HAYWARD, A TOP FLIGHT
ZONE AND GET DOWNHILL FINDS A
FOOTBALL KIND OF PLAYER
ATHLETICALLY.
HE IS IMPRESSIVE.
THE 1 YEAR STARTER AND IT WILL
TAKE A WHILE TO GET GOING.
I GO WITH A 8 MINUS.
TWO YEARS FROM NOW HE WILL BE
GOOD.
>> HE WAS ABLE TO DEVELOP
PLAYERS.
IS HE A FELDER GUIDE?
>> HE IS NOT A FELDER GUIDE
EXPECT THAT'S HOW I JUST
LEARNED.
>> I LIKE HIM IN HIS OWN BETTER
THAN MAN.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT HE CAN
COME OFF AND THE THING I LIKE
THE MOST ABOUT HIM IS HE CAN
SEE THROUGH THE RECEIVER AND
SEE THROUGH THE ZONE AND HE
MATCHES AND CAN COME OFF AND
MAKE A TACKLE.
I'M GOING WITH ALL P PLUS HERE.
AS YOU FIT HIM IN THIS GAME
THAT'S WHEN HE CAN GROW.
THE IDEA IS WHERE DO YOU PLAY.
HE HAS NOT PLAYED AS MUCH
FOOTBALL AS THE OTHER CORNERS
WE HAVE SEEN.
>> A ONE YOUR STARTER WILL TAKE
A BIT.
>> SHERMAN, WHAT DO YOU THINK
WHEN YOU HEAR A GUY WITH NOT A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE BUT WHAT DO
YOU THINK HE WILL BE ASKED TO
DO WITH THE CHICAGO BEARS
DEFENSE?
>> I'M EXCITED.
HE WORKED AT THE FACILITY.
BOBBY AND OTHER NFL GUYS HAVE
WORKED OFF AT.
HE'S A HECK OF A PLAYER AND
COMPETITIVE.
WHEN THERE WAS COVID-19 WE WERE
OUT THERE HOLDING SEVEN ON
SEVEN PULLING HIS OWN WITH NFL
PLAYERS, JOSH ORTON AND D.K.
METCALF AND COVERING GUYS LIKE
THAT THIS IS WHEN HE WAS
YOUNGER AND THE FRESHMAN.
I EXPECT HIM TO HAVE A LOT OF
SUCCESS.
IT'S A GUY WHO WORKS HARD AND
IS SMART HE WILL FIT WELL BE A
GOOD PLAYER IN THE FUTURE.
>> LET'S GO TO MORE INSIGHT,
GENTRY.
APPARENTLY, YOU FACED THIS GUY.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE PACING KYLER
GORDON.
>> I REMEMBER PLAYING HIM MY
SOPHOMORE YEAR IN COLLEGE.
HE WAS A YOUNG PLAYER.
LAST YEAR WAS HIS FIRST YEAR
STARTING IN ONE WE PLAYED HIM
HE WAS ROTATING IN AND OUT.
YOU WATCH THE TAPE.
HE IS IN THERE MAKING PLAYS.
HE TACKLED ME PRETTY WELL.
THAT IS ONE THING I SAID.
HE IS NOT AFRAID OF PUTTING HIS
HEAD IN THERE.
EVERYONE WANTS A DB THAT CAN
STICK HIS HEAD IN THERE AND
MAKE A TACKLE.
>> THAT IS GREAT INSIGHT.
WE LEARNED ABOUT AUSSIES AND
PRACTICING FROM RICHARD SHERMAN
AND HE HIT AHMAD ST. BROWN WELL
ENOUGH THAT YOU REMEMBER IT.
WE REMEMBER PEOPLE TACKLE AS
WELL.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A GOOD IDENTITY
MATCH BETWEEN HIM AND THE
CHICAGO BEARS.
YOU HAVE TO THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST PICK FORMAT.
I KNOW WE WANT TO TURN AROUND
THIS OFFENSE BUT I NEED MY
IDENTITY AND I'M A DEFENSIVE
GUY AND I NEED MY WEAPONS.
WE WILL LET LUKE FIGURE OUT THE
OFFENSE.
NOW BACK TO BACK PICKS.
SEE A CHANCE FOR MALIK WILLIS.
THEY MAY MAKE US WAKE FOR THE
SECOND ONE.
THEY HAVE NOT ANNOUNCED THE
BEARS PICKED ON TV YET BUT WE
ARE STILL AHEAD.
NAKOBE DEAN HAS NOT BEEN TAKEN.
ANDREW BOOTH HAS NOT BEEN
TAKEN.
AND I MENTIONED MALIK WILLIS.
CONNOR, WHAT ARE WE THINKING
HERE?
>> THIS IS WHERE YOU THROW THAT
DART YOU ARE PLAYING WITH HOUSE
MONEY FOR YOU COULD STILL GET
SOMETHING THAT IS MORE SUREFIRE
OUT OF THE SECOND ROUND AND IF
THEY REALLY WANT TO GO CRAZY IN
THE FENCE YOU STILL HAVE
RAYMOND ON THE BOARD.
THAT IS AN OFFENSIVE LINE THAT
HAS NEEDED A LOT OF LONG TURN
WORK.
ANDREW WHITWORTH SHOULD BE IN
PLAY IN THE SPOT.
THEY NEED TO PASS RUSHER AS
WELL.
I WOULD NOT SLEEP ON MOWING A
MATE, THE TYPE OF PLAYER THAT
THEY LIKE TO TAKE.
>> FELDNER I WANT YOU TO CHIME
IN BUT LET'S LOOK AT SEATTLE
SEAHAWKS AND WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
SAY DADDY, IF WE SHOULD TAKE
MALEIC?
I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE RIDING
DADDY.
PEOPLE WANT BLEAK.
THEY ARE NOT THAT COMFORTABLE
GOING IN WITH DREW LOCK.
YOU COULD GO CORNER, TRE BROWN
AND IS SEE ENDING KNEE INJURY.
OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> I THINK ANDREW BOOTH FOR
CORNER MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
I WAS GOING TO ASK ABOUT MATT
CORRAL.
AS WE GET DEEPER INTO THE DRAFT
NOW WE START TO SEE WHAT DOES
VALUE NEED MEAN TO YOU.
WOULD YOU HAVE A HEALTHY MALIK
WILLIS?
>> HE HAS THE BODY TYPE TO BE
AN EFFECTIVE LEVEL1.
THEY BOTH HAVE GREAT ARMS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT FRAME IS
GOING TO HOLD UP IN THE NFL AS
A RUNNER.
I JUST PREFER MALEIC.
>> I JUST WANTED TO GET THAT IN
THERE.
AS IT GETS LOWER AND LOWER WE
START TO SEE TEAMS WHO ARE
EYEBALLING CORRAL AND IT WAS
NOW WILLIS VERSUS CORRAL.
>> YOU TALKED ABOUT OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN, ARE THERE ANY LYMAN
LEFT THAT ARE STILL AT A
CERTAIN TIER THAT MIGHT
EVAPORATE?
HIM JURGENS SOMEONE YOU HAVE TO
GET.
CAMERON JURGENS IS THE CENTER
THAT OKAY GET HIM OR YOU ARE
LOOKING AT A WAY DIFFERENT
FIELD.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY JABARI
TOREY.
TRE MORRIS SORRY IS THE REASON
WHY THEY WON THE GAME.
JABARI SORRY STARTED AT LEFT
CAPITAL THAT SAID WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING WITH THIS ALABAMA
DEFENSIVE FRONT.
THEY MOVED HIM INTO GUARD AND
THAT LONG COOK IS BECAUSE
JABARI SAWYER.
I THINK HE IS A GUY HIGH ON
FULL SPORT BECAUSE HE IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO BE AN
INSIDE GUIDE.
40 IS THE ONE THAT GOT FOR
RUSSELL WILSON.
THIS IS A NEW IDENTITY FOR THE
SEATTLE SEAHAWKS FINISHING 7-10
AND I CAN'T REMEMBER THE LAST
TIME THEY FINISHED FOURTH IN
THE NFC WEST THE NFC WEST IS
OPEN.
I FEEL LIKE TYLER IS HAPPY NOW
BECAUSE NOW HE HAS HOLLYWOOD
BROWN IN THAT STORY LINE MIGHT
BE FADING OFF.
THE NINERS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
IS IT JIMMY G. WILL THEY GIVE
IT FULLY TO TREY LANCE.
WHAT IS GOING ON WITH DEBO.
THIS SEEMS TO BE UNREST THERE.
YOU LOOK AT THE SEAHAWKS AND
THE RAMS OF THE SUPER BOWL
CHAMPIONS.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THEM GET HURT
THEY ARE A GOOD TEAM BUT THEY
HAVE A LOT OF HOLES.
A LOT OF GUYS LEFT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT ROSTER.
THE WEST WAS THE CLASS OF THE
NFL AND I THINK IT'S FALLEN OFF
IN A HUGE WAY.
>> I AGREE WITH YOUR
REGRESSION.
WITH THE WEST.
MY NUMBER ONE QUESTION WITH
SEATTLE.
I CAN'T ANSWER.
ARE THEY WITH THE OLDEST COACH
IN THE NFL WITH EACH CAROL?
ARE THEY THE OLDEST TEAM IN THE
NFL?
THEY HAVE NOT TRADED D.K.
METCALF, THEY TOOK CHARLES
CROSS.
I LOVED THAT PICTURE.
IS THIS ANOTHER OFFENSIVE LINE.
? ARE THEY BUILDING A
FOUNDATION FOR THE NEXT
QUARTERBACK IS THIS GOING TO
TAKE THE BEST PLAYER, BOY A
MATE, OR THEY CAN GRAB DAVID A
JOB WELL.
THIS SHOULD TEACH US ABOUT
SEATTLE AND WHAT THEY THINK.
>> WHERE THEY THINK THEY ARE.
IF YOU GET SOMEONE THAT CAN
PLAY RIGHT NOW IT FEELS LIKE
THEY ARE IN WIN MODE NOW.
>> TRADING RUSSELL WILSON MEANS
YOU ARE NOT.
YOU DON'T TRADE RUSSELL WILSON.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO REBUILD
YOU TRADE RUSSELL WILSON.
CAN RICHARD COMMENT ON THIS?
IS HE AVAILABLE?
>> YEAH.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, MAN?
WHERE DO YOU THINK RECEIVE
HAWKS ARE IN TERMS OF A
FRANCHISE?
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE IN
WHEN NOW MODE.
I THINK THEY ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE QUARTERBACKS
COMING OUT NEXT YEAR AND THAT'S
WHERE THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR
FOCUS.
I DON'T THINK YOU TRADE YOUR
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK AWAY AND
SAY HEY, WE HAVE DREW LOCK.
WE ARE GOING TO GO AFTER HIM.
YOU LET DUANE AROUND WALK YOU
DRAFTED A ROOKIE.
HE NEEDS DEVELOPMENT AND IS A
HARD LEARNING CURVE.
THE PASS RUSHERS ARE GOING TO
MAKE IT HARD LEARNING CURVE.
YOU STILL HAVE BOTH SOFT AND
AARON DONALD.
AND LEONARD FLOYD.
I THINK THE PIECES THEY WILL
DRAFT WILL SHOW YOU THAT EVEN
IF THEY DRAFT A QUARTERBACK.
THEY DON'T EXPECT YOU TO PLAY
NOW.
I EXPECT TO QUARTERBACK RUN
NEXT YEAR ALL IN FOR A
QUARTERBACK NEXT YEAR EXPECT
THE PICKS ARE IN AND LET'S DO
IT.
OH, THERE IS THE GUY.
A LOT OF FRONT OFFICES HAVE
THIS IS A JOHN SCHNEIDER KIND
OF GUY ATHLETICALLY AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE PRODUCTION IS
KIND OF THE SAME STORY AS TRE
BROWN WALKER.
HE IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PLAYER BUT HE DIDN'T HAVE A
BREAKOUT MONSTER DOUBLE-DIGIT.
WHY HE WAS THE 30 FIRST OVERALL
PLAYER FOR ME, BOYE MAFE, CAME
IN WITH HIGH EXPECTATIONS AND
HE'S GOING TO NEED TIME BUT
ATHLETICALLY WE THINK IT'S ALL
THERE AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT
LIGHT TURN ON WITH STAFF AND
BOARD.
BOYE MAFE NEEDS SOME SEASONING
AND GOOD VALUE FOR SEATTLE.
THEY HAVE HAD TWO GREAT PICKS.
A.
>> RUNNING ON 1-5-3 SHORT
SPLIT.
>> I LOVE EVEN THE SHORT CLIP.
HE IS PATIENT WITH HIS FEET AND
INSTANT EXPLOSION SIDE TO SIDE
TO GET TO THE QUARTERBACK AFTER
THE PLAY.
HE HAS THE ABILITY TO DO ALL
THOSE THINGS.
BOYE MAFE PLAYED IN MINNESOTA.
EXPLOSIVE OFF THE EDGE.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE THAT TEND
YARD SPLIT COMING.
DON'T WORRY, I CAN DISENGAGE
AND GET BACK DOWNHILL TO MAKE A
PLAY.
FOR SMOOTH DOESN'T WORK, I KEEP
GOING.
JUMPED DOWN INSIDE ON A SLED.
HE CAN DO THAT AS WELL.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE AND HE IS SOMEONE THAT
WILL GIVE YOU HIS EFFORT ALL
THE TIME AND PLACE FOR A SCHOOL
WHERE A LOT OF FOLKS WERE
CHUCKY FOR THE DEFENSE AND WERE
CHECKING FOR WHAT THEY ARE ABLE
TO DO AND CAN SEND INSTANT.
THE BIG KEY WITH HIM AND I WILL
GIVE THIS A BE PLUS BECAUSE OF
THE VALUE FOR THE PICK.
THE ONLY THING GOING ALL THE
WAY TO AND A, AS RICHARD SAID,
IF THEY ARE NOT IN WIN NOW MODE
LET'S GET THE MORE EXPLOSIVE
GUY IF NEXT YEAR IS THE GUY.
>> MAYBE THEY GO BACK TO BACK.
>> OVER THEN OCHO NWOSU.
HE IS A BIG SACK GUY THEY ONLY
HAD 34 SACKS LAST YEAR WHICH IS
BOTTOM 10 IN THE NFL.
THIS IS A TEAM.
THEY LOST SO MANY IDENTITY
PIECES NOT JUST RUSSELL WILSON
ON OFFENSE, KENNETH WALKER IS
THE SECOND PERIOD.
>> PETE CARROLL, ULTIMATE PEAK
PICK RIGHT HERE.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
IDENTITY IT'S A RUNNING BACK
GOING TO THE SEATTLE SEAHAWKS.
>> Reporter: WALKER LED FPS
WITH 89 FORCE MISSED TACKLES
AND YARDS AFTER CATCH.
ONLY TWO CAREER FUMBLES IN HIS
ENTIRE CAREER AT MICHIGAN STATE
AND ONLY 19 CATCHES THIS
RUNNING BACK HERE, WHAT DO YOU
THINK FOR THE SEAHAWKS?
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS MUCH
IN THE PAST GAME.
THAT'S BEEN PROVEN.
AS A PURE RUNNER HIS RIGHT AT
THE TOP OF HIS CLASS.
TACKLE BREAKER, SHIFTY.
PLAYER COMPARISON WITH DEANGELO
WILLIAMS.
LITTLE SURPRISED SEATTLE FELT
THE NEED TO GO RUNNING BACK.
I HAD OTHER NEEDS.
I HAD THREE TOP 50 PICKS 53, I
GO WITH A B- HERE.
KENNEDI WALKER IS A GREAT
RUNNER BUT I DON'T LIKE WHAT
THE DRAFT IS IN THIS PICK AFTER
GREAT.
WITH BOYE MAFE.
>> I LOVE HIM.
HE GOT INTO AN OFFENSE THAT WAS
MORE CONDUCIVE TO WHAT HE CAN
DO.
HE IS A TOUCHDOWN MACHINE AND
EITHER SCHOOL.
MY WIFE WENT TO MICHIGAN STATE
SO I'M GIVING IT IN A.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> COULD CURVE.
>> THE THING THAT MIGHT BE
INTERESTING IS RASHAAD PENNY
AND RICH CARSON WILL BE FREE
AGENTS AFTER THIS YEAR.
I HEARD, RICHARD SHERMAN, YOU
WERE EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT
THIS.
WHY?
>> I AM BECAUSE THIS IS P. IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A RUN FIRST PLAY
DEFENSE PHILOSOPHY AND THAT'S
WHERE HE WILL LEAN THIS YEAR.
YOU WILL SEE.
EVERYONE KILLED THEM ON THE
RASHAAD PENNY PICK YEARS AGO
AND THIS YEAR HE BLOSSOMED.
HE WAS RUNNING THE HECK OUT OF
THE BALL.
HE HAD FOUR OR 5150 PLUS GUARD
GAINS.
THEY WILL EXPAND ON THAT AND
PUSH THEIR STABLE OF BACKS THIS
ENTIRE SEASON.
THEY WILL KEEP THE BALL WITH
THEIR QUARTERBACK AND ALLOW THE
DEFENSE AND THE RUN GAME TO
SHORTEN THE GAME AND SNEAK OUT
SOME WINS.
THAT WAS THE PHILOSOPHY IN THE
SUPER BOWL.
WE RUN WITH MARSHAWN LYNCH PLAY
GREAT DEFENSE AND THE
QUARTERBACKS DON'T TURN THE
BALL OVER.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS TRYING TO
BUILD AGAIN.
>> YOU MIGHT BE ONTO SOMETHING.
THEY DID MISS A LOT OF GAMES
FROM THE RUNNING BACKS AND THEY
HAVE THAT STABLE.
CHRIS CARSON, RASHAAD PENNY,
TRAVIS HOMER'S AND DEEJAY
DALLAS' THERE AND NOW KENNETH
WALKER.
WHERE YOU THINK, CONOR, KENNETH
WALKER WILL RANK IN THAT ROOM?
RIGHT WITH WHEN THEY GO OUT AND
LOOK AT HIM.
>> HE IS THE BEST PURE RUNNER.
YOUNG LEGS.
LOWER BODY.
GOOD SHORT AREA.
HE NEEDS TIME AND SEASONING ON
THIRD DOWN.
NOT SEEING THE FIELD AS A PASS
CATCHER.
HE WOULD BE THE GUY BY THE
SECOND HALF OF THE YEAR.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT DAVIS
BEING A TWO DOWN DEFENSIVE
LINEMAN YOU ARE ALMOST
SIGNALING TO THE DEFENSE WHAT
YOU ARE DOING HERE.
>> HOW HARD WOULD IT BE TO GET
HIM IN THE GAME?
>> I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE SEAHAWKS DEFENSIVE DEPTH
CHART TO REALIZE HOW MANY OTHER
POSITIONS THEY HAD TO ADDRESS
AND LOOKING AT THE OFFENSE AND
I GUESS RICHARD IS RIGHT.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO THE
QUARTERBACK HERE AND THEY WILL
COMPLETELY PUNT AND IT WILL BE
A GENO SMITH, DREW LOCK, OFF-
SEASON BATTLE.
WE ARE GETTING TO ONE OF THE
BEST GYMS IN THE BATTLE.
CHRIS BOWERS PICKING HERE AND
42.
IT'S THE FIRST.
>> AN INTERESTING BECAUSE THEY
HAVE AN OFF-SEASON IN WHICH
THEY GOT MATT RYAN.
SITE.
THE VIKINGS HAVE TRADED UP.
REMEMBER.
THEY TRADED BACK FROM 34 WITH
GREEN BAY AND THEY TOOK 53 AND
59.
AND NOW THEY MOVE UP TO 42 WITH
INDY.
WHAT WERE YOU SAYING?
>> THEY MOVED THREE OR FOUR
TIMES.
SOUF MENSAH IS HAVING HIS FUN
RIGHT HERE.
>> WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT PICKS
THEY GAVE UP.
WE ARE WAITING TO SEE WHICH WAY
THEY GO.
MINNESOTA ENDING THE FIRST
ROUND BY GOING WITH LEUCINE,
THE SAFETY OUT OF GEORGIA.
NOW THEY MAYBE NEED SOME
INTERIOR DEFENSIVE LINEMAN,
POSSIBLY NEEDING A CORNERBACK
IN ADDITION TO THAT SAFETY.
WHERE ARE YOU THINKING THEY
COULD GO HERE?
>> QUIETLY WHAT PEOPLE MISS
WITH MINNESOTA IS THEY DO NEED
A RECEIVER.
JEFFERSON IS A START.
ADAM HAS BEEN GETTING INJURIES.
I LIKE SKAI MOORE WITH THEM A
LOT.
THIS IS WHERE YOU HAVE GEORGE
PICKENS COME INTO PLAY.
SKYY MOORE WOULD BE THE ONE.
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE IT ENOUGH I
WOULD NOT RULE OUT A CORNERBACK
SELECTION, EVEN WITH CURT
COUSINS ON THE MONEY RIGHT NOW.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> MOST INTRIGUING ONE FOR ME
AND I TALKED ABOUT HIM PLENTY
OF TIMES.
I LIKE HIM.
IF HE COMES OFF THE BOARD, THE
IDEA OF HAVING DICKENS AND
JEFFERSON AS THEY AGE OUT IS
TERRIFYING.
BOTH OF THOSE GUYS CAN GO UP
AND GET THE BALL.
>> WE HAVE A PICK AND IT'S
GOING TO BE ANDREW BOOTH, THE
CORNERBACK OF CLEMSON THAT WE
THOUGHT COULD GO IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
HE GOES HERE TO THE MINNESOTA
VIKINGS AT 42.
FIRST TEAM ALL ACC, 35 GAMES,
15 STARTS.
WAS THE NUMBER TWO CORNERBACK
IN THE 2019 HOOTING CLASS
BEHIND DEREK STINGLEY AND ONLY
PENALIZE ONE TIME IN THREE
YEARS TO GET HIM HERE AT 42.
>> I LIKE HIM.
FIFTIETH OVERALL.
WE SAW McCREARY AND GORDON
CAUGHT THE BOARD HE HAS NOT
BEEN ABLE TO WORK OUT DURING
THE DRAFT PROCESS WHERE.
>> HE HASN'T BEEN ABLE TO WORK
OUT BECAUSE OF A HAMMY.
>> SECOND ROUND GRADE.
A LITTLE OVER AGGRESSIVE AT
TIMES.
THERE ARE TIMES HE IS SO JACKED
UP HE MISSES TACKLES.
CARLTON DAVIS LIGHT.
DAVIS IS A GOOD PLAYER.
ROCKSOLID IN THE B.
>> I LOVE HIM.
THIS IS A GUY WE SAW HIM SHOOT
DOWN JAMES COOK AND THAT
CLEMSON GAME.
GET THE BALL OUT AND DO THE
THINGS YOU WANT TO DO AND YOU
SEE HIM PLAYING COVERAGE IN THE
BACK OF  THE.
HE ASKED CLEMSON TO PLAY COVER,
COVER ONE, COVER TWO,
COMMITTED,, REPORT.
HE DOES NOT FIT INTO THE MOLD
WE TALKED ABOUT.
HE IS A MAN CORNER.
HE IS ASSUMED CORNER.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A ARE A
AND HE IS A FIRST ROUND TALENT
YOU CAN GET LATER.
>> I LOOK AT THE ROSTER AND
NONE OF THEM ARE THERE.
THEY GO SECONDARY WITH BOTH
PICKS.
CHEM ANDREW BOOTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
DEFENSE.
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIM AS
A PLAYER?
WHO ARE THEY GETTING HERE?
>> THEY ARE GETTING A GUY WHO
IS INTELLIGENT AND MAKE PLAYS
AND TAKE THE BALL AWAY.
ANYTIME YOU FACE AARON RODGERS
YOU NEED THAT.
CHICAGO WILL FIND A WAY TO BE
COMPETITIVE AND I THINK YOU
NEED CORNERS AND DB AND THAT'S
WHY THEY WENT DB WITH THE FIRST
TWO PICKS.
THEY HAVE NOT HAD A REALLY
CONSISTENT PRO BALL ALL STYLE
STROKE CORNER SINCE ROADS LEFT
YEARS AGO.
HE WAS THE MOST CONSISTENT.
YOU ARE COMPETING WITH MEGATRON
AND SAY ADAMS.
HE CAN BE THAT KIND OF PLAY FOR
THEM IF THEY BUILD AROUND HIM.
THEM ALLOWING DRAFTING SAFETY
AT THE SAME TIME AND HAVING
HARRISON SMITH THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO GROW TOGETHER THAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO BUILD A SECONDARY.
ALLOW THEM TO THRIVE TOGETHER
AND MAKE MISTAKES TOGETHER AND
REALIZE WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF.
>> HARRISON SMITH RINGS ALONG
LEUCINE AND PATRICK PETE WILL
BRING ALONG ANDREW BRUCE,
RICHARD SHERMAN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU TO OUR SPONSOR OR
DRAFT COVERAGE FOR 25 ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR AN EDGE
IN THE HOME BUYING MORTGAGE
WITH ROCKET MORTGAGE.
VERIFIED APPROVAL CAN HELP YOU
COMPETE.
GIVE YOU THE EDGE YOU NEED AND
THAT IS ROCKET MORTGAGE AND WE
WANT THE THANK THEM FOR
SPONSORING A DRAFT COVERAGE BUT
FINALLY WE SEE THE NEW YORK
GIANTS.
DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING FOR ME?
>> WAN'DALE ROBINSON.
NOT FULLY GADGET PLAYER.
A TRULY GADGET PLAYER OF THIS.
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK OF
THEM TRYING TO REMOVE KADARIUS
TONEY.
THIS IS A GUY THAT FITS INTO
THAT DO EVERYTHING ROLL.
IT'S WAN'DALE ROBINSON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
VALUE HERE?
>> I DON'T LOVE IT BUT THE
GIANTS HAVE HAD A KILLER DRAFT.
THIS TELLS ME THEY DON'T LIKE
DARIUS TONY BECAUSE HE PLAYS
THE SAME ROLE.
I COMPARED HIM TO OTHER GUYS.
HE CAN PLAY IN THE SLOT AND
MAKE THINGS HAPPEN.
I LOOKED AT THE GIANTS NOW AND
I WOULD'VE GONE WITH THE MORE
TRUE WIDE RECEIVER.
LIKE SKAI MOORE AND YOUR
CHICKENS.
I LIKE JEAN MACHI.
THIS IS A GADGET PLAYER.
HE IS EFFECTIVE AT FORCING
MIXED TACKLES I WILL GO WITH
THE C. THEY HAVE AN INTERESTING
WIDE RECEIVER.
>> ZERO PERCENTILE.
>> HIS ARMS ARE 27 5/EIGHT.
NO OTHER WIDE RECEIVER IN THE
STRATFORD ARMS SHOWN.
DID YOU WATCH A LOT OF KENTUCKY
THIS YEAR?
>> I WATCHED A LOT OF NEBRASKA
TOO.
100 CATCHES AT KENTUCKY.
THAT'S NOT THE BULK OF HIS
CAREER.
THE BULK OF HIS CAREER IS IN
NEBRASKA 51 CATCHES AND 46
RUSSIA'S IN HIS SOPHOMORE YEAR
AND WE GO TO THE FRESHMAN YEAR,
CAUGHT 88 BALLS AND 40 TOUCHES
AS A RUNNING BACK.
HE IS THE TRUE GADGET PLAYER OF
THIS DRAFT AND I REALLY LIKE
HIM.
>> YOU DO.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
I THINK HE'S GOT THE ABILITY TO
BE REALLY SKILLED I DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE MEASURE GOALS IN
TERMS OF LENGTH.
YOU FIND THE WAY TO GET THE
BALL IN HIS HANDS AND HE FINDS
A WAY TO MAKE PEOPLE MISS.
THE NUMBERS HE PUTS UP, ONE OF
THE SAVIORS, AND SCOTT FROST
FUMBLED THE BAG AND WANDEL TOOK
IT TO KENTUCKY.
I THINK THIS IS AN A. I DO NOT
CARE WHERE HE FITS IN TERMS OF
THE VALUE.
NO RESPECT.
I LOVE THIS GUY IS A PLAYER HE
IS A FOOTBALL PLAYER.
HE WILL GET THE JOB DONE.
SHE WILL PLAY IN THE SLOT.
HE WILL PLAY IN THE BACKFIELD
AS A RUNNING BACK IF YOU ASK
HIM TO.
TO ME HE'S A LITTLE LIKE PERCY
HARVARD.
HE WILL RUN INTO THE INTERIOR
WHICH IS WHAT HE DID FOR
NEBRASKA A LOT OF TIMES.
>> STERLING SHEPARD A FREE
AGENT.
THEY ISSUES WITH KADARIUS TONEY
MAKES SENSE.
YOU CAN DO SLAYTON DOWN THE
SIDE.
AHMAD ST. BROWN.
WAN'DALE ROBINSON.
THOUGHTS?
>> HE REMINDS ME OF A LESSER
TERAN JOHNSON IN COLLEGE.
NOT AS FAST AS I WATCHED HIS
TAPE EARLIER THIS MORNING.
WITH THE BALL IN HIS HANDS HE
IS MAKING GUYS MISS.
HE IS SPECIAL WITH THE BALL IN
HIS HANDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ELITE HE WILL
BE.
HIS EYES MIGHT HURT HIM A
LITTLE.
IF HE CAN GET THE BALL IN HIS
HANDS WITH A REVERSE ORDER
RETURN I THINK HE'S DANGEROUS
WITH THE BALL IN HIS HANDS.
>> HE IS ELECTRIC.
GIANTS GOING BACK TO THAT WELL.
IT'S NOT SITTING WELL.
WAN'DALE ROBINSON THE PICK FOR
THE GIANTS AT 43.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHAT HE IS FROM
STAFF THAT CAME FROM BUFFALO
WITH BRIAN ABEL?
THIS IS THEIR ISAIAH McKENZIE.
I AGREE WITH FELDNER AND AHMAD.
DO YOU TAKE HIM IN THE SECOND
ROUND?
I DON'T.
>> LOOKING AT MY BOARD MAYBE WE
CAN GET HIM LATER BECAUSE THE
GIANTS HAVE TRADED DOWN AND
THEY HAVE ACCUMULATED MORE
PICKS BUT THEY THOUGHT WE
NEEDED GOD THAT CAN RUN
REVERSES LIKE WE HAVE WITH
ISAIAH McKENZIE IN BUFFALO.
HE WOULD TOUCH THE BALL LIKE
FIVE OR SIX TIMES A GAME.
>> IT'S FREE HOURS FOR YOUR
QUARTERBACK EXPECT THEY ARE
MAKING LIFE EASY FOR DANIEL
JONES.
CLEVELAND BROWNS ARE UP AND
THIS IS THE CLEVELAND BROWNS
FOR.
>> THEY TRADED THREE FIRST
ROUND PICKS FOR DESHAUN WATSON.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
WITH BAKER MAYFIELD WITH 7
PICKS TOTAL.
THEY DO NEED A DEFENSIVE END UP
INSIDE MYLES TERRY.
THEY DEFINITELY NEED HELP AT
DEFENSIVE TACKLES.
THREE OF THE FOUR STARTERS NO
LONGER.
LUKE MCDONNELL EMILIE JACKSON
GONE AND YOU SAW WHAT LARRY
OGUNJOBI DID WHEN HE WENT TO
CINCINNATI.
IS THERE ANOTHER GUY THAT JUMPS
OUT?
>> THEY DID A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS RECEIVER CLASS.
IT WAS BEFORE THEY TRADED THEIR
FIRST ROUNDER AND I HEARD THEY
WERE ALL OVER JAMESON WILLIAMS.
DOES YOUR MIND GO TO SKAI
MOORE?
A 10-YARD SPLIT IS
ACCELERATION.
YOU KEEP SAYING IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE OUT THEY
HAVE AMARI COOPER BUT THEY WANT
MORE THE THING FOR ME, THEY'VE
GOT NEED AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
TRAVIS JONES.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT IS AN A+
FOR ME, FIRST ROUND PLAYER.
THERE IS ONLY THREE LEFT AND I
COMPARED HIM TO MARCELL DARIUS.
>> ANOTHER TRADE.
BROWN'S TRADING BACK WITH
HOUSTON.
HOUSTON WENT JALEN PEACHY AND
THEY STATED THEIR PICK AND IT
LOOKS LIKE HOUSTON IS MOVING UP
I DO NOT SEE ANY OTHER PICKS IN
THIS ROUND.
THEY MUST BE PACKAGING FUTURE
PICKS OR PICKS IN THE THIRD AND
FOURTH ROUND TO MOVE UP.
>> I HAVE A TRADE.
TEXAS TRADED 60, 108 AND THEY
ARE TAKING JEAN MACHI.
>> THE WIDE RECEIVER OUT OF
ALABAMA.
HOUSTON GETTING SOME SPEED
AFTER THEY WENT TWO SECONDARY
GUYS AND AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN,
JEAN MACHI.
>> IS KNOWING YOUR OLD FRIENDS
AND GETTING FRONT OF NEW
ENGLAND.
>> HOUSTON TEXANS TRADE UP AND
IS GOING TO BE JEAN MACHI THE
THIRD.
SECOND TEAM ALL SEC.
AVERAGE OVER 13 YARDS PER
CATCH.
NICK SABAN SAID THIS IS THE
EPITOME OF WHAT YOU LOOK FOR IN
A WIDE RECEIVER.
HE PLAYS HURTS AND PHYSICAL
PLAYS OPEN AND HE NEVER
COMPLAINS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS
WEAPON THEY GET FOR DAVIS
MILLS.
>> I COMPARED THEM TO EMMANUEL
SANDERS.
YOU HEAR A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
EMMANUEL SANDERS.
I LOVE JEAN MACHI.
AN EXPLOSIVE PLAYER.
UNDERSTAND SPACING ON THE
FIELD.
HE KNOWS HOW TO BEAT HIS
IMPEACHMENT COVERAGE.
I LIKED HIM AS A VALUE.
IN THIS DRAFT IN THE THIRD
ROUND.
I THOUGHT THE INJURY WOULD TAKE
HIM THERE.
IF YOUR ARTICLES CHECKED OUT
AND YOU BELIEVE HE WILL BE THE
PLAYER THAT HE IS AN EFFECTIVE
SECOND ROUND WIDE RECEIVER AND
A HIGH POSITION NUMBER TWO.
THIS IS A B+ FOR ME AND HE JUST
HAS TO GET HEALTHY.
>> IT'S NICO COLLINS WHO HAS
SHOWN SOME FASHIONS BUT HE CAN
PLAY VERY SOON.
HE DID HAVE MORE DROPS THAN I
BELIEVE TOUCHDOWN CATCHES.
DOES THAT WORRY YOU AT ALL?
>> HE WAS NOT A TOUCHDOWN GOD
FOR THEM.
THAT'S WHY THEY HAD JAMESON
WILLIAMS.
>> AND DEVONTA SMITH.
>> AND BRIAN ROBINSON.
HE WAS NOT THERE TOUCHDOWN BY.
HE IS A SET UP BY WHAT HE IS
ABLE TO DO IS FIND SPACE.
HE IS THE WIGGLE ROOM BY.
I THINK THIS IS AN A. YOU HAVE
TO SEE IF HE IS HEALTHY BUT I
THINK HE IS THE GUY AND WE
TALKED ABOUT HIM PRESHOW WITH
AHMAN ROSS TRE BROWN.
>> WHAT DO WE THINK?
IS HE GOING TO THE TEXANS, JEAN
MACHI?
>> I THINK JEAN MACHI IS ONE OF
THE MOST UNDERRATED PLAYERS.
IF HE FULLY RECOVERS HE DOES A
GREAT JOB FINDING SPACE.
IN THE SLOT I THINK HE WILL BE
THE MOST PRODUCTIVE IN THE NFL.
OBVIOUSLY, HE HAD A FEW DROPS.
HE WILL CATCH IT AND START AND
STOP ON A DIME, WHICH IS HUGE.
I THINK HE WILL BE GREAT AT THE
NEXT LEVEL.
>> IN TERMS OF FINDING OPEN
SPACE, DOES HIS INTELLIGENCE
READING AND DEFENSE POP OUT ON
FILM WHEN YOU ARE WATCHING HIM?
>> IT DEFINITELY DOES.
DIFFERENT ZONES.
COVERAGE TWO OR THREE.
IF HE IS TO THROTTLE THEM IN
THE WHOLE AND YOU WATCH THEM ON
CERTAIN SHALLOW ROUTES AND
SPEEDS ON.
HE POPS ON FILM THAT HE KNOWS
THE NAME TO SMART AND HE KNOWS
HOW TO FIND OPEN HOLES.
>> AHMAD ST. BROWN.
JEAN MACHI TRADING UP, THE
TEXANS GETTING AHEAD OF THE
PATRIOTS.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS SUCH A
SEAMLESS FIT.
IN THE BELICHICK RELATIONSHIP.
THEY DON'T DRAFT IN THE FIRST
ROUND BESIDES N'KEAL HARRY.
THEY COULD TAKE HIM IN THE
SECOND ROUND.
NICK CASERIO CAME FROM NEW
ENGLAND.
THE VALUES ARE DIFFERENT HAVING
HIM 72ND.
I LIKE THIS PLAYER.
IF HE DID NOT GET HURT HE WOULD
BEEN A LOT HIGHER.
>> BALTIMORE RATIONS ON THE
CLOCK AT KYLE HAMILTON AND
TRADED UP FOR TYLER LINDERBAUM.
>> IN SAME DRAFT.
>> THE STORY IS THEY TREATED
HOLLYWOOD BROWN, THAT IS
SOMETHING THE QUARTERBACK,
ESPECIALLY HOLLYWOOD BROWN HAS
SAID I'VE BEEN ASKING FOR A
TRADE AND I TOLD LAMAR ABOUT
IT, WHICH WAS VERY INTERESTING.
>> IT MAKES YOU WONDER.
I LOOK AT TRAVIS JONES.
HOW MUCH SHOULD WE TALK ABOUT
JORDAN DAVIS AND THE RAVENS.
THE BIGGEST HUMAN ON EARTH.
TRAVIS JONES 325 POUNDS AND RAN
A SUB 540.
IF JORDAN DAVIS WASN'T IN THIS
DRAFT THEY WOULD TALK ABOUT HOW
FREAKISH THAT COMBINE WAS.
>> I SAW TRAVIS JONES.
>> WE THOUGHT THE RAVENS WOULD
GET HIM LAST NIGHT?
>> WHEN THEY TOOK LINDBOHM AT
25 AND THEY DID NOT EVEN HAVE
TO TRADE UP AT 45.
IS THAT WHERE YOU PUT YOUR
MONEY RIGHT NOW EXPECT IT JUST
MAKES SO MUCH SENSE.
NAKOBE DEAN.
>> PATRICK QUEEN HAS STRUGGLED.
HE IS STILL DEVELOPING BUT THEY
ARE NOT COMFORTABLE WHERE HE IS
AT.
>> WILL LIST ALL OF LAST SEASON
AND THAT GOT HIP SURGERY THIS
TEAM SMITH WAS GOING TO SIGN
WITH AND BACKED OUT OF HER
VERBAL AGREEMENT AND WENT TO
THE VIKINGS.
>> THEY ARE THIN UPFRONT.
>> FOR A TEAM THAT PRIDES
ITSELF BEING GOOD.
KDAF AOA AND TOBIAS HOWARD
COMING OFF OF SEASON SURGERIES
AND THE GUYS BEHIND THEM,
FERGUSON AND HAYES HAVE ZERO.
ALEX CAMPBELL IS BACK BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH TIME COLEUS
CAMPBELL HAS.
THIS IS A TEAM, THEY DO NOT
HAVE A BIG DUDE UPFRONT, IT
DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THE BALTIMORE
RAVENS EXPECT WHEN DOES
BALTIMORE GET BULLIED AROUND
LIKE THAT?
TRAVIS JONES, WATCHING HIM IN
THE SENIOR BONE.
THAT CLUB MOVE.
HE SOMEONE YOU DON'T WANT TO
FIND YOURSELF ACROSS FROM
EXPECT WE HAVE THE PICK.
IT'S GOING TO BE DAVID OJABO.
>> AWESOME.
>> THEY GO FOR THE PASS RUSHER.
>> THEY HAVE TO BE PATIENT BUT
THAT'S OKAY.
>> DAVID OJABO AND 45.
FIRST TEAM ALL BIG TEN,
MICHIGAN RECORD 5 FIRST
FUMBLES.
ONLY PLAYED TWO SEASONS FOR A
HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL FOR ONLY
26 DEFENSIVE SNAPS IN HIS FIRST
TWO YEARS IN MICHIGAN AND THEN
EXPLODED.
WHAT IS THE VALUE?
>> THE FIRST ROUND PLAYER AND
THE BEST PLAYER LEFT ON MY
BOARD.
MY 18TH OVERALL PLAYER.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
INJURY.
GREAT ATHLETE.
HE'S GOT A SPIN MOVE AND HE IS
FUN TO WATCH.
HE MOVED FROM SCOTLAND TO NEW
JERSEY IN THE LONG ROAD TO
AMERICAN FOOTBALL.
WATCHING HIM AND AIDAN
HUTCHINSON WORK.
WHEN HE GETS THOSE ISOLATED
MATCHES FAST ON THE OUTSIDE
SHOULDER AND I THINK HE WILL
LEARN TO COUNTER RUSH INSIDE AS
WELL.
DAVID OJABO RAVES ABOUT THE
CHARACTER.
HE IS BILLED FOR DEVELOPMENT,
HARD WORKER IN THE WEIGHT ROOM.
BALTIMORE IS GOING TO LOVE THIS
GUY.
THIS IS AN A+.
HIM AND KDAF AOA WILL BE THE
BEST DO WHAT WE SEE.
>> THE SKY IS REMARKABLE AND
HE'S PLAYING OUTSIDE OF AIDAN
HUTCHINSON AND YOU MENTIONED HE
IS PLAYING OPPOSITE.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT HE IS
DEVELOPING PAST MOVES AND I GO
WITH A+ AS WELL.
HE WILL STOP IN AND ONCE HE IS
HEALTHY.
YOU SEE HIM GET UPFIELD AND
MAKE PLAYS AND BE ABLE TO GET
UNDERNEATH.
>> BALTIMORE RAVENS 30 SECONDS
AGAINST THE PASS AND THEY NEED
TO GET AFTER THE QUARTERBACKS
ESPECIALLY IN THE DIVISION.
THAT HIS JOEY BOROUGH ACROSS
THE MAIN AND THE EVER ELUSIVE
KENNY PICKETT READY THE RAVENS
HAD THE SPEED ON THE OUTSIDE
AND THE QUESTION WILL BE DO
THEY MOVE UP TOGETHER BIG
INTERIOR DEFENSIVE LINEMAN.
HOW DO THEY ADDRESS THAT?
THE LINES ON THE CLOCK?
OUR GOD, AHMAD ST. BROWN READY
TO GO WITH THE LINES AIDAN
HUTCHINSON THEIR FIRST TICKET
NUMBER TWO AND TRADED UP TO GET
JAMESON WILLIAMS AT 12.
THIS IS ONE OF THE PICKS I GOT
BACK IN THE TRADE AS THEY GAVE
UP OTHER PICKS OTHER NEEDS FOR
THEM COULD THIS BE MALIK
WILLIS?
>> I HOPE SO.
>> IT IS NOT.
IT IS JOSH PASCHAL THE PICK
HERE.
YOUR AND IT TOLD BOX.
GO FOR IT.
>> THIS IS A TOUGH PLAYER.
TOUGH, STRONG AND GOOD HANDS.
YOU SEE HIM ON THE OUTSIDE
SHOULDER AND HE CAN KICK IN A
LITTLE BIT AND HE REMINDS ME OF
ADRIAN CLAYBORN.
HE'S GOT SOME JUICE AGAINST THE
PAST BUT THAT'S NOT HIS GAME.
HE'S SUCH A HARD EDGE AND A
HARD WORKER.
IF YOU GOT DERBY DOWN AT THE
SENIOR BOWL HE WILL GIVE THOSE
CYCLES A TOUGH TIME.
PASCO I69 PLAYER ON THE BOARD
AND WE ARE GETTING TO THAT
POINT AND IF IT'S WHAT THEY
WANT AND TRE FLOWERS HAS NOT
WORKED OUT THERE.
PASCO NOT THAT DIFFERENT OF A
PLAYER THIS IS A HIGH FOR PICK
AND A B+ FOR ME.
THE LINES ARE HAVING A NICE TWO
GAMES HERE.
>> THE TEAM CAPTAIN AND IS THE
KING EVERY DAY AND ONE OF THE
MOST SPECIAL PLAYERS I EVER
COACHED.
2018 BATTLE BACK.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THE
PLAYER HERE?
>> I LOVE HIM.
I THINK YOU CLAIM IS A TRUE
DEFENSIVE END.
THE QUESTION BECOMES ARE YOU
GOING TO PUT HIM AT A 4-3
DEFENSIVE END?
THAT BECOMES A? I'M GOING WITH
THE B HERE BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE FITS ALONG THE
DEFENSIVE FRONT AND I DON'T
THINK HE WANTS TO KICK WAY DOWN
INSIDE OUTSIDE OF PAST RUSH
SOUNDS BUT ON DOWNS ONE, TWO
AND SHORT YARDAGE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE WILL BE AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
>> OF COURSE, ROMER CHORUS
RECOVERING FROM AN ACHILLES
INJURY.
28 IN RUSHING AND 24TH IN
PASSING THAT IS TWO PICKS MR.
AHMAD ST. BROWN FOR THE D-BACKS
LINEBACKING CORPS.
YOU KNOW YOUR HEAD COACH.
IS THIS HIS BREAD AND BUTTER OR
ANOTHER TOY TO PLAY WITH?
>> 100%.
I THINK THEY DID THEIR
RESEARCH.
I'M SURE THIS GUY IS GREAT.
THAT'S WHAT HE TALKS ABOUT ALL
THE TIMES.
YOU CAN NEVER HAVE ENOUGH DEATH
AT THE LINE.
BIG ON THE TRENCHES.
A GREAT PICK FOR US.
WE WILL NEED HIM AND I AM
EXCITED.
AHMAD ST. BROWN, JOSH PASCHAL
THE PICK FOR THE DETROIT LIONS
AT 46.
I HAVE NEXT UP WASHINGTON.
YOU HAVE THE PICK ALREADY
CONNOR?
>> I DON'T HAVE THE PICK, NO.
>> THIS IS THE PICK THEY HAD
ALONG WITH CARSON WENTZ.
47 NOW THEY TOOK JAHAN DODSON
AFTER MOVING OUT FOR CHRISTIANS
LABBE.
>> THIS IS THE CARSON WENTZ ERA
OFFICIALLY.
THEY NEEDED HELP ALONGSIDE
TERRY MCLAURIN AND I GOT JOHN
DOPSON AFTER PENN STATE.
THEY RELEASED COLLINS GOING
WITH PHIDARIAN MATHIS, THE PICK
THERE FOR THE WASHINGTON
COMMANDERS.
>> IT TELLS ME THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO PLAY STRONG PAIN.
>> WHAT ARE THEY GETTING FROM
PHIDARIAN MATHIS, KERNER?
>> HE REMINDS ME OF HARRIS.
NOT OVERLY ATHLETIC BUT DOES
HIS JOB IN THE TRENCHES.
GIVES YOU SOME FOR JUICE
AGAINST THE PASS. BUT NOT A
BURSTING EXPLOSIVE CONSTANTLY
WINNING PASS RUSH KIND OF
PLAYER.
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS HIS JOB
AT ALABAMA.
HE WAS READING REACTING AGAINST
THE RUN WHICH IS THE HARRISON
PHILLIPS COMPARISON THERE.
MY 79TH OVERALL PLAYER IN THIS
DRAFT THOUGH.
THIS IS THE KIND OF GUY YOU CAN
GET IN THE THIRD ROUND AND THE
FOURTH ROUND AND IT FEELS LIKE
A BEACH.
HIGH FLOOR AND A STARTER BUT IT
C PLUS FOR ME THEY HAD A LOT OF
OTHER NEEDS THAT THAT THE
OTHER.
>> SECOND ALL-AROUND TEAM,
FELDNER.
HE SET A GOOD EXAMPLE FOR THE
YOUNGER GUY.
WHAT KIND OF IMPACT WILL HE
HAVE.
>> I THINK HE CAN PLUG AND
PLAY.
HE IS AS CLOSE TO THE PROS AS
YOU CAN GET.
THE BIG KEY IS WATCHING HIM
PLAY FROM TWO TO THE FIVE
DEPENDING ON WHAT SETS THEY
WERE AND HE BRINGS A TOUGHNESS
AND INTELLIGENCE TO THE GAME.
HE IS A REALLY SMART FOOTBALL
PLAYER ALONG THE DEFENSE
INTERIOR AND UNDERSTANDS WHAT
TEAMS ARE TRYING TO DO AND HOW
TO COUNTERACT IT.
I WILL GIVE IT A B+.
WE WANT TO GET TO JASON KELCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT MATHIS?
>> HE'S A SOLID PLAYER.
WASHINGTON JUST LOST SETTLE.
IT WAS A SOFT SEASON AND THEY
NEEDED THAT DOTS AND SOMEONE TO
PLAY ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY LIKE
TO PLAY BASE AND GET THREE TEE
LINEMAN.
HE CAN PLAY ANYWHERE ON THE
FRONT.
PLEASE BIGGER THAN HE IS.
VERY SOLID.
JUST A REALLY SOLID PLAYER.
>> ANOTHER ALABAMA DEFENSIVE
LINEMAN FOR WASHINGTON WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT YOUR OWN PAIN AND
JONATHAN ALLEN AND ALL THOSE
GUYS THERE.
HE MENTIONED TO RON PAYNE IS A
FREE-AGENT THEY JUST PAID
JONATHAN ALLEN.
THEY DID GET INTO THE ONE BIG
FIGHT ON THE DALLAS SIDE LOOKS
LIKE IN THE LONG RUN JONATHAN
ALLEN IS THE GUY THAT STAYS.
PHIDARIAN MATHIS.
>> ALL THREE GUYS ALABAMA D9.
>> PHIDARIAN MATHIS IS THE GUY
THAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF JOSH
PASCAL.
I KNOW WHERE MATHIS PLACE.
PASCAL I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE
PLAYS.
>> SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN EXPECT
THREE LESS PICKS ALL ALONG THE
DEFENSIVE FRONT SEVEN.
TWO THE LINEMAN AND BEFORE THAT
TWO WIDE RECEIVERS AND OUR
FIRST RUNNING BACK, THE BOARD
AND WE ARE STILL YET TO SEE A
TIGHT END FOR ANY OF THE OTHER
QUARTERBACKS.
HERE IS THE LAST 10 PICKS AS WE
GET READY FOR CHICAGO WHICH
WILL TAKE US HALFWAY THROUGH
THE SECOND ROUND.
LOOKING AT YOUR BIG BOARD, WHO
IS SURPRISING YOU THAT IS
AVAILABLE?
>> NAKOBE DEAN.
TRAVIS JONES.
MY FIRST TWO ROUNDS GRATES THAT
ARE LEFT.
YOU GET INTO IT MALIK WILLIS
SHOULD NOT BE WAITING MUCH
LONGER.
MY FAVORITE PLAYER IS JAQUAN
BRISKER.
A STARTING SAFETY THAT IS
PERSONABLE AND INTERCHANGEABLE.
HE CAN HANDLE THE RITUALS AND
FRONT SUPPORT.
I LOOK AT THAT AND SAY IF YOU
NEED A SAFETY, GO GET HIM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE UGLY AFTER
HIM AND BRIAN COOK GO.
THEN THE WIDE RECEIVERS WILL
FALL OFF A CLIFF.
WE SEEMED AT ONCE COME OFF THE
BOARD.
>> THIS IS AGAIN MATT EBERFLUS
13.
THEY TRADED KHALIL MACK AND
THEY HAD A PICK FOR TRADING
CHILI AND THEY GOT RID OF ALLEN
ROBINSON.
TWO FIGUREHEADS BOTH SIDES OF
THE BALL.
>> YES.
>> THEY WENT CORNERBACK WITH
KYLER GORDON.
THEY DO NEED SOME SIZE UP
FRONT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY STAND
WITH SMITH.
HE IS UP WITH THE CONTRACT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY GO
LINEBACKER BUT IF MATT EBERFLUS
WENT AGAIN IF YOU HAD TO GUESS,
WHAT DO YOU  THINK?
>> BERNHARD RAIMANN.
WHY NOT AT THIS POINT?
IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS, HE MOVED
FROM TIGHT END TO TACKLE DURING
THE PANDEMIC.
HE CAME OVER FROM AUSTRIA.
HE HAD TO DO HIS NECESSARY
MILITARY TIME, IT'S ABOUT SIX
MONTHS TO EIGHT MONTHS.
HE'S AN OLDER ROOKIE.
I LOOK AT BERNHARD RAIMANN AND
THINK THAT IS SOMEBODY THAT YOU
HAVE SOME VERSATILITY WITH WHAT
YOU CAN DO AND MAYBE YOU GET
RAYMOND AND SAY WE PLAY ON THE
LEFT OR RIGHT AND GUARD AND I
LOOKED AT HIM AND SAID ONE
EVERYONE HAD HIM THAT'S NOT A
GOOD IDEA AND SAME WAY I FELT
ABOUT TREVOR PENNING.
AT THIS POINT A DEVELOPMENTAL
TACKLE THAT CAN GIVE YOU GUARD
FLEXIBILITY AND I LOVE IT HERE.
>> THEY HAD TWO OF THOSE SECOND-
YEAR TACKLES.
THEY TOOK THEM LAST YEAR.
AND THAT SORT OF WHAT I'M
READING AND I WAS THERE.
THEY WERE LAST IN THE NFL IN
SACKS ALLOWED IT 58 AND IF YOU
ARE GOING TO PLAY JUST IN
FIELDS, YOU HAVE TO BLOCK FOR
HIM A LITTLE BIT EXPECT YOU CAN
ASK HIM TO RUN AROUND.
>> DECIDES DARNELL MOONEY, WHO
IS HE THROWING TO EXPECT THEY
DID SIGN BYRON PRINGLE.
>> BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A DUDE.
>> NO.
>> I'M CONCERNED FOR THE FUTURE
OF JUSTIN FIELDS THIS YEAR AND
I KNOW IT'S NOT RYAN POLES'
FAULT THE ROSTER IS IN GREAT
AND IT WILL TAKE SOME TIME.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS IS A
DEFENSIVE.
MATT EBERFLUS FIGURED OUT THIS
YEAR.
DEDICATED PEAKS TO THE OFFENSE.
>> IS THAT SCOTT MORELAND?
>> NOW YOU ARE WORKING ABOUT
THE VERTICAL.
WE KNOW HE CAN PUSH IT.
>> I GOT JAQUAN BRISKER.
>> LOVE THE PLAYER.
ONCE AGAIN THEY ARE LOOKING
DEFENSE AGAIN.
LOVE THE PLAYER.
>>> CHICAGO PLAYERS.
NUMBER 48 IN THE KHALIL MACK
TRADE THEY ARE GOING SAFETY
JAQUAN BRISKER OUT OF PENN
STATE, GOOD SIZE AND GOOD
SPEED.
IN LAST 5-YEAR THE CHICAGO
BEARS HAVE NOT DRAFTED A SAFETY
IN ANY ROUND AND THEY DO IT HERE
WITH HIM.
HE HURT HIS SHOULDER IN THE
SEASON OPENER PLAYED THROUGH IT
AND HAD SOME MISSED TACKLES
BECAUSE IS PLAYING WITH HER
SHOULDER.
REALLY GOOD INSTINCTS AND YOU
CAN USE THEM.
I LOVE HIM.
HE WAS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS.
THIS IS A LETTER A- FOR THE
BEARS.
THEY HAVE OFFENSIVE NEEDS BUT I
LOVE HIM.
>> TEAM ALL BIG 10, THE
UNQUESTIONED LEADER OF THE TEAM
BY HIS TEAMMATES.
WHENEVER I WATCHED PENN STATE,
HE WAS MAGNETIC.
I FELT LIKE HIS TEAMMATES
WANTED TO TOUCH HIM WHENEVER
THE BALL WAS IN THE AIR HE WAS
THERE.
A PLAYMAKER.
>> HE KILLED GAMES, THE
WISCONSIN GAME.
HE'S KILLED THESE GAMES.
HE'S WENT OUT AND MADE PLAYS,
THE AUBURN ONE, EXCUSE ME.
AND A PICK IN THE FIRST ROUND.
I KNOW WE HAVE TO GET TO
RICHARD SHERMAN.
YOU SEE JAQUANTE PLAY WHAT DO
YOU THINK HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE?
>> I THINK THIS IS WHAT THE NFL
COMING TO IS LIKE POSITION AS
FOOTBALL.
HE WILL BE IN THE SLOT BLITZING
AND DEEP SAFETY AND I THINK
HE'S A GREAT FLICK.
YOU ALWAYS THINK DEFENSE THEY
NEED OFFENSIVE WEAPONS BUT THE
BEST OFFENSE IS TO GET SOME
REALLY QUALITY DEFENDERS TO
KEEP POINTS OFF THE BOARD.
THEY WILL APPRECIATE THE GAMES
NOT BEING 40 TO 48.
HE TRUSTS HIMSELF.
EARLY ON IN HIS CAREER HE DID
NOT TRUST HIMSELF FOR WHAT HE
SEES.
HE IS CHANGED AND HE SHOOTS HIS
GUN AND HE TRUSTS WHAT HE SEES
AND IT MAKES HIM AND IMPACT
PLAYER, JAQUAN BRISKER.
>>> IF YOU THINK ABOUT THE
INDIANA COLTS WHEN MATT
EBERFLUS IT WAS DEEP TACKLE IN
THE MIDDLE LINEBACKER AND
ALWAYS SEARCHING FOR THAT
SAFETY, MATT EBERFLUS TRYING TO
GET THAT GUY JAQUAN BRISKER.
THE NEW ORLEANS SAINTS AROUND-
THE-CLOCK AND IS THIS A CHANCE
THAT WE SEE MALIK WILLIS?
COULD THIS BE?
ALL I HEARD FROM THE SAINTS AS
WE THINK WE ARE REALLY CLOSE
AND WE DON'T WANT TO GO WITH
THE QUARTERBACK.
>> THEY REALLY LIKE DEMONS.
THEY REALLY DO BELIEVE IN
JAMEZ.
IF YOU ARE AT THAT POINT GET AN
IMPACT PLAYER.
THERE ARE IMPACT PLAYERS ON THE
BOARD.
>> THEY WENT TREVOR PENNING THE
OFFENSIVE TACKLE TO REPLACE ARM
STRENGTH.
THEY KNOCKED OFF TWO NEEDS
RIGHT AWAY.
HOWEVER YOU FEEL ABOUT TREVOR
PENNING IS HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT
TREVOR PENNING.
THEY DID LOSE MARCUS WILLIAMS
BESIDES MARCUS MAY THEY LOST
JENNINGS.
THERE COULD BE A NEED FOR
SAFETY.
FOR ME, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
GO TOO MUCH WITH ANOTHER WIDE
RECEIVER BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK.
>> WHEN TREVOR BRIAN?
DO WE THINK THAT TREVOR BRIAN
HAS ENOUGH CREDIT?
IT DOES NOT HAVE TO BE WIDE
RECEIVER.
AS TREY MCBRIDE AND AN
ADDITIONAL WEAPON TO THROW TO
EXPECT THE SAME ROOM ON THE
BLEACHER REPORT IS ALL
QUARTERBACK.
EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT THE
COULD BE BETTER?
COULD IT BE WILLIS?
WHAT IS IT GOING TO BE.
AGAIN, IF YOU ARE WATCHING ON
THE BLEACHER REPORT APP YOU CAN
FIND YOUR TEAMS ROOM PROJECT
PICKS AND ALL THE GUIDES SO
WHEN YOU END UP TAKING GUYS
THAT THE OTHER TEAM DON'T LIKE
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO
THAT OF THAT ABUSE FROM THOSE
GUYS.
IT'S MICKEY LOOMIS BUT THIS IS
DENNIS ALLEN'S TEAM NOW WITH
MICKEY DRAFTING IT'S THE SAME
PHILOSOPHY WE HAVE SEEN.
>> THEY ARE A PROGRAM.
IS THAT WHAT YOU CALL IT?
>> THEY STAY WHERE YOU ARE.
>> WE WATCH THEM GO UP LAST
NIGHT AND THEY PREFER SOME
IMPACT IT WILL BE FASCINATING
IF THEY DO TAKE A QUARTERBACK
YOU ARE GOING TO UPSET JAMISON
WINSTON BECAUSE A SECOND-ROUND
PICK ISN'T GOING TO CEDE HIS
JOB.
WE DRAFTED TREVOR PENNING.
RIGHT?
WE'VE HAD A HOLE AND WE GOT
KRIS HARVEY.
THEY DID BRING SOME GUYS BACK.
MARCUS WILLIAMS LEFT AND THEY
BROUGHT IN MARCUS MAY.
THEY LIKE THEIR DEFENSE.
HEAD COACH RUNS THE DEFENSE.
>> IT IS A REALLY INTERESTING
TEAM.
I LOOK AT THEIR DEFENSE AND IT
IS AN INTERESTING TEAM.
MAYBE YOU TAKE NAKOBE DEAN AND
PUT HIM NEXT TO DAVIS.
>> AND THE DIVISION STINKS.
THEY GAVE THE BUCKS A HARD TIME
LAST YEAR.
I THINK THEY HAVE BEATEN ABOUT
CELESTE WERE TIMES I PLAYED
THEY HAD HIS NUMBER.
>> IF I HOSTED A FOOTBALL CAST
I WOULD SAY TO YOU ALL REALIZE
HOW IMPORTANT SEAN PAYTON IS
AND HOW GOOD OF A COACH HE IS?
YOU MAY THINK YOU ARE CLOSE.
THEY ARE GOING ALONG TATE
HEIPLE ARE TWITCH IT LOOKS LIKE
FELDNER SAID WHAT?
>> IT IS THE FIRST STRANGE PICK
OF THE DAY, APPARENTLY.
IT IS AMONTE TAYLOR QUARTERBACK
OUT OF TENNESSEE.
CONNOR WHERE DID YOU EXPECT HIM
TO GO?
>> ON DAY THREE WHEN MATT
EBERFLUS AND I ARE TRYING TO
BRING OURSELVES BACK TO LIFE.
PLAYER 161, I COMPARED HIM TO
ISAIAH DUNN.
AN INTERESTING PLAYER IN TERMS
OF WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO AT
THE NEXT LEVEL?
DO YOU TRUST HIM IN MAN OR THE
PHYSICALITY?
THERE WERE BETTER PLAYERS ON
THE BOARD IF YOU NEEDED A
CORNER THAT BADLY.
FOR THE SAINTS, DEFINITELY THE
LEAST FAVORITE.
I WOULD'VE TAKEN KOBE BRYANT.
>> WAIT?
EXCUSE ME?
>> WEIGHT.
>> SAUCE GARDNERS RUNNING BACK
AT CINCINNATI.
THIS IS EARLY.
IT'S REALLY EARLY FOR AMONTE
TAYLOR SO THIS IS A D PLUS.
>> I HAVE HIM ON MY SAFETY
SEAT.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK HE
WILL CONVERT.
>> THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
>> GREAT.
DO IT ON DAY THREE.
>> THEY ARE NOT IN A FIGHT WITH
ANYBODY FOR THE.
>> . NOBODY ELSE IS GOING TO
PICK HIM RIGHT NOW OR TODAY.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT IS AND I
LIKE TAYLOR.
HE WAS A GOOD PIECE OF THAT
TENNESSEE DEFENSE AND THE
REASON WE TALK ABOUT HIM
TRANSITIONING TO SAFETY IS HE
WAS GOOD WITH THEIR ZONE
SCHEMES AND SEEING THROUGH HIS
RECEIVERS IN THE QUARTERBACK
AND HE IS NOT AFRAID TO MAKE
THE TACKLE THOSE ARE THE THINGS
HE DOES WELL.
THE REALITY IS AND I WILL GIVE
IT A C. I WON'T BE AS HARD.
>> YOU DID NOT HAVE TO GET HIM
RIGHT NOW.
I DO THINK HE IS AN NFL PLAYER
GROW INTO THAT STAR POSITION,
THE BIG NICKEL TYPE PLAYER.
HE WILL GROW INTO THAT AND
PROVIDE REAL VALUE AND I JUST
DON'T THINK YOU NEEDED TO GET
HIM RIGHT NOW.
>> STAR RATING REPS WITH FOUR
INTERCEPTIONS.
NO BALL PRODUCTION.
I SAW HIM GET LOST IN MAN.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE WILL BE A
SAFETY.
>> THAT MOST OF STONE FOR A
WHILE.
>> AHMAD ST. BROWN PLAYED WITH
THIS GUY.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF THIS GUY?
>> I PLAYED WITH HIM AND HIGH
SCHOOL AT THE NIKE OPENING WITH
THE TOP 150 HIGH SCHOOL PLAYERS
AND HE WAS A RECEIVER AND WE
WERE BOTH PLAYING RECEIVER.
ONCE HE GOT TO COLLEGE HE
SWITCHED TO DB.
AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS A BIG
TRANSITION AND FOR HIM TO GET
PICKED THIS EARLY I'M EXCITED
FOR HIM AND HE MADE THE
TRANSITION WELL, APPARENTLY
AWESOME DUDE.
>> YOU VOUCH FOR HIS CHARACTER?
YOU THINK HE IS A GOOD GUY?
>> YES.
100%.
>> I WAS HOPING YOU WOULD GO
THE OTHER WAY.
GENTRY THANKS FOR CHECKING IN.
AMONTE TAYLOR, THE FIRST
SHOCKER.
>> HE IS AN NFL PLAYER.
STARTING EXPERIENCE ALL FOUR
YEARS, WE ARE IN THE SECOND
ROUND, GUYS.
YOU ARE BEATING UP YOURSELF.
>> TEAM I THINK HAS DONE A GOOD
JOB FIGURING OUT THEIR NEEDS,
THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS ARE UP.
GETTING TRENT McDUFFIE TO PLAY.
GETTING THEM TO SOLIDIFY THE D
LINE WITH THE OTHER SIDE OF
FRANK CLARK AND JONES I WAS
TEXTING WITH THEIR QUARTERBACK
TODAY.
>> DOGS ON DEFENSE AND ALL WE
HAVE TO DO IS GET MORE WEAPONS
ON OFFENSE.
ARE THERE WEAPONS OUT THERE
NOW.
THEY WILL NOT REPLACE TYREEK
HILL WHO DO WE THINK IT WILL
BE?
>> IF THERE IS A TEAM THAT WILL
PLAY ROULETTE ON THE GEORGE
PICKENS EXPERIENCE RIGHT HERE,
IT IS THEM EXPECT THE PATRIOTS
ARE ON THE CLOCK AND TRADE WITH
THE CHIEFS.
THE CHIEFS HAVE TRADED WITH THE
CHIEFS TWICE.
FIRST TRENT McDUFFIE AT 21 AND
NOW THEY ARE TRADING AGAIN.
SO BATH BEACH AND BILL
BELICHICK.
>> HEY WHAT'S UP.
>> GOOD.
LET'S TRADE EXPECT THE PATRIOTS
ARE ON THE CLOCK.
I WANTED TO KNOW WHAT YOU MEANT
BY THE GEORGE PICKENS
EXPERIENCE, TO BE HONEST.
>> HE IS A FASCINATING PLAYER.
THAT SIDE SPEED IS SO
ENTERTAINING.
HE'S A TOUGH GUY.
>> IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE
GEORGIA TECH SITE.
>> THERE IS A VIRAL GEORGE
PICKENS MASHUP ON MINE.
>> NONE OF HIM TOUCHING.
JUST WALKING AND COMING UP THE
BALL.
WALKING GUYS STRAIGHT TO THE
GROUND.
>> HE IS FUN.
IT IS A MATTER OF WILL HE BE
SUPER PRODUCTIVE.
>> PATRIOTS TRADED FOR DEVANTE
PARKER.
THEY COULD STILL USE IN MY MIND
A CORNERBACK.
THEY LOST J.C.
JACKSON AND A HUGE COUNTER FOR
THE CHARGERS.
THEY DID ADD MALCOLM BUTLER AND
THEY COULD USE SOME CORNERS
THERE.
>> LINEBACKER.
>> NAKOBE DEAN ON THE MAIN.
>> HERE IS THE THING THOUGH.
DID THEY SEE TAYLOR GO UP THE
BOARD?
>> TRAVIS JONES, IT'S GOING TO
BE TACKLE IMPORTANT.
I AM JUST READING YOUR FACES TO
SEE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW YOU ARE TAKING
IT.
>> THE BURNER, 4-2-8, CONNOR?
>> HE HAS CAUGHT GAS.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
VALUE HERE?
>> TERRIBLE.
IT'S AWFUL.
SURE, REMEMBER YESTERDAY WHEN I
SAID IS RARE TO GET A GUY THAT
RUNS 7-4-3 ABOUT JAMISON JONES.
HE REINCE SUB 4-3 AND NO
POLITICS.
>> ANYONE-4-10.
>> 180 POUNDS AND HE CAN FLY.
SIZE PROFILE LONG, FAST, NOT A
NATURAL PASS CATCHER AT ALL.
NOT A NATURAL PASS CATCHER AT
ALL.
NOT MUCH GOING ON BESIDES GET
VERTICAL OR WE WILL GET A TOUCH
TO RUN.
>> WHAT NUMBER DID YOU HAVE
HIM?
>> 189 ON THE BIG BOARD.
I HAD THEM IN THE SIXTH ROUND
AND THE 25th WIDE RECEIVER.
WE WANTED THE FASTER THE SKY
BUT I DON'T SEE ANY POLISHED
HERE.
>> WHAT IS YOUR GRADE?
>> THIS IS A D. I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
RECEIVERS ON THE BOARD AND I
DON'T THINK HE IS ONE?
>> IF WE ARE HONEST BELICHICK
HAS NOT BEEN GOOD WIDE
RECEIVERS.
HE'S STOLEN OTHER WIDE
WHAT DO WE THINK ABOUT
THORNTON?
>> HE IS A FORMER AND
SUPERFAST.
INSTALL MY THUNDER.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE CAN CATCH.
HE JUMPS UP WHEN THE BALL IS AT
HIS FACE WILL JUMP UP AND CATCH
IT IN HIS STOMACH INSTEAD OF
CATCHING IT WITH HIS HANDS IN
FRONT.
XU D PLUS MAYBE HE GO STRAIGHT
LINE DOWN THE FIELD AND YOU CAN
THROW IT OVER THE TOP BECAUSE
HE CAN RUN FASTER THAN ANYONE
ELSE BUT THIS IS TOUGH.
>> DOES HE HAVE SPECIAL TEAMS
EXPERIENCE?
THEY LOST THE PLAYER.
>> BABY THEY LIKE HIM AS A
COVERAGE KIND OF GUY.
I CANNOT EMPHASIZE ENOUGH, HE
IS REALLY LIGHT, 180 POUNDS AT
6'2" AND HE REMINDS ME OF
D.J.B CHARK.
>> MAYBE WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE
WILL TALK ABOUT.
MAYBE AHMAD ST. BROWN WILL COME
IN AND SAY CLOSURE MILES AND
THIS GUY IS AMAZING.
ARE WE DUMB?
WHAT DO YOU THINK AHMAD ST.
BROWN?
>> I'M ACTUALLY SHOCKED HE WENT
TOO THIS EARLY.
HE DUSTED EVERYONE AT THE
COMBINE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HIS GAME WILL
TRANSLATE TO THE NFL.
YOU ARE FAST BUT WHAT CAN YOU
DO BETWEEN 0-20 YARDS.
CAN YOU RUN A RUNBACK OR A
PEARL.
HE JUST PUT A SAFETY OVER THE
TOP AND YOU ELIMINATE THAT.
THE PATRIOTS COULD HAVE GONE, A
LOT, IN MY EYES, A LOT OF
BETTER RECEIVERS I COULD HAVE
CHOSEN.
HE'S FAST.
MAYBE THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT SO
WE WILL SEE.
>> AHMAD ST. BROWN, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR HONESTY.
I THINK OF COREY COLEMAN OUT OF
BAYLOR AND DENZEL MIMS AND
TYLER THORNTON.
MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES ON THE
CLOCK WITH PICKED NUMBER 51.
LAST NIGHT JASON KELCE AND I
SHARED A SPLIT SCREEN AND WE
LOST OUR MINDS.
THE PICK HAS BEEN MADE ALREADY?
>> I LOVE THE PICK.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE.
>> IT'S ON THE SCREEN, IT'S
CAMERON JURGENS.
IT IS A CENTRE.
>> [ LAUGHTER ]
>> YES.
>> WHAT THE HELL?
>> I KNEW WE WERE TAKING HIM.
>> YOU DID?
>> SO THIS IS MY FAVORITE
PLAYER IN THE DRAFT.
I'M NOT JUST SAYING THAT
BECAUSE WE PICKED HIM.
THE EAGLES HAVE BEEN USING ME
TO EVALUATE SOME OF THE SENDERS
COMING OUT AND OF ALL THE GUYS
I HAVE LOOKED AT FOR THE PASS
TO OR THREE YEARS AND OUT OF
ALL THE GUYS I COMPARE MOST TO
MYSELF, THIS GUY IS HIM.
HE IS SO ATHLETIC AND SO FAST
AND YOU SEE HIM IN SPACE AND HE
RUNS AND HE IS A NATURAL
ATHLETE.
YOU SEE THE FLUIDITY VICKI
PLAYED HIDE AND.
HE IS A CONVERT TO THE
OFFENSIVE LINE FOR 4-9, 240,
ONE - 7-10.
THIS GUY IS A FREAK
ATHLETICALLY.
HE HAS THE BEST CHANCE AT BEING
A DIFFERENCE MAKER AT THE
CENTER POSITION.
I LIKE THIS KID A LOT.
I CAN'T WAIT TO WORK WITH HIM.
I CAN'T WAIT TO TEACH THEM
EVERYTHING I KNOW.
EVERYBODY LOVES HIM.
HIS COLLEGE OFFENSIVE LINE
COACH WAS OUR ASSISTANT
OFFENSIVE LINE COACH WITH THE
EAGLES I WAS ABLE TO TALK TO
HIM AND GET THE LOWDOWN ON THIS
KID.
WE HAVE BEEN HIGH ON THIS KID
FOR A LONG TIME.
I'M EXCITED WE WERE ABLE TO GET
HIM HERE.
TO MAKE IT SCARY, HIS FAMILY
HAS A CATTLE FARM AND I JUST
BOUGHT 11 TILES SO MAYBE I CAN
GO IN ON HIS FAMILY BEEF JERKY
THING.
>> AND HE TOLD ME HE WOULD GIVE
ME SOME TO TRY.
I NEED ME SOME BEEF JERKY.
>> YOU ARE TELLING ME RIGHT NOW
FOR THE LAST TWO OR THREE YEARS
AND YOU HAVE BEEN A PERENNIAL
PRO BOWLER.
NOT REALLY RUNNING BACKS.
YOU'VE BEEN HANDPICKING YOUR
VEGETABLE REPLACEMENT AND YOU
HAVE BESTOWED THE HONOR ON
CAMERON JURGENS?
>> NO.
I AM NOT SAYING THAT.
I AM SAYING THAT THE EAGLES
ASKED MY OPINION ON DIFFERENT
CENTERS AND I THINK THIS GUY
RIGHT HERE IS THE GUY THAT
ASSIMILATES THE MOST TO  ME.
>> HE HAS THE JASON KELCE THE
STAMP OF APPROVAL.
>> FOR SURE.
HE CAN BE MUCH BETTER THAN ME
THE CEILING IS SO HIGH ON THIS
GUY, I AM ALL IN.
>> WOW, THE FACT THAT YOU ARE
SO AND TOOK THE AWKWARDNESS
AWAY.
WHAT GRADE ARE WE GIVING HERE?
>> AN A+ FOR ME.
JASON, I CAN HEAR HIM TO A RYAN
KALIL ASK KIND OF GUY.
THEY TAKE THE MEDIA MEMBERS
LIKE ME TO MAKE THESE BIG
BOARDS AND MAKE A CONSENSUS FOR
THE FEEDBACK I WAS GIVEN THE
RANK HIM THE SECOND-HIGHEST OF
ANYONE AND 96.
HE IS A FREAKING START.
HE IS ATHLETIC AND NASTY AND
TOUGH.
OUTSIDE BULLY AND IT'S EVEN
BETTER.
>> WHEN YOU LISTEN TO KELSEY
YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM IN A. I
LOVE THAT SOMEONE FROM
CHARLOTTE WATCHING THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS AND IF YOU CAN GET
THAT STABILITY WHETHER IT'S
JASON KELCE OR RYAN STOCK
KHALIL THAT STABILITY MEANS A
LOT.
>> I WANT JASON KELCE TO PLAY
FOREVER AND I WANT FLETCHER COX
TO PLAY FOREVER.
BOTH OF THEM ARE UNWANTED YOUR
CONTRACTS.
THE FACT THAT DAVIS IS COMING
IN AND I JUST HEARD CAMERON
JURGENS HAS A LITTLE BROTHER
SHARING A CATTLE FARM, AS AN
EAGLES FAN I THINK IT'S
BEAUTIFUL FOR IT'S LIKE THIS,
JASON, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HUMBLE DO.
THAT WAS A BEAUTIFUL THING YOU
JUST SAID.
>> I AM EXCITED.
I AM AT THIS POINT IN MY CAREER
WERE YOU WANT TO LEAVE THINGS
IN A GOOD SPOT IN THE WAY WE
SEE IT IS BETTER THAN WE HAVE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD YOUNG
TALENT AND GUYS AND PLAYED INTO
AN THE SKY TO OUR GROUP I FEEL
GOOD ABOUT WHERE OFFENSIVE LINE
IS IN THE FUTURE.
>> HUNGRY DOGS RUN FASTER.
SHOT OUT.
ANOTHER DIG.
PITTSBURGH STEELERS ON THE
CLOCK IN THE PICK IS IN.
THEY ARE RIDING KENNY PICKETT
IN THE FIRST ROUND AND NOW
THINK OF GEORGE PICKETT TO JOIN
A WIDE RECEIVER ROOM INCLUDING
CHEESE KLEEBERG AFTER THEY LOST
JUJU AND JAMES WASHINGTON COULD
TALK ABOUT THE FIGHTERS THAT IS
GEORGE PICKENS?
>> HE'S BIG AND LONG WITH
DOWNFIELD SPEED.
AT 6'3", ALMOST 200 POUNDS AND
COMING OFF A SERIOUS INJURY WE
DID NOT GET TO SEE HIM AND THAT
YOU BREAK DOWN.
THE THINGS YOU WANT TO WATCH ON
TAPE IS THE TARGETS THAT DID
NOT MAKE IT TO HIM.
THE BALL NEVER GETS THERE TO
HIM.
GEORGE PICKENS, WE KNOW THE
STEELERS LIKED TO THROW IT
DOWNFIELD.
I AM EXCITED TO WATCH THEM GROW
TOGETHER AND THIS IS AN A- FOR
ME.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO SEE THOSE
GUYS.
>> OVER 70% OF HIS CATCHES WERE
FIRST ON HER TOUCHDOWN AND HE
MOVES THE SIX AND SCORES
TOUCHDOWNS.
IS HE A FELDER GUY?
>> THIS IS IN BOWIE.
WATCHING HIM SLINGING GEORGIA
TECH DIRECTLY INTO THE WALL.
IT'S WHERE THAT WE CALL HIM A
TONE SETTER.
A+ FOR ME.
HE RAN OFF THE 20% NUMBER THE
PROBLEM IS HE DID NOT GET
ENOUGH TARGETS FOR HIS
TOUCHDOWNS OR PRODUCTION TO THE
PERCENTAGE THAT THE BIG ISSUE
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A MARCY
BROWN ON THE LINE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT GEORGE PICKENS
IF HE'S HEALTHY, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS THE NEXT LEVEL BUT
THIS IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
SERIES IN THIS DRAFT, DAY TWO.
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT HIM THE MOST
IS THE BULLY IN HIM WHEN I
WATCH THEM ON TAPE I SEE THAT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PLACES
BLOCKING THE BEES AND PUTTING
THEM ON THERE BUT.
YOU WATCH THE FIGHT AGAINST
GEORGIA TECH, YOU DON'T WANT
THAT AS A COACH OR A TEAM.
THAT IS THE KIND OF GUY HE IS
AND THAT'S THE KIND OF GUY I
WANT AS A TEAMMATE.
I THINK IT'S GREAT.
STEVE THREAT CAN CATCH
UNDERNEATH STRONG HANDS AND BIG
BODY FAST.
>> I THINK THERE ARE CERTAIN
TEAMS WHEN THEY DRAFT CERTAIN
POSITIONS THAT YOU GO THEY WILL
BE GOOD AND THAT'S THE
PITTSBURGH STEELERS EVERY TIME
THEY TAKE A GUY I DON'T KNOW
WHO IS EVALUATING WIDE
RECEIVERS FOR KEVIN COLBERT IN
HIS 27-YEAR, THEY RARELY MISS I
AM NOT TAKING A SHOT.
I PROMISE BUT IF YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOW HE IS TOUGH
AND GNARLY AND HE WILL FIGHT
YOU THAT IS A FAR FIVE FROM
TIKTOK JUJU SMITH-SCHUSTER.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE COMING AND
ANYBODY BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
FIGHT ANYBODY WE KNOW CHASE CAN
FIGHT.
IN THE MEANTIME IF YOU WANT
HELP WITH HOMEBUYING HERE IS A
MESSAGE FROM ROCKET MORTGAGE.
.
>>> IS GOING TO BE THE COLTS
HERE AND THEY ARE TAKING ALEC
PIERCE WIDE RECEIVER OUT OF
CINCINNATI AND CONNOR SAID I
COULD SEE THIS IMMEDIATELY.
WHY A PREMIUM TESTER.
I STILL WORRY ABOUT HIM
SEPARATING AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
I KNOW YOU READ THE
MEASURABLE'S AND HE IS AN
ABSOLUTE FREAKING TERMS OF THE
WORKOUT.
WATCHING HIM IN MOBILE THERE
WERE TIMES WHERE HE STRUGGLED
TO GET OFF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE AND TO BE FAIR A LOT
OF TIMES DESMOND MILLER IS HIM.
HE IS A JUMP BALL TARGET AND
STYLISTICALLY REMINDED ME OF
MARTAVIS BRYANT.
>> MAN WAS HE GOOD.
>> JUST WORRY ABOUT HIM GETTING
AWAY FROM DEFENDERS WERE THIS
IS A C+.
ON THE GOOD NOTE OF A
QUARTERBACK WHO KNOWS HOW TO
GET THIS GUY AND THAT WILL HELP
HIM.
>> THE INACCURACY OF DESMOND
RIDDER OPENS IT UP.
HE DEADLIFTS 675 AND THE HIGH
SCHOOL ATHLETE.
>> VOLLEYBALL GUY TOO.
>> I THINK THIS IS A B+.
AND I LOOK AT HIM AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT HE NEEDS TO GET
SEPARATION BECAUSE HE WILL TAKE
THE BALL AWAY FROM PEOPLE THAT
IS VALLEY.
YOU WATCH ALEC PIERCE AND WHAT
DO YOU THINK BRINGS TO THE
TABLE THAT CAN JUMP UP AND HI-
POINTE THAT FOR PAUL.
>> I HAVE NOT WATCHED TOO MUCH
OF HIS TAPE AND I WATCHED HIS
GAME THE COLLEGE FOOTBALL
PLAYOFFS.
HE WAS A BIG DUDE.
HE RAN REALLY FAST AND FREE
ATHLETE, BASICALLY IN FOR HIM I
DON'T KNOW HOW POLISHED SHE IS
AS A RECEIVER FOR I JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW POLISHED SHE IS BUT IF
HE CAN MAKE A JUMP BALL IN THE
50/50 ABOUT HE CAN MAKE SOME
MONEY.
YOU HAVE TO RUN AND CATCH.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO FIND
HELP, PITTMAN IN PASCO WENT TO
THE EAGLES.
T.Y.
HILTON IS A FREE AGENT AND
LET'S BRING IN JASON KELCE
FORMALLY OF THE CINCINNATI
BEARKATS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF ALEC
PIERCE.
>> I LOVE THIS KID, MAN.
HE ALWAYS SEEMS TO BE AN OPTION
AND WATCHING HIM IN HIS COLLEGE
CAREER HE IS ALWAYS THERE.
EVEN WHEN HE IS COVERED HE IS
OPEN.
YOU CAN THROW IT UP TO HIM AND
I THOUGHT THEY SETTLED THE
SPEED CONCERNS.
HE IS A BIG BODY, A LARGE
TARGET TO THROW TO NATURAL
CATCHER.
I HAVE WATCHED HIM PLAY IN AND
FIRED UP TO WATCH HIM AT THE
NEXT LEVEL.
LET'S GO, BABY.
>> I LOVE THE NEXT PICK.
KANSAS CITY WE KNEW THEY NEEDED
A WEAPON AND WE HAVE A RUN
GOING ON NOW FOR WIDE
RECEIVERS.
FOUR OF THE LAST HAVE BEEN WIDE
RECEIVERS AND KANSAS CITY JUST
GOT ANOTHER WEAPON FOR PAT
MAHOMES.
SKYY MOORE, 95 CATCHES, 1200
YARDS, 10 TOUCHDOWNS, THE
LARGEST HANDS.
HE PLAYED QUARTERBACK IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
HE PLAYED CORNERBACK IN HIGH
SCHOOL A 4-4-1. WHAT DO WE
THINK HERE AT 54?
>> HE IS WELL WORTH IT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SKYY MOORE HE
FITS WITHIN NEED.
THE ONE - FOUR.
>>> BULLET IS READ.
WHEN I LOOK AT SKYY MOORE HE
REMINDS ME OF PIERRE GARCON.
HE CAN DO THE TOUGH STUFF BUT
HE HAS ENOUGH JUICE TO WIN DOWN
THE FIELD.
IT'S A GOOD COMPLEMENT.
THEY HAVE TO DO WHO IS MORE OF
POSSESSION KIND OF GUY THAT
WHERE HE WILL SHINE IS
VERTICALLY.
THE VALUE GREAT FOUR ALL FOR
ALL PLAYER PRACTICE IS GREAT
FOR THE CHIEFS.
>> WHY IS HE STILL HERE?
>> I WAS LITERALLY GOING TO SAY
THAT.
>> YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THIS
GUYS AS PART OF YOUR FAVORITE
AFTER WE GOT PAST THE ORIGINAL
FIVE I THOUGHT SKYY MOORE WOULD
BE IN THE MIX AND TO GET IN IN
THE BACK AND IS AN A+ AND I
LOVE THE FACT THEY GET HIM AND
HE IS SOMEONE THAT CAN DO THE
DIRTY WORK UNDERNEATH.
IF YOU WANT HIM TO RUN THE
SHALLOW CROSSES HE WILL AND HE
WILL RUN AWAY FROM A NICKEL
CORNER BUT IF YOU NOT HIM GET
VERTICAL AND ASK HIM TO PUT
DOWN THE FIELD YOU WILL BE IN
TROUBLE.
>> AND HE PLAY RIGHT AWAY.
THIS IS A TEAM THAT IS TRYING
TO WIN NOW.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT GUYS, DID
THEY DOMINATE?
95 CATCHES, HE WILL BE FINE.
>> THEY ARE NOT ASKING HIM TO
BE NUMBER ONE RECEIVER.
THEY'VE GOT THESE GUYS HE WILL
BE A FOURTH GUY MEANING HE IS
COVERED BY THEIR FOURTH GUY AND
HE CAN BE THAT FOURTH GUY TO BE
THE FOURTH OPTION.
>> HE WILL BE THAT SMALLER
TYREEK HILL RECEIVER.
HE WON'T HAVE THE TYPING SPEED.
AHMAD ST. BROWN WHAT DID YOU
THINK WHEN YOU WATCHED SKYY
MOORE?
>> HE PRODUCED A LOT.
HAS BIG HANDS AND CAN MAKE THEM
CATCH.
AS ROUTE RUNNING, HE RUNS GREAT
ROUTES AND ITS ABILITY TO
ATTACH CONTESTED BALLS OVER THE
MIDDLE SOME DUDES GET SCARED
AND LINEBACKERS AND SAFETIES OF
THEIR AND HE MAKES THOSE
CONTESTED CATCHES OVER THE
MIDDLE AND I THINK IT'S HUGE
FOR HIM MAKING THOSE PITCHERS
EARLY ON AND ONCE HE MAKES
THOSE MAKING DEEP SHOTS LIKE
YOU TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
>> MY MAN AHMAD ST. BROWN
COMING THROUGH WITH THE
ANALYSIS.
FROM THE LOOK OF SKYY MOORE HE
IS A GAMER AND HE WILL BE
READY.
ARIZONA WENT OUT AND TRADED FOR
A WEAPON IN HOLLYWOOD BROWN FOR
TYLER.
THEY ARE SAYING TYLER WE HAVE
YOUR BACK AND DO HAVE THE FIRST
TIGHT END OFF THE BOARD.
TREY MCBRIDE OVER COLORADO
STATE.
MCBRIDE PUT UP NUMBERS.
HE BECAME THE FIRST TIGHT END
TO PASS 1000 RIDE RECEIVING
ONLY SIX WERE BROUGHT AN
AVERAGE SIX IS A GAME UNANIMOUS
JOHN MACKEY AWARD WINNER AND IS
HE A PREMIER TIGHT END THAT
COULD BE A TOP TIGHT END IN
THIS LEAGUE?
>> I THINK IS MORE TOP 12 OR
TOP FIVE.
FORTY-FIFTH OVERALL PLAYER AND
A SMALLER PART ANDREWS.
>> NOW HOLLYWOOD BROWN.
THEY WILL BE BUDDIES.
>> I THINK HE HAS THE BEST ENDS
IN THE DRAFT COUNTING THE WIDE
RECEIVERS AND HE IS REALLY
TOUGH AS AN IN-LINE WALKER.
HE DID NOT ALWAYS RUN AWAY FROM
PEOPLE.
HE CATCHES THE BALL IN TRAFFIC
AND WHEN THINGS ARE CONGESTED
AND HE SHOWS SOME JUICE AFTER
THE CATCH WHETHER SLEEPING
RUNNING TO PEOPLE.
NOW THEY HAVE ZACH ERTZ THERE
FOR THE SHORT-TERM.
HE CAN BE AN EFFECTIVE NUMBER
TWO AND FOR ME THIS IS A A AND
I LIKE THIS PICTURE ARIZONA AND
THIS IS HELPING KYLER MURRAY.
>> YOU THINKING SMALLER MARK
ANDREWS AND YOU ARE THINKING
THE SMALLER BALL CONNECTION.
SHE WENT TO OKLAHOMA.
MCBRIDE IS A PLAYER THAT MAKES
EVERY CATCH.
90 CATCHES IN COLLEGE IS IN
SAYING, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
KNOW HE IS WENT TO BE THE
TARGET.
THE NEXT.
>> HAD HALF AS MANY CATCHES.
THIS IS A GUY THAT DOES HAVE
GOOD SPEED.
HE CAN RUN AWAY FROM SAFETIES
AND MOST WINEMAKERS AND THAT IS
A POSITIVE FOR HIM.
HE TRACKS THE BALL WELL THAT'S
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT HIM.
I THINK THIS IS AN A+ PICK AND
GET HIM HERE NOW TO GET TYLER
MOORE HELP WHICH ARE BRINGING
IN HOLLYWOOD BROWN AND GET HIM
A TIGHT END THAT WILL BE A
PROBLEM YOU SEE HIS ABILITY TO
BALL TRACK SO NICE.
AND AGAIN, GOOD HANDS WHEN YOU.
GOOD HANDS WITH THE ABILITY TO
PUT YOURSELF IN POSITION TO USE
YOUR BODY TO MAKE CATCHES
INVITE YOU MENTIONED HERTZ.
EARLY ON 12 PERSONNEL, $0.08
AND NOW WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
RUN LEFT OR RIGHT WE CAN MAKE
PLAYS OR LINE THEM UP ON THE
SAME SIDE AND OVER BOTH THAT.
>> THEY RE-SIGNED MAX WILLIAMS
AND THEY COULD GO THREE TIGHT
END.
MAX GOT HURT LAST YEAR WHICH IS
WHY THEY TREATED.
THAT DOUBLE TIGHT END SITE IS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THIS TEAM.
LIKE YOU MENTIONED THAT THE
EARTH IS GETTING UP THERE IN
AGE EXPECT YOU CAN GO AND
FEEDBACK FILLED WITH THREE
TIGHT END.
>> IT WAS EMPTY SET WITH FOUR
AND FIVE WIDE RECEIVERS.
>> HE GETS TOWARD THE GOAL
LINE.
>> ARIZONA IS TO REPLACE
CHANDLER JONES.
THE COWBOYS, 56 GOING SAM
WILLIAMS HERE.
SAM WILLIAMS PASS RUSHER OUR
BOLDNESS WEARING SEVEN SO YOU
KNOW HE IS GOOD.
4-4-6, 6'4", 261.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF THE POWERS
TRYING TO GET AN EDGE RUSHER AS
I LOST THE PASS RUSHER WITH THE
ONE AND ONLY RANDY GREGORY.
>> THIS IS RIGHT WHERE YOU
EXPECT SAM WILLIAMS TO GO.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT IS KIND OF
LIKE I'M GOING TO RUN IN A
STRAIGHT LINE AND OVERPOWER
YOU.
IT WORKED FOR HIM AND HE'S BIG
AND STRONG AND A RAN A 4-4 WITH
640.
HE CAN BEND.
HE KNOWS HOW TO KEEP HANDS OFF
OF HIM.
IF YOU WANT TO KEEP HANDS OFF
OF YOU HE WINS LEVERAGE GAMES
IN THE WAY HE HITS QUARTERBACKS
WHICH IS THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
AUTHORITY HE DOES NOT JUST TRY
TO BRING YOU TO THE GROUND HE
IS BRINGING YOU TO THE PAIN.
HE HAD A GREAT WEEK OF PRACTICE
AND HE GOT THE CALL UP FOR THE
SENIOR BOWL THAT'S BIG TIME FOR
SAM WILLIAMS.
I THINK HE'S LIMITED NOW BUT
HIS EFFORT IS GOOD AS A PASS
RUSHER IN THIS WAS A NEED FOR
DALLAS AND HE IS READY TO GO.
I KNOW I SAID PASSION RUSH IS A
PROBLEM, HE IS EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE OF HIS MOTOR.
>> I LOVE THE WAY HE GETS
CHOPPED IN THERE.
HE HAS TO WORK ON TIPPING HIS
SHOULDER AND WHEN HE GETS HIS
CHOPPED GOING TO GET HIS HANDS
OFF AND HE IS AN APEX PREDATOR.
HE KNOWS HOW TO HUNT AND HE
WANTS TO EAT.
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM PLAY IS THAT
FAIR TO SAY?
HE WAS THE GUY FOR THEM?
I THINK HE'S A B+ BECAUSE HE IS
SOMEONE SOME PACKAGES EARLY,
PLATE HIM NOW.
PUT HIM IN THE GAME EARLY AND
PLAY HIM NOW.
>> HE IS VERY EFFECTIVE AS A
PASS RUSHER AND WE ARE AT THE
POINT WHERE YOU DRAFT PASS
RUSHERS.
>> TAMPA BAY TRADED WITH
BUFFALO AND THEY ARE AT THE.
>> . THEY CAME OUT WITH THE
FIRST PICK OF THE SECOND ROUND
AND WHAT WITH LOGAN HALL, THE
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN OUT OF
HOUSTON.
THEY STILL HAVE QUESTIONS AT
WIDE RECEIVER EVEN THOUGH THEY
SIGNED RUSSELL GAGE THEY STILL
HAVE QUESTIONS AT CORNERBACK
REMEMBER WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WOULD DO
ANDREW BOOTH AND THE OTHER
QUESTION IS LAVONTE DAVID.
32 YEARS OLD, FREE AGENT NEXT
YEAR, NAKOBE DEAN IN COMPARISON
THERE.
WE KNOW WHAT TODD BOWLES CAN DO
WITH A GOOD READ AND REACT.
I WONDER THEY DID LOSE
POSTCARDS.
THEY TRADED FOR SHAQ MASON.
I DO NOT KNOW IF THERE IS A
GUARD THAT CAN.
GRONK, DID HE RETIRE?
>> THEY MIGHT SEE A RUN IN
TIGHT ENDS.
>> THEY REALLY LIKE TREY
McBRIDE.
THAT WAS A TIGHT END WE REALLY
LIKED.
WE LIKE JEREMY RUCKERT A LOT.
WASN'T GIVEN THE SAME TARGETS
AS TREY McBRIDE.
>> WE WAIT AND GET ISAIAH
LIKELY?
>> GUYS, TRAVIS JONES IS STILL
ON THE BOARD.
>> HE WOULD'VE BEEN A
CONSIDERATION FOR THEM AT THE
END OF ROUND ONE.
>> THIS IS A TEAM, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO DO IT COME IS
GOING TO BE THAT THEY LOST BOTH
CARDS.
CAPITAL MOVED ON AND MARK PAT
MOVED ON BUT THE GUARD, LOOK AT
JACKIE, 28 STARTS, 24 RIGHT
TACKLE PLAYED FOUR GAMES AT
TIGHT END AND HE CAME AS A
TIGHT END AND PUT ON 100
POUNDS.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF THE VALUE
HERE IT 57?
>> THEY NEEDED A GUARD AND WE
KNOW HOW THE BOARD HAS GONE.
HE IS MY 86TH OVERALL PLAYER.
FORMER TIGHT END TURNED TACKLE.
STARTED IN 2010 TEAM AND MISSED
220 BECAUSE OF INJURY.
THE ARM LENGTH WOULD MOVE HIM
INSIDE SHORTER ARMS LIKE A FIRE
HYDRANT.
HE TAKES NAMES AS A RUN
BLOCKER.
HE IS AN KICKER AS A RUN
IT REMINDS ME OF RODGER
SAFFOLD.
>> AND THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
THE BOX WINE IS GOOD AND YOU
WILL KEEP THINGS SIMPLE.
HE IS A GUARD IS A LITTLE OFF
ENDED A B+.
HE WAS FINE AS A PASS PROTECTOR
IN COLLEGE KICKING INSIDE WAS
ALWAYS HIS ROAD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS GUY
HERE?
>> HE'S A BULLY.
WE TALKED ABOUT SKYY MOORE
COMING UP PLAYING G5 BUT NOT
POWER FIVE.
THIS DOES NOT LOOK THE SAME
WHEN A GUARD DOMINATES BECAUSE
THE STATS ARE THE SAME BUT YOU
DO SEE TOTAL DOMINATION AND
TEAMS EITHER OPTED TO LIVE NOT
LINE UP OVER TOP OF HIM OR THEY
DECIDE TO SLANT MOVE FROM PLACE
AND THE DEFENSE TRIED TO DO
THINGS AGAINST HIM IN SLANT AND
MAKE IT HARD FOR HIM BECAUSE
THEY KNEW IF WE LINED UP HEAD
OVER HIM WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE PROTECTED
FROM WHEN YOU PLAYED THE GUARD
SPOT YOU ARE PROTECTED FROM
THAT.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT WHEN YOU
SEE THE TACKLE CLIPS AND THAT'S
WHERE I LOVE TO SEE HIM AND I
LOVE TO WATCH THE WAY HE CAN GO
OUT THERE AND BODY PEOPLE UP.
>> I THINK IT'S AN EASY
TRANSITION IN TERMS OF THIS.
THEY TRADED WITH NEW ENGLAND
BECAUSE TOM BRADY FELT
COMFORTABLE.
RYAN JENSEN IT CENTER DONOVAN
SMITH THE LEFT TACKLE.
YOU PUT THIS GUY IN BETWEEN AND
NOBODY IS MESSING WITH RYAN
JENSEN THERE.
THEN YOU HAVE MASON NECK GREG
GARD AND JASON IT CENTER AND
THIS KID AT LEFT GUARD AND
DONOVAN SMITH.
IF YOU ARE MAKING A RUN WITH
TOM BRADY YOU CAN'T HAVE A HOLE
AND LEFT GUARD BUT YOU ARE
TUCKED BETWEEN TWO GOOD PLAYERS
AND THE DEVELOPMENT SHOULD BE
EASY.
>> WE LOOKED AT A LOT OF TACKLE
FOOTAGE BUT WHEN HE KICKED DOWN
THE GUARD THIS GUY IS A
MONSTER.
HIS GUYS ON EITHER SIDE OF HIM.
TEAMS WILL LEARN REALLY EARLY,
MAYBE WE SHOULD NOT HAVE PUT
THAT GUY OVER THERE BECAUSE HE
JUST WASHED DOWN THAT ENTIRE
SIDE.
THAT WILL BE THE BEAUTY OF THAT
TECH FOR THE BUCCANEERS.
>> THEY ARE FORTIFYING THEIR
LINES AND IT'S INCREDIBLE THE
AMOUNT OF TIMES I'VE HEARD
PEOPLE SAY HE'S AN OKAY TACKLE.
ZACK MARTIN BECAME ALL-PRO.
ATLANTA TAKES TROY ANDERSON
WHICH CAUSES A FIST PUMP FROM
MICHAEL CHEN ONE.
DEFENSIVE PLAYER LOCKING THE
15TH GETTING RIGHT AFTER THE
QUARTERBACK TOREY ANDERSON THE
PICK.
I SEE A LOT OF FOUR DUMBA WHICH
MEANS PROBABLY NOT A BIG SCHOOL
AND IT WASN'T.
MONTANA STATE, BIG PLAYER?
>> ATLANTA HAS HAD AN AWESOME
DRAFT AND YOU TALK ABOUT
SOMEBODY THAT WAS AN EXCELLENT
COLLEGE RUNNING BACK WAS AN ALL
CONFERENCE QUARTERBACK AND THEN
MOVED TO LINEBACKER.
THIS IS IN COLLEGE, NOT HIGH
SCHOOL.
THE TRACK ATHLETE IN HIGH
SCHOOL, ONE OF THE BEST
ATHLETES TO COME OUT OF THE
STATE OF MONTANA EVER WHEN YOU
LOOK AT TROY ANDERSON HE IS THE
CLASSIC.
GUYS FELT HIS PRESENCE.
YOU LOOK AT THE COACHES TAPE
AND YOU SEE THE RUNNING BACK
AND HE DROPS THE RUNNING BALL
BECAUSE THEY FELT HIM RUNNING
100 MILES AN HOUR.
HE IS LEARNING TO PLAY RUN
LINEBACKER.
COMING DOWNHILL.
IF YOU NEED A RUN AND CHASE
BECKER WITH A COVER THREE
SCHEME SIDELINE TO SIDELINE AS
A BLITZER.
I THINK HE COULD HAVE BEEN AN
NFL RUNNING BACK.
THAT'S THE KIND OF RUNNER HE
IS.
INSANELY FAST AND EXPLOSIVE.
THE VERTICAL AND THE 40.
HE HAS TO FIGURE IT OUT COMING
DOWNHILL.
>> AND LIKE THAT ATLANTA HAS
TAKEN HIM THIS IS GOOD VALUE.
THE GREEN LIGHT WILL COME ON.
>> IT SOUNDED LIKE A DEFENSIVE
CORDARRELLE PATTERSON.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF TROY
ANDERSON?
>> THE WAY HE PLAYS IS SO FUN
TO WATCH.
HE IS A WILL.
HE'S A HUNTER.
HE WILL TRACK YOU DOWN.
WE SAW THE CLIPS WHERE YOU SEE
HIM BANG ON PEOPLE.
I'M LOOKING AND I'M LOOKING AND
I'M FINDING AND NOW I'M GOING
TO GET IT.
HE IS LEARNING ABOUT THE WAY
THE DEFENSE WILL FIT HAND-IN-
HAND IN LEARNING ABOUT THAT
PART OF THE FOOTBALL GAME.
THE WAY HE RUNS SIDE TO SIDE.
>> 100-METER CHAMP IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
HE IS IN MONTANA BUT STILL.
>> IS THERE A FEAR, AND ALL
SCHOOLS HERE?
>> I DON'T THINK SO, I'M GIVING
THIS AN A. THE KEY FOR ME IS HE
IS A PLAYER I LIKE.
DO I WISH IT WAS NAKOBE DEAN,
YES BUT HE IS A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF LINEBACKER.
I DON'T NEED TROY ANDERSON.
I NEED HIM TO PLAY OFF THE BALL
AND THE BACKSIDE AND RUN
EVERYTHING DOWN AS WE FUNNEL IT
BACK TO HIM.
SCRAPE BACKSIDE DAY AND WE WILL
GET THE BALL BACK TO YOU AND
YOU MAKE 120 TACKLE.
>> IT SHOULD BE VERY
INTERESTING.
THE MANAGER DIDN'T NEED A
CORNERBACK.
HE SOUNDS LIKE THE FIRST
PERFECT HUMAN.
VALEDICTORIAN HIGH SCHOOL TO
PLAY QUARTERBACK PLAYS DEFENSE.
ANDERSON THE PICK FOR THE
FALCONS THERE.
59 MINNESOTA AND WE'VE BEEN
SEEING MOVED AND MOVED, CONNOR
TERMS OF PEOPLE LEFT THAT MIGHT
FIT THEM?
>> WE TALK ABOUT HOW ATLANTA
PASSED ON THE QUARTERBACK
THERE?
COMPLETELY.
>> THEY ARE COOL WITH MARCUS
MARIOTA RATHER THIS LATE IN THE
SECOND ROUND AND I LIKE TROY
ANDERSON.
I THINK THIS IS A GOOD THING
FOR ATLANTA.
IT'S PRETTY SHOCKING.
>> ED INGRAM MINNESOTA WENT
SECONDARY WITH THE FIRST TWO
PICKS AND ANDREW KRUSE THE
CORNERBACK AND NOW THEY ARE
GOING WITH AN OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
WHAT DO WE THINK FOR THE VALUE?
>> NOT GREAT.
124 HERE.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE A LATE
THIRD ROUND PLAYER.
HOT AND COLD FILM.
THERE ARE SOME GAMES AND
ALREADY CAN DO AND IN 2020 HIS
CONSISTENCY AS A PASS PROTECTOR
IS GOOD.
AND CAN HE FIND THAT MEAN
STREAK AND IS THE ATHLETIC
ENOUGH.
THIS IS NOT WHERE I WOULD TAKE
THIS PLAYER PERSONALLY.
HE IS A DECENT ATHLETE, ED
INGRAM.
NOT GOOD AT GETTING TO THE
SECOND LEVEL BUT NORTH AND
SOUTH IS ENOUGH STRENGTH.
THE.
>> DOES NOT EXCITE ME.
A THIRD OR FOURTH ROUND PLAYER
AT A POSITION YOU CAN FIND
STARTED THERE IN A C+ WITH ME.
>> STEAM DRAFTED CHRISTIAN
DARRISAW AND HE IS YOUR LEFT
TACKLE BRIAN ONIEL FISHER RIGHT
TACKLE.
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE COMPETING
WITH JESSE DAVIS FOR RATE CARD.
CAN YOU HIDE HIM.
I'M NOT EVEN TALK ABOUT THAT.
HOW ABOUT I SHUT THE HELL UP
AND LET YOU TALK.
I THINK THIS GUY IS GOOD
ENOUGH.
>> INTERESTING.
>> EVEN IN THE MINICLIP PACKAGE
THE BIG THING FOR ME IS THE
OVEREXTEND HIMSELF IN PLACE
HIGH.
WHEN YOU OVEREXTEND AND PLAY
HIDE IN AND TAKE ADVANTAGE.
HE IS A STRONG PLAYER.
HE'S ABLE TO PASS OFF THE TWIST
AND HE GETS HELP.
WE DOESN'T GET HELP THE
QUARTERBACKS ON THE GROUND.
GOOD JOB.
STICK TO HIM AND DON'T PUSH
THEM IN THE BACK ALSO.
THE BIG THING FOR ME, WHEN HE
HAS HELPED SHE CAN DO IT.
HE SAW THE HELP MONDAYS
UNCOVERED HELPING DOWN INSIDE.
HE'S GOT A LITTLE BIT OF
ATHLETICISM AND YOU WANT TO
MAKE THAT MORE VIOLENT.
I GIVE THIS A C. I THINK HE WAS
PART OF A QUALITY LSU OFFENSIVE
LINE.
I WONDER WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
WITHOUT THE HELP.
>> HE WAS THERE FOR A LONG
TIME.
BACK TO HELP, I DON'T THINK
HE'S DOING IT BY HIMSELF.
IF YOU PLAY GUARD YOU HAVE
HELP.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR GRADE?
>> I GAVE IT A C.
>> THERE ANY CHANCE THERE AND
CANARD COULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER
PICK THERE?
>> YES.
>> WHO IS YOUR MAN CRUSH?
>> TRE MORRIS ALL YEAR.
>> OUT OF GEORGIA.
>> IN REGARD I SEE I GET
FRUSTRATED.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THAT WILL
BE HAPPENING?
>> I HAVE NOT HEARD ANYTHING.
>> IT IS THE LACK OF
MEASURABLE.
HE'S JUST A PLAYER.
IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT HE'S THE
BIGGEST OR THE FASTEST HE'S A
BULLY AND A FIRE HYDRANT 63320
BUT HE DIDN'T RUN THE 40.
>> IS NOT A SUPER ATHLETE.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO DRY WALK
AND BE A SKIING.
PROBABLY A HAIR UNDER 63 WHEN I
MENTIONED IN HIGH SCHOOL HE
REMIND ME OF RAFAEL FROM THE
NINJA  TURTLES.
>> BUFFALO IS ON THE CLOCK.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS KAIIR ELAM
AND A LOT OF TRADING BACK.
THIS ATTACKING CORNERBACK
BECAUSE OF THE INJURIES THEY
TRIED TO FIND J.D.
MCKISSIC.
MAYBE THEY GO RUNNING BACK
BECAUSE THE BILLS ARE STACKED
EVERYWHERE IN THIS TEAM IS
READY TO MAKE A SUPER BOWL RUN
THE BENGALS ARE ON THE CLOCK.
CINCINNATI WAS KICKING DOWN AT
63 THE SECOND OF THE LAST PICK
MOVING UP IN THE QUESTION IS
WHY WOULD THEY NEED TO JUMP
KANSAS CITY AND SAN FRANCISCO
IN ORDER TO GET THIS ANDY
GANNON YOU ARE LOOKING AT THE
BIG BOARD THERE THEY MAY HAVE
TRADED THE 63RD PICK SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY HAVE GIVEN UP
YET AND IT STUDENTS GOING TO BE
CINCINNATI HERE AT 61.
ANY GUESSES HERE, CONNOR?
>> WE SAW HIM GET TAX
YESTERDAY, RIGHT AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT FROM THEM I THINK
IT'S EARLY.
THEY COULD STILL USE A TIGHT
END I KNOW THEY HAVE HAYDEN
HURST AND THEY HAD CJ OSAMA, A
HUGE PART OF THEIR OFFENSE.
IT WOULDN'T SHOCK ME TO SEE A
JEREMY WALKER TYPE CLEAR AND
YOU COULD LOOK INTO GREG
DULCICH.
I AM ON TIGHT END HERE.
>> COULD THEY GO WITH THE CAR
THAT YOU GUYS WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT?
>> THEY SIGNED THREE OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
>> TED KARRAS AND ALEC CAMPBELL
ARE OLDER AND IF WE LEARNED
ANYTHING WE NEED THAT AND IT IS
TAYLOR BRITT.
>> CAM TAYLOR-BRITT.
>> WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
YESTERDAY.
>> MAYBE WE NEED TO REPLACE ELI
APPLE HE IS ON A 4-YEAR DEAL
AND WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM.
CAM TAYLOR-BRITT OUT OF
NEBRASKA.
>> A POOR MAN'S DEVIN McCOURTY.
FELDNER AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS.
HE LOVED TO COME DOWN AND HIT.
YOU SEE HIM BLITZING.
>> HIM AND DAX HELP.
>> THEY LIKE THEIR ATHLETES.
WHEN I LOOK AT DELIBERATE HE IS
A FUN PLAYER.
HE CAN DO A LOT OF THINGS FOR
YOU.
LIKE WHEN EVERYTHING IS KEPT IN
FRONT OF HIM.
HE CAN COME DOWN AND GET HOME
HELP QUICKLY AND TACKLE FIND
THE FOOTBALL.
ONCE AGAIN, DO I THINK HE WILL
BE THIS OUTSIDE MAN-TO-MAN LONG-
TERM CORNER?
LIKE ZACH SILL IN A SUPER WAY.
>> SUPER VERSATILE.
>> HE IS A SOLID PLAYER.
THE BENGALS ARE THINKING ABOUT
2023.
>> I'M ALSO THINKING ABOUT THE
BUFFALO BILL FROM THE KANSAS
CITY CHIEFS THIS YEAR.
>> I'M GIVING IT AN A. I LOVE
THIS GUY.
HE IS SO VERSATILE PLAYING WIDE
RECEIVER CONNECTED TO CORNER.
PLAYS LIKE A SAFETY AS YOU
MENTIONED, CONNOR.
HE IS SO WILLING TO BE VIOLENT
I LOVE THAT.
>> AND AGAIN ALL THE CONTRACTS
ARE UP AFTER THIS YEAR.
RICHARD SHERMAN DO YOU LIKE CAM
TAYLOR-BRITT?
>> YES, I REALLY DO.
I REALLY DO.
WE TALKED ABOUT ELI APPLE AND
CHIDOBE AWUZIE A LAST YEAR.
THAT THEY PUT OUT THERE AND
THERE WAS PROBABLY HIS BEST
YEAR.
ELI APPLE HAD A PRETTY SOLID
YEAR AND THEN HE GOT INTO THE
HEADLINES FOREVER TOO MANY
CONVERSATIONS.
THIS GUY COULD BE ANOTHER GUY
WHO'S PLUG AND PLAY AND GET
SOME THAT THAT THE MAKES THE
CORNERBACK COMPETITION A QUICK
OPPORTUNITY.
HE WILL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO START IF HE CAN
ABSORB THE GAME AND BE READY.
HE'S TACKLING AN AGGRESSIVE AND
I THINK HE HAS A CHANCE TO
PLAY.
I DON'T SEE THEM PENCILING
STARTERS AND WAS DRAFTING HIM
IN THE SECOND ROUND.
>> MY FAVORITE THING ABOUT CAM
TAYLOR-BRITT IS THE COACHES SAY
THE TEMPERATURE OF THE ROOM
RISES WHEN HE ENTERS.
I HEAR OUR RICHARD SHERMAN
LIKES CERTAIN THINGS THAT TANIA
ROGERS IS SAYING.
RICHARD, WHAT ARE SOME OF YOUR
FAVORITE THINGS CONNOR HAS BEEN
SAYING DURING THE DRAFT?
>> YOU KNOW, I MEAN, WE COULD
TALK ABOUT DRAKE ONE BEING A
KELDON JOHNSON LIKE, HIS
HIGHEST COURT IN THE FLOOR ON
THESE GUYS. I FELT LIKE HE HITS
THIS HIGH FLOOR ON 37 GUYS IN
HIS DRAFT SO FAR.
I LIKE IT.
>> CONNOR?
>> A LOT OF STARTERS HE DAY TWO
OF THIS DRAFT.
A NICE WAY OF SAYING NOT TO
START IS THE WAY I WOULD PUT
IT, RICHARD SHERMAN.
I WOULD NEVER CALL HIM A KYLAN
JOHNSON MIGHT.
WE WILL STICK WITH DRAKE
LONDON.
>> HE DID NOT SAY THAT ONE BUT
I LIKE HIS LIGHT VERSIONS.
>> WHO WERE THE LIGHT ONES?
>> WE CAN CALL IT DIET COKE OR
LIGHT.
>> I JUST SAID POOR MAN'S DEVIN
McCOURTY ABOUT CAM TAYLOR-
BRITT.
I NEVER WANT TO BE THE PLAYER
COP GUIDE THAT HEY THERE'S
JULIO JONES AND RICHARD SHERMAN
IN THIS DRAFT A LOT OF PEOPLE
OFF GARDENER RICHARD SHERMAN.
>> I CALLED GARDENER RICHARD
SHERMAN.
>> I WASN'T GOING TO GO THERE
AND I FELT LIKE IT WAS RICH FOR
ME BUT I LIKE IT AND I AM
BRANDON YOU AGREE WITH IT.
>> I THINK HE IS A LINE IN THE
DISRUPT SOON AND I THINK HE IS
MORE DEVELOPED THAN I WAS EARLY
ON.
I DEVELOPED LATE AND GOT REALLY
CONSISTENT.
>> NINERS GOING DRAKE JACKSON
AND I'M PICKING A FIGHT WITH
RICHARD SHERMAN AFTER THIS.
IF YOU COME FOR CONNOR YOU COME
FOR ALL OF US.
DRAKE JACKSON OUT OF U.S.C.
6'0", 254.
HIS AGENT GOT ADAM SCHEFTER TO
TWEET ABOUT HIM.
DRAKE JACKSON AND DRESCHER HERE
FOR SAN FRANCISCO TEAM LOOKING
FOR SOMEONE THE OPPOSITE SIDE
OF NICK BOSA.
>> I COMPARED THEM TO ARDENB KE
WHO THEY JUST LOST THEY HAD A
BREAKOUT YEAR AND HE LEFT IN
FREE AGENCY.
JACKSON 9-6-6 RELATIVE ATHLETIC
SCORE AND A GREAT ATHLETE.
DOCTOR U.S.C.
AND NEVER BECAME THE GUY WE
WERE HOPING FOR HIM TO BE, A
DOMINANT PASS RUSHER.
HE IS A FINESSE RUNNER, HE CAN
STARTED STOP.
HE CAN BEAT YOU INSIDE OR
OUTSIDE WITH THAT STARTER STEP.
YOU DON'T SEE THE REALITY OF
THE OFFENSIVE LINE IN THE NFL
IF THEY KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE THE
POWER THEY KNOW YOU ARE
PREDICTABLE AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE BIG BOARD FOR HIM 70
FIRST SO THE VALUE IS NOT
REALLY CRAZY BUT IF SAN
FRANCISCO NEEDS INCIDENT IMPACT
WE ARE ABOUT TWO YEARS AWAY AND
I GIVE THIS ONE A B- RIGHT
HERE.
>> I LOVED HIM COMING OUT OF
RECRUITING.
THEY THOUGHT HE WOULD BE SOME
VERSION OF WHETHER IT WAS MILES
GARRETT.
THIBODEAU.
I THOUGHT HE WAS THAT AND HE
WASN'T.
YOU HAVE TO GET HIM TO BE MORE
VIOLENT.
HIS HANDS HAVE TO BE MORE
HE HAS TO TRANSITION SPEED THE
POWER.
I LOVE THE WAY HE CAN GET
STONED AND COME BACK WITH AN
INTERCEPTION.
I WOULD LIKE HIM TO WIN.
I LIKE THE FACT HE CAN CHASE
THINGS DOWN AND I WANT THAT TOO
BUT I WANT TO SEE HIM SET THE
HARD EDGE AND USE A COUNTER
MOVE.
LISTEN.
IT'S A GREAT HIGHLIGHT BECAUSE
HE GETS A SACK BUT NOBODY
TOUCHED HIM.
GET OFF A BLOCK AND GO MAKE A
PLAY.
WE HAD TO WAIT REPLACE TO GET
TO SEE THAT.
THAT'S THE PART I'M LOOKING AT.
I'M GOING TO GIVE IT A B. IT'S
SOMEONE I WANT MORE OUT OF IN
COLLEGE AND I THINK HE WILL
LEAVE US WANTING MORE IN THE
NFL UNTIL SOME GOOD DEFENSIVE
LINE COACH GET HER HAND ON HIM
AND DOES NOT GET AWAY WITH
USING SPEED.
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T THINK
ABOUT THAT COACHING DEFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
I PICKED THIS UP FROM FRANCE A
PLAYED WITH BUTCH DAVIS AND
BUTCH DAVIS DID NOT LET YOU DO
IT THE EASY WAY OR USING SPEED
ONLY.
HE THROTTLED DOWN GUYS TO MAKE
THEM DO THINGS THE RIGHT WAY.
AND THEN YOU COULD USE YOUR
SPEED ONCE YOU HAVE PASSED
BRUSH MOVES.
>> BUT TALK TO AHMAD ST. BROWN.
A LOT OF CONCERN APPEARED, DO
YOU SHARE THAT.
>> I DO NOT.
I LOVE THIS.
WHEN JAKE FIRST GOT TO U.S.C.
FRESHMAN YEAR HE BALLED OUT AND
WE GOT A NEW DEFENSIVE
COORDINATOR SOPHOMORE YEAR AND
THEY WANTED HIM TO LOSE WEIGHT.
HE LOST WEIGHT SOPHOMORE YEAR
AND HE WASN'T AS STRONG IN MY
OPINION.
HE DID NOT USE HIS STRENGTH TO
HIS ADVANTAGE.
WHAT HE DID OVER THE COMBINE IS
AGAINST ITS WAY BACK AND AM
SUPER EXCITED FOR HIM AND IS
ONE OF THE BEST ATHLETES.
HE CAN DO AROUND OFF AND A
BACKFLIP WITHOUT EVEN THINKING.
HE'S A FREAK ATHLETE THAT CAN
JUMP AND RUN.
I'M EXCITED FOR HIM AND THINGS
ARE AWESOME FOR HIM.
>> HIS BODY TRANSFORMATIONS
HAVE BEEN INTERESTING.
HE LOST 35 POUNDS DURING
QUARANTINE.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT AND YOU WONDER IF HE IS
THAT GOOD HE COULD PROBABLY
SUSTAIN IT AS WELL.
HE COULD BE A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT PLAYER BUT SAN
FRANCISCO WILL FIND A DIFFERENT
WAY TO USE HIM.
KANSAS CITY IS ON THE CLOCK AND
WE GOT TINTED EARLIER BUT LOVE
THE DRAFT GETTING PUT TOGETHER.
McDUFFIE ON THE CORNER AND THEY
GET SKYY MOORE, THE WIDE
RECEIVER.
>> IMPACT GUYS, ALL THREE.
>> AND VERY DEFINED ROLLS.
>> WHAT ARE WE THINKING HERE?
COULD THEY GO OFFENSIVE LINE?
COULD THEY GO ANOTHER WIDE
RECEIVER?
>> I AM SHOCKED RAYMOND IS ON
THE BOARD.
>> TAKE HIM.
>> AND LET HIM SIT.
>> WHAT IF THEY THREW A TRAVIS
JONES ON THAT THE LINE IN BOTH
UP AT THE LINE THAT DOES NOT
HAVE A LOT OF SIZE.
21 AGAINST THE RUN WITH A LOT
OF INJURIES LAST YEAR.
>> YES.
I WOULD BE ALL ABOUT IT.
>> WHAT ABOUT NAKOBE DEAN?
>> SURE.
>> THERE ARE CERTAIN GM'S
WHETHER THE MEDICAL OR SIZE,
THEY OPERATED AT ARE YOU GOOD
AT FOOTBALL AND WE LIKE YOU
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GO TO THE
SUPER BOWL.
>> WHO IS THE PLAYER HERE.
RYAN COOK GO SAFETY.
START WITH FELDNER.
SAFETY IS THE PICK HERE AFTER
THEY WENT CORNER TREATMENT
FEEDE FIVE JUSTIN REID BUT THEY
MAY HAVE LOST HONEY BADGER.
THIS KID OUT OF CINCINNATI YOU
LIKE HIM A LOT.
>> IS ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYERS IN THE ENTIRE DRAFT.
YOU SEE HIM PEELING OFF THE MAN
TO GO GET HELP AND PROVIDE HELP
TO MAKE A PLAY AND HE'S AN
AMAZING TACKLER AND WHEN YOU
PLAY MAN COVERAGE HUGE GAPS
OPEN UP AND HE'S A RACER HE CAN
GET THE JOB DONE AND I THINK HE
IS FOR ME I HAD HIM AS MY 2.5
SAFETY AND HE IS A VIOLENT
TACKLER BUT ASSURED TACKLER AS
WELL.
THE FACT THAT HE PLAYED SO MUCH
MAN COVERAGE WITH ME KNOW HE
WILL PLAY MAN COVERAGE.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE.
THE SKY, RYAN COOK SOMEONE THAT
IS GOING TO HAVE A HOME IN THE
NFL VERY QUICKLY AND VOTE WILL
GET TO KNOW HIM VERY WELL.
>> A TRANSFER FOR HOWARD AT THE
CINCINNATI AND NEVER LOOKED.
I LIKE THIS PLAYER.
350 PLUS NAPS IN THE BOX, 186
IN THE SLOT.
300 EVERY SAFETY.
ANYTHING THEY NEEDED HIM TO DO
HE DID IT SUCCESSFULLY.
>> AND HE KNOWS ALL ABOUT
CONFUSING WITH TWO NEW GUYS.
RICHARD SHERMAN ARE YOU IS HIGH
ON BRIAN COOK AS THEY ARE WHAT
DO YOU HAVE OVER THERE?
SHARE THE FOOD.
WHAT ARE YOU EATING?
>> IT WAS LUNCH.
>> NO.
I'M NOT GIVING IT TO YOU.
>> ONION RINGS.
BATTERED OR REGULAR.
>> THEY ARE CLASSIC.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS KID.
BRIAN COOK IS ALL.
>> I THINK HE IS AN ENFORCER.
I SEE WHAT YOU DID THERE.
THEY LOST THE LANDLORD WITH
TYRANN MATHIEU.
HE SPENT AN ENFORCER AND THE
LANDLORD IN KANSAS CITY FOR
MOST OF THE SUPER BOWL RUNS AND
A PIVOTAL PART OF IT.
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO
REPLACE THAT AGGRESSION AND
TENACITY.
I THINK THEY HAVE DONE IT.
TYRANN MATHIEU IS A BIG TIME
PLAYMAKER IN THE PAT'S RUN AND
EVERY PARTNER GAME.
THIS GUY WILL MAKE AN IMPACT AS
WELL AND HE WILL BE A BIG TIME
HITTER TAKE THE BALL AWAY AND
COMBAT DARREN WALLER AND TITANS
IN THE AFC WEST THAT IS HUGE.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO STOP DARREN
WALLER.
THE RAIDERS WILL BE AN ISSUE
ESPECIALLY WITH DAVANTE ADAMS.
>> WE HEAR A LITTLE EXCITEMENT.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR THE
EXCITEMENT ON JASON KELSEY'S
VOICE.
HE'S NOW JOINING YOUR BROTHER,
ANOTHER UC GUY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> DUDE, THIS IS ANOTHER
PICTURE OF A BEARCAT TEAM.
BEST TEAM IN COLLEGE HISTORY.
I'M SO EXCITED FOR THIS KID.
HE'S GOING TO A GREAT SITUATION
AND KC AND ANDY REID LOVES
THOSE BEARCAT.
>> AFTER ME, MY BROTHER, TRENT
COLE, BRENT CELEK.
HIS TRACK RECORD IS PHENOMENAL.
I CANNOT WAIT FOR THIS KID TO
GET THERE WITH BIG RED IN THE
KANSAS CITY CHIEFS UNIFORM.
HE'S A PLAYMAKER AND ALL OVER
THE FIELD.
MAN I AM EXCITED.
LET'S GO, BABY.
>> THERE IS NOTHING BETTER.
BILLS SELECT CHAINS COOK WITH
THE SECOND TO LAST.
OF THE SECOND ROUND.
IF MY MIND SERVES ME RIGHT SIDE
AND I LIKE THE HAIL MARYS.
I WENT FOR.
>> LISTENED.
I LOVE IT.
IT CAME OFF THE TOP ROW.
>> JAMES COOK BUT IN ALL-
PURPOSE GUARDS.
THE YOUNGER BROTHER OF DALVIN
COOK GOING TO BUFFALO.
THEY DID NOT HAVE A LOT OF
HOLES AND THEY TRIED TO SIGN
J.D.
McKISSIC.
HE WENT BACK TO WASHINGTON.
DO YOU LIKE HIM IN THIS ROLE?
>> HE REMINDS ME OF BERNARD.
YOU SEE WHERE THEY ARE GOING
WITH JAMES COOK.
HE'S GOT SOME JUICE AND SOME
VERSE AND HE IS PIGEONHOLED AS
A THIRD-DOWN PASS CATCHER AND I
DON'T SEE HIM AS AN EARLY DOWN
PLAYER.
HE WAS CONNECTED TO GUYS LIKE
BRUCE HALL.
IT'S EARLY FOR HIM HERE AND I
THINK MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND I
GO WITH T-MINUS.
>>> 511 FOR 199, 1-4-2.
>> FIRST TIME I EVER SAW HIM
WAS IN ATLANTA IN 2017 AND
AGAIN IN 2017 AND OREGON.
AND THE MOUTH AND THE CHIRP,
NONSTOP.
HIM JUST TALKING TO GUYS AND
TALKING TO GUYS AND TALKING THE
GUYS.
HE LINED UP AND THE LINEBACKERS
AND THE CAT AND MOUSE JILL ATE
THEIR LUNCH TO NOT GO GET LUNCH
AND WENT TO THE WIDE RECEIVER
AND UP AGAINST THE BEST CORNERS
HE'S LIKE REFERENCING THE
OPENER.
THIS 150 PLAYERS BEST CORNERS
IN THE COUNTRY ATE THEIR LUNCH
AS A WIDE RECEIVER UNDERUSED TO
GEORGIA.
HE IS INCREDIBLY EXPLOSIVE I AM
NOT SURPRISED HE CAME OFF THE
BOARD BEFORE ZAMIR WHITE.
>> I AGREE.
>> I THINK HE FITS INTO JULES
BERNARD AND HE FITS INTO THAT
GROUP OF GUYS, IF YOU WANT TO
HAND HIM THE BALL 25 TIMES?
NO?
YOU WANT HIM TO TOUCH ABOUT 20
TIMES IN THE GAME?
YES.
I TOLD MY WORK AND I SAINT-JEAN-
DE-MATHA PLAINFIELD LINEMAN
WIDE RECEIVERS AND WE WILL PUT
THEM HERE AND LINE THEM UP OVER
HERE AND MOTIONED HIM INTO THE
BACK.
HE CAN DO EVERYTHING YOU WANT
HIM TO DO AND IS CONFIDENT THAT
HE BELIEVES HE BELONGS IN THE
NFL AND NOBODY CAN TELL HIM
OTHERWISE.
>>> TEARING HIM UP WITH ISAIAH
McKENZIE AND KEVIN DORSEY IS
THE QUARTERBACKS COACH HUNDRED
BRIAN DABOLL.
>> DON'T FORGET SINGLETARY
COMING UP.
>> THE FINAL PICK OF THE SECOND
ROUND, THE BRONCOS SOURCE MIGHT
CAUSE SOME THE BREW CLOTHES.
THEY TECH TAKE NICK BONINO
GOING TO THE DENVER BRONCOS.
WHAT DO WE THINK HERE, CONNOR?
>> WE LIKE IT.
ME AND FELDNER ARE HIGH ON THE
SKY.
ASAAD REDDICK, THEY GAVE HIM A
LOT OF MONEY.
YOU CAN GET CREATIVE WITH HIM.
WHETHER IT'S RUNNING BACKS HE
CAN RUN AND PEEL OUT.
HE PLAYS BIGGER THAN THAT SIZE
AND WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT
TOM CAN YOU HANDLE THE RUN.
HE IS TOUGH GUY FOR THAT SIZE
AND I LOVE THE SITUATIONAL PASS
RUSH ROLE FOR HIM.
RANDY GREGORY AND NOW NIK
BONITTO VALUE SAY IS MONEY
DOWN, THIRD-DOWN, OR TOWNS, GET
ONE WITH THE TACKLE DON'T
UNDERESTIMATE THE POWER.
AN A- FOR ME AND PASS RUSH FOR
ME AS YOU GET OFF THE FIELD
WITH PATRICK MAHOMES.
>> 30% OF TACKLES BEHIND THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
IS HE A GUY THOUGH?
>> I LOVE HIM.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
NO SURPRISE TO ME THAT HE IS
THE FIRST OKLAHOMA DEFENDERS
OFF THE BOARD.
I LOVE THE WAY HE COMES OFF THE
BOARD IS THE FIRST ONE.
WATCHING HIM PLAY I'M GOING TO
GIVE THIS IN A. GETTING A GUY I
THOUGHT WAS PROBABLY THE TOP
HALF OF THE SECOND ROUND GUY AT
THE BACK END AND THE LAST
OFFICIAL PICK OF THE SECOND
ROUND IS GOOD VALUE.
YOU PUT THEM WITH RANDY GREGORY
AND JONATHON COOPER VICKI CAN
PITY HIS EARS BACK AND GET THE
QUARTERBACK.
HE WILL BE EXCEPTIONALLY
VIOLENT.
I THINK THAT THE BIG PLUS.
NIK BONITTO IS A GOOD PLAYER
AND I LOVE THE WAY HE BRINGS
FIRE TO THE TABLE.
DENVER WRAP UPS, GETTING A
LINEBACKER, ODDLY ENOUGH WAS
FROM THE TRADE FOR VON MILLER,
TRYING TO GET SOME DEPTH THERE
FOR THE NEW HEAD COACH NATE
HACKETT ON THE DEFENSIVE SIDE.
DO YOU LOVE THIS DRAFT THEY
COVERAGE IN THE PALM OF YOUR
HANDS?
OUR SHOW SPONSORED BY ROCKET
MORTGAGE AND THEY MADE IT
POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO GET A HOME
LOAN RIGHT HERE ON THE SAME
PHONE.
IF YOU SHOWED US OFF AND GO TO
ROCKET MORTGAGE, JUST WAIT
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW UNTIL THE
THIRD ROUND IS OVER AND GET
YOUR TO ROCKET MORTGAGE WITH
THE PROCESS BUILT AROUND YOUR
NEEDS WHEN YOU NEED A HOME LOAN
THAT FITS YOU.
THIRD ROUND AND I JUST WANT TO
SAY NAKOBE DEAN HAS NOT BEEN
DRAFTED, MALIK WILLIS STILL HAS
NOT BEEN DRAFTED, TRAVIS JONES,
ALL OF THE QUARTERBACKS HAVE
NOT GROWN.
>> HOW MANY QUARTERBACKS?
>> ZERO QUARTERBACKS.
>> ALL WE HEARD WAS A RUN ON
QUARTERBACKS.
WE SAW THE QUARTERBACKS ALL GO?
THIS IS SURPRISING TO SEE TEAMS
HOLD THEIR WATER LIKE THAT.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE THIS
QUARTERBACK EXPECT THE JAGUARS
ARE GOING LUKE FORTNER.
LUKE FORTNER.
CENTER FOR KENTUCKY GOING HERE,
AND FINALLY, THE JACKSONVILLE
JAGUARS GET SOME PROTECTION FOR
TREVOR LAWRENCE, CONNOR.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT FORTNER
OBVIOUSLY WE SAW STRANGE GO OFF
THE BOARD AND JURGENS.
THIS IS MY FOURTH CENTER IN THE
CLASS AND THIS FEELS RIGHT AT
THIS SPOT UNLESS YOU PLAY
DILLON BAR.
HE'S GOT HEAVY FEET AND A 24-
YEAR-OLD ROOKIE GOING INTO
TRAINING CAMP.
HE REALLY STRUGGLED TO GET OUT
IN FRONT IN SCREENS.
ANYTHING WIDE IN THE RUN GAME.
HE'S GOT A STRONG ANCHOR BUT
THE LACK OF ATHLETICISM
CONCERNED ME THE THREE CONE
VERTICAL AND IT'S ON TAPE.
HE COULD NOT GET TO HIS SPOTS
IN TIME.
THIS IS A C FOR ME.
I DO NOT THINK HE IS A LONG-
TERM ANSWER JACKSONVILLE THAT'S
WHAT THEY ARE DRAFTING HIM TO
BE.
>> BRANDON LONDON RETIRED AND
THIS IS THE GUY THAT SLIDES IN.
>> FIRST TEAM ALL SEC DOUBLE-
DIGIT START THE GARDEN CENTER
AND THEY WENT DEFENSE WITH THE
FIRST TWO PICKS.
WALKER, BOYD AND WE'VE SEEN
JURGENS COME OFF THE BOARD AND
LENDER MOM.
BE IT DID NOT FIT RIGHT WITH
THEIR BOARD.
DO YOU THINK OF THIS GUYS AS
THE FUTURE TREVOR LAWRENCE?
>> HE'S THE BEST ON HIS TEAM.
>> CANARD IS STILL ON THE
BOARD.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN HIM HE WILL
GIVE YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO WIN.
THE REALITY IS HE
I'D LOVE TO SEE HIM THERE.
GET HIS HIPS TURNED, GET
UNDERNEATH.
USE HIS LEVERAGE AND DO THAT.
HE CAN DO THAT.
IF HE'S A TEAM THAT THAT'S ALL
YOU'RE GOING TO ASK HIM TO DO.
PLAY IN A PHONE BOOTH.
GREAT WAY TO PUT IT, CONNOR.
I DON'T THINK HE'S THE BEST
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
WHY NOT GET THAT GUY AND SEE
WHAT YOU CAN DO WITH HIM.
>> NOT EVEN THAT GOOD AT RIGHT
TACKLES.
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE THIS A C
MINUS.
LARGELY ROOTED IN THE FACT
THAT -- STILL ON THE BOARD.
YOU COULD HAVE HAD HIM.
THIS TO ME DOESN'T FEEL LIKE A
HUGE UPGRADE AT THE CENTER
POSITION, WHEN YOU COULD HAVE
HAD AN ACTUAL UPGRADE.
>> INTERESTING.
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS, DEFENSE,
DEFENSE, AND THEN CENTER, AND
NOW MINNESOTA IS ON THE CLOCK,
MINNESOTA, WE'VE SEEN THEM GO
SAFETY, CORNER, OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN.
YOU SAID THEY'D MAYBE GO WIDE
RECEIVER.
THEY'RE GOING BRIAN OSMOA TO THE
VIKINGS.
>> MONEY BACKER, WHAT YOU'D CALL
IT.
>> TWO PICKS AHEAD OF TELEVISION
RIGHT NOW.
THEY DID GET JORDAN HICKS, ERIC
KENDRICKS, BUT YOU ARE SAYING
HE'S THE MONEY LINEBACKER.
RYAN OSAMOA.
LEARN HOW TO SPELL PEOPLE'S
NAMES, IT MATTERS TO THEM.
CONNOR ROGERS, WHAT DO YOU
THINK?
>> HE'S A RUNNING CHASE GUY.
PLAYING UNDER 230 POUNDS.
PLAYING IN SPACE, AND KEEPING
HIM CLEAN, NOT GETTING OFFENSIVE
LINEMEN CLIMBING TO HIM.
HE CAN MAKE PLAYS SIDELINE TO
SIDE LYNN, RUN AND COVER, WHICH
IS SOMETHING I REALLY LIKE, HE'S
A SUBPACKAGE LINEBACKER, YOU
WON'T SEE HIM ON THE FIELD ALL
THREE DOWNS, I LIKE HIM AS THAT
NICKEL OR DIME BACKER.
SHACK THOMPSON LIGHT, SHAQ CAN
SURVIVE ON THE FIELD.
HE DOES BEST TO RUN AND CHASE.
I THINK THIS IS A C PLUS FOR ME.
A SUBPACKAGE PLAYER, A LITTLE
EARLY HERE, BUT HE HAS A DEFINED
ROLE.
>> SHAQ ALSO GOT -- FIRST
ROUNDS.
THIS IS A THIRD-ROUND PICK.
FOR ME, GRADE FOR ME IS "B"
PLUS.
I THINKLESS GOING TO RUN AND
CHASE GUYS DOWN, ADD SPEED TO
YOUR TEAM, YOU GET INTO YOUR
NICKEL PACK BACK, PLAY BIG
NICKEL.
THE MAKEUP, TALK ABOUT THE
VIKINGS, THE VISION OF THOSE
TEAMS PLAYING IN THE NFC, THOSE
ARE GOING TO BE TEAMS THAT WILL
SOMETIMES GO 12 PERSONNEL.
12 PERSONNEL.
YOU STILL MIGHT NEED YOUR NICKEL
PACKAGE DEPENDING ON THE TIGHT
ENDS IN THE GAME.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PUT IN A
SMALLER SAFETY, PUT IN A
SMALLER -- OR A BIGGER SAFETY,
AND A SMALLER LINEBACKER, I LIKE
THE BENEFIT OF THAT, THAT
VERSATILITY, AND THIS GUY'S
GOING TO BE IN ALL YOUR FOUR
CORNERS.
>> HICKS, KENDRICKS, ASAMOAH.
I'M HEARING RICHARD SHERMAN
LIKES YOUR LIGHT.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
LAST THOUGHT ON THIS, TOO, IT'S
NOT -- THE VALUE IS NOT THAT FAR
OFF.
PLAYER 105.
NOT A BAD PICK.
CHAD MUMA IS STILL ON THE BOARD.
LEO CHENAL IS STILL ON THE
BOARD.
>> THEY'RE DIFFERENT PLAYERS.
TRULY, I'M THINKING ABOUT, IF
YOU HAVE TO GO BIG NICKEL, HE
CAN STILL COME IN AND MAKE PLAYS
AT THE LINE OF GYM NAJ.
>> IN THREE YEARS HE MISSED ZERO
GAMES, THE DURABILITY YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR.
THE GIANTS ARE ON THE CLOCK, THE
NEW YORK FOOTBALL GIANTS, WHEN
THIBODEAUX, NEAL, AND ROBINSON.
THEY FOLLOW THAT UP WITH JOSH
AZUDU, THE PICK RT WHAT'S YOUR
TAKE ON IN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
>> I LIKE THE RUN GAME, WHAT
THAT'S BEEN ABLE TO DO THE LAST
TWO YEARS, HE CAN MOVE PEOPLE.
HE PLAYED HA LOT OF TACKLE IN
COLLEGE.
6'4", 308.
EXTREMELY ATHLETIC.
LEFT TACKLE.
GOOD ATHLETE, SUITED FOR A LONG
TERM GUARD ROLE IN MY OPINION.
HE'S BEEN A PART OF SOME UNITS
THEY KNEW HOW TO RUN THE
FOOTBALL.
I HAVE QUESTIONS IN PASS
PROTECTION.
PLAYER 153, I HAD RISING
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS, I FEEL
LIKE I FOUND HIM LATE.
ALMOST A LITTLE TOO LOW FOR ME
BUT PLAYING GUARD OR
TRANSITIONING INTO GUARD AT THE
NEXT LEVEL HURTS THAT.
THE GIANTS NEED HELP.
THEY NEED VALUE.
HE'S LOWER ON THE BOARD BUT THIS
IS A PRETTY DECENT PICK BY THE
GIANTS.
HE'S A LONG TERM STARTER AT
GUARD OR A DEPTH PIECE.
B MY NICE FOR AZUDU.
>> NOW YOU HAVE THE YOUNG GUY
BENEATH HIM, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF AZUDU, MR. NORTH CAROLINA.
>> HERE'S THE THING WITH AZUDU,
THEY HAD A REALLY GOOD RUN GAME
A RAERG, AND LAST YEAR THEY HAD
A GOOD RUN GAME.
TWO VERY DIFFERENT TYPES OF RUN
GAMES, HE WAS ABLE TO BE A GUY
TO MAKE THE PLAYS IN THE RUN
GAME.
LINED UP AT THE GUARD SPOT,
PULL, MAKE PLAYS, I LOVE THAT.
THAT'S WHERE HE'S GOING TO PLAY
AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
THIS IS WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO,
HE'S GOING TO MAKE THESE PLAYS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO -- TIGHT
POLES ARE GOOD FOR HIM, SEE IT
AGAIN, THE PUSH.
THE LITTLE SHIFT, HE'S NOT A
TACKLE.
HE'S A GUARD, PLAY HIM AT THE
GUARD SPOT, SEE HIM AT TACKLE,
AND HE'S PATIENT, CALM, GOOD
ANCHOR.
MOVE THAT INSIDE, HE'S GOING TO
BE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
THEY ASK HIM TO DO.
I AGREE WITH CONNOR, I THINK HE
CAN BE A STARTER AT THE GUARD
SPOT FOR A WHILE IN THE NFL.
DON'T ASK -- IF YOU NEED HIM TO
FINISH OUT A GAME OF TACKLE.
MAYBE HE CAN DO THAT.
I'M GOING WITH A "B."
YOU'RE GETTING SOMEONE YOU KNOW
CAN BE A QUALITY PLAYER, TWO AND
A HALF YEARS AS A STARTER AT
UNC, AND OFFENSE ONE.
YOU LIKE JAVONTAE WILLIAMS,
MICHAEL CARTER, THOSE GUYS NEED
TO OPEN THE HOLE UP.
>> JOSH AZUDU, THE PICK FOR THE
GIANTS.
TACKLES FIGURED OUT WITH THOMAS
AND EVAN NEAL, AND THEY'RE
GETTING FUTURE GUYS.
CLEVELAND BROWNS ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
THEY HAVE YET TO MAKE A PICK IN
THIS DRIFT AND THEIR FIRST PICK
IS MARTIN EMMERSON.THE PICK, THS
DRAFT FOR THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
AGAIN, THEY GAVE UP MOST OF
THEIR PICKS IN THEIR PURSUIT OF
DESHAUN WATSON, HOLES ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
YOUR READ ON MARTIN EMMERSON,
FOURTH PICK.
>> I LIKE OTHER CORNERS BETTER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EMERSON,
REMINDED ME OF ISAIAH.
YOU WORRY A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
LONG SPEED AND THE LACK OF --
>> THE 4, 5, 3 JUMPED OUT TO ME.
>> IT'S NOT A DEAL BREAKER BUT I
DIDN'T THINK HE FOUND THE
FOOTBALL IN COLLEGE.
THAT'S WHAT CONCERNED ME.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING A LOT OF
UPSIDE HERE, ONCE AGAIN, REMINDS
ME OF ISAIAH OLIVER, THE PROBLEM
ONCE AGAIN IS I LIKED A LOT OF
CORNERS BETTER IN THIS DRAFT,
ESPECIALLY COBY BRYANT THAT DOES
ALL THE THINGS I SAID BUT THAT
MUCH HIGHER LEVEL.
THIS IS A C PLUS FOR ME.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
WHY YOU WOULDN'T LIKE HIM.
WHY SHOULD WE LIKE IMIN.
>> HE'S PHYSICAL, HE'S A
FIGHTER, HE'S A BOXER, SOMEONE
YOU WANT ON YOUR SIDE IN A FIST
NIGHT IN AN ALLEY.
WHEN HE PUTS PAWS ON GUYS, THEY
DON'T FORGET ABOUT IT.
HE'S PATIENT.
SEE HIM COME DOWN HERE, CLOSE IT
DOWN IN THE RUN GAME.
HE'LL DO THAT.
I LOVE THE WAY THAT HE PLAYS
ZONE COVERAGE, I LOVE THE WAY
HE'S ABLE TO TRACK GUYS, COME
OUT OF -- HE DOES WHAT YOU NEED
TO GET GUYS DOWN ON THE GROUND.
EFFORT, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
THAT.
THAT'S NOT A GREAT TACKLE.
IT'S NOT.
NOT PRETENDING IT WAS.
BUT HE DOES WHAT HE HAS TO DO TO
GET GUYS ON THE GROUND.
BUT THERE'S A FEW TIMES WHEN YOU
WATCH HIM PLAY THAT HE COMES
THROUGH AND HE DESTROYS PEOPLE.
AND I LIKE THAT PART OF HIS
GAME.
WE DIDN'T GET ANY OF THOSE
CLIPS, TO REENFORCE WHAT I WAS
SAYING.
I THINK THIS IS A B PICK FOR ME.
THERE ARE CORNERS I LIKE MORE
THAN HIM, MARCUS JONES FROM
HOUSTON.
>> GOOD CALL.
>> SMALL GUY, THOUGH.
>> HE WANTED A BIG GUY.
THIS IS THE BIG GUY.
HE'S THE BEST THAT PRESS BAIL AS
YOU MENTIONED.
HE CAN BE PHYSICAL, THE KEY FOR
HIM IS TO NOT MAKE TACKLES,
MARTIN EMERSON, HE PLAYS A LOT
OF DENIAL FOOTBALL, WHEN HE GETS
PAWS OF YOUEN, THE ROUTE IS
DISRUPTED, THE TIMING IS
DISRUPTED.
THAT'S SOMETHING I LIKE TO SEE
OUT OF A CORNER.
>> THEY RESIGNED DENZEL WARD,
HAD SUCCESS WITH GREG NEWSOM,
CAN THIS GUY PLAY ALONGSIDE
THOSE GUYS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE'S A TRUE OUTSIDE CORNER.
I WANT TO MAKE THAT CLEAR.
>> NOW MAYBE MOVE NEWSOM TO THE
INSIDE.
>> NEWSOM IS A PLAYER YOU CAN
MOVE ALL AROUND.
>> TEN CORNERS HAVE COME OFF THE
BOARD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AND SEE WHERE
THEY WENT.
STINGLEY AND SAUCE WENT IN THE
TOP FIVE.
McDUFFIE AND -- TWO WENT AT THE
END OF THE FIRST ROUND.
35, 49, 32 RKS McCREARY, BOOTH.
BRIT GOT A LOT OF LOVE FROM --
GOING TO SNAENT, VERSATILE
SECONDARY, AND FINISH WITH
MARTIN EMERSON, THE RUN HAPPENED
BETWEEN 35 AND TOWARDS THE END
THERE.
DID THEY GO IN AN ORDER THAT
MADE SNS SENSE TO YOU?
>> I'M SURPRISED COBY BRYANT IS
STILL ON THE BOARD.
GOT A LOT OF EXPOSURE, PLAYED
ACROSS FROM SAUCE GARDNER.
HE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
SENIOR BOWL STANDOUT.
I'M SURPRISED HE'S THERE.
I LIKE JOSHUA WILLIAMS FROM
FAYETTEVILLE STATE.
SMALL SCHOOL PLAYER BUT HE LOOKS
THE PART.
>> TEAM THAT TOOK ROGER
McCREARY.
BUT PETIT-FRERE, THE BIG TACKLE
OUT OF OHIO STATE.
NICHOLAS PETIT-FRERE, 6'5", 313.
THEY'RE LOSING ROGER SAFFOLD AT
RIGHT GUARD.
YOU'RE ALSO WONDERING, HOW MUCH
LONGER IS TAYLOR LA JUAN GOING
TO BE PLAYING, WHAT'S THE PLAN
FOR PETIT-FRERE.
>> YOU'LL STASH HIM THIS YEAR.
GROW AS A TACKLE.
I GOT TO SEE HIM PLAY IN PERSON
THIS YEAR, KIND OF A DANCING
BEAR AT THAT SIZE.
THAT WAS IMPRESSIVE TO ME THE
WAY HE CAN CARRY HIS WEIGHT AND
ZIL MOVE.
I LIKE HE PLAYS THROUGHOUT
WHISTLE.
THAT STOOD OUT TO ME AS WELL.
IN TERMS OF THE KIND OF PLAYER,
ANDRE DILLARD.
>> UNFORTUNATELY --
>> AS PROSPECTS.
>> YES.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, THAT'S
WHO HE REMINDED ME OF.
PLAY STYLE AND PROSPECTS.
PETIT-FRERE, I DON'T THINK HE'LL
BE STARTING THIS YEAR.
THEY HAVE HOLES ON THE OFFENSIVE
LINE.
THIS IS A GUY YOU WANT TO DRAFT
AND STASH IN THE THIRD ROUND.
HE HAS LONG TERM STARTER
POTENTIAL.
"B" MINUS FOR ME FOR TENNESSEE.
I THOUGHT THEY'D GO OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN EARLIER.
>> THIS IS A B FOR ME.
THIS GUY GOT THE JOB DONE, HAS
REALLY GOOD TECHNIQUE, NEVER SEE
HIM WITH HIS HANDS OUT WIDE.
>> YES, WELL COACHED.
>> YES, VERY WELL COACHED.
HE CAN DRIVE PEOPLE, AND ABLE TO
SET, AND GET PASS SET, AND PASS
SET READY.
B FOR ME, THE GUY IS A REALLY
GOOD BALL PLAYER.
>> JASON KELCE, YOU WATCHED
PETIT-FRERE.
HOW DOES HE TRANSLATE?
>> HE TRANSITIONS WELL, HE'S A
GOOD ATHLETE OVERALL, LIKE THE
GUYS SAID, HANDS ALWAYS A GOOD
TECHNICIAN.
HE WINDS UP A LITTLE BIT AND
TELEGRAPHS THINGS FROM TIME TO
TIME, BUT THAT'S GOING TO COME
AS HE GETS OLDER.
HE'S A SOLID ALL AROUND PLAYER,
AND SURPRISED HE WASN'T HIGHER.
LOOKED LIKE HE STARTED TO CREEP
UP A LITTLE BIT TOWARDS THE END
OF THE DRAFT, IN SOME OF THE
PROJECTIONS AS PEOPLE WATCHED
MORE OF HIS TAPE.
HE'S ONE OF THOSE GUYS WHEN YOU
WATCH HIS TAPE, GETS THE JOB
DONE, REALLY SOLID PLAYER.
>> REALLY SOLID PLAYER ACCORDING
TO OUR JASON KELCE.
NICHOLAS PETIT-FRERE WILL BE AN
INVESTMENT AND POSSIBLY A NEW
PLAYER FOR THE TENNESSEE TITANS.
BACK TO THE JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN SIX
PICKS, A FEW PICKS AGO THEY WENT
LUKE FORTNER OUT OF KENTUCKY,
THE CENTER, THEY STILL HAVE SOME
NEEDS ON OFFENSE.
THEY DID GO ON A WILD FREE AGENT
SPENDING SPREE IN OFFSEASON,
BRINGING IN A NUMBER OF GUYS,
CHRISTIAN KIRK, SAVE JONES, EVAN
INGRAM.
BRANDON SIR OF, AND NEXT TO
FORTNER, HE CAN HELP BRING HIM
ALONG.
IN TERMS OF NEEDS.
WHAT ARE WE THINKING FOR
JACKSONVILLE?
>> THEY OBVIOUSLY SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY AND MADE A DECENT AMOUNT
OF PICKS ALREADY.
THEY MIGHT BE THINKING BEST
PLAYER AVAILABLE.
>> THAT'S YOUR GUY.
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE BEST
PLAYERS AVAILABLE.
>> TALK ABOUT HIM.
GET RIGHT INTO IT.
>> THIS IS A TEAM THAT ALSO TOOK
DEVIN LLOYD.
>> YES.
>> THEY ARE JUST LOADED IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD.
I LOVE CHAD MUMA.
HE'S SOMEBODY, TO ME, THAT
THERE'S NOT REALLY ANY WEAKNESS
IN HIS GAME.
I'VE SEEN HIM COME DOWNHILL AND
FIND THE BALL CARRIER, I'VE SEEN
HIM RUN SIDELINE TO SIDELINE.
HE CAN RUN AND COVER.
>> THEY HAVE TWO OF YOUR TOP
THREE LINEBACKERS IN THIS DRAFT.
>> AND GUYS THAT NEVER, EVER
HAVE TO COME OFF THE FIELD AND
THIS TELLS ME THEY'RE GOING TO
USE DEVIN LLOYD TO RUSH THE
PASSER AND TAKE CHAD MUMA,
SAYING YOU'RE A TRA TITIONAL
RAIN BEAKER, SAM OR MIKE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE FIELD.
WE TRUST YOU.
MORE ATHLETIC IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE FIELD.
THEY'VE GOT GUYS THAT CAN RUN
BUT THEY DON'T SACRIFICE IN
TRAFFIC COMING DOWNHILL.
I LOVE MUMA.
38th OVERALL PLAYER.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR JACKSONVILLE.
THAT MIDDLE OF THE DEFENSE IS
LOOKING STELLAR.
>> SUPER VERSATILE.
>> HE'S GOOD, THIS GUY IS REALLY
GOOD.
YOU WATCH HIM PLAY, HE CAN WORK
IN PASS COVERAGE, SCRAPE OVER
THE TOP.
DOESN'T GET LOST IN THE TRASH
AND I LOVE THE WAY HE'S ABLE
TO -- WITH TROY ANDERSON, A GUY
STILL FIGURING OUT HOW
FOOTBALL -- FOUR GUYS UP FRONT,
THREE GUYS FIT BEHIND HIM LIKE
THAT.
THAT'S THE WAY DEFENSIVE
FOOTBALL WORKS.
CHAD MUMA UNDERSTANDS THAT
RELATIONSHIP EXCEPTIONALLY WELL
ALREADY.
IF THIS GUY HAS "A" GAP AND THIS
GUY HAS "C" GAP.
I'M IN B GAP.
>> HE FLOWS.
>> HE FLOWS EXCEPTIONALLY WELL,
AND FLOWS DOWNHILL.
READ STEP OFF THE TOP AND THEN
GOES, SEES IT AND GOES AND GETS
IT.
NO BAD STEPS THERE, IN THE HOLE.
MEETS THE GUY IN THE HOLE, TO
COLLISION TO GO MAKE A PLAY.
HE CAN PLAY MUGGED UP.
AND THEN PURSUE.
MAKE A TACKLE.
I LIKE THAT.
THE FACT -- THE IDEA, THE
SCARIEST PART FOR ME, THINKING
ABOUT IT CORRECTLY PERTAINING TO
JACKSONVILLE, IS THE FACT THAT
IF THEY COULD HAVE DEVIN LLOYD
LINED UP TO RUSH THE
QUARTERBACK, YOU MUG UP MUMA ON
A THIRD AND LONG, YOU MUG MUMA
UP, YOU'VE GOT TRAVON WALKER
THERE, JOSH ALLEN THERE --
>> LET'S PUT OUR EARS BACK, AND
THEN MUMA BAILS OUT OF THERE --
>> YOU COULD BLITZ FROM
ANYWHERE.
>> HE BAILS OUT ON HIS OWN DOG,
BAILS OUT ON A MAN DOG AND HE'S
A RAT IN THE HOLE TO TAKE THE
BALL AWAY FROM ME.
THIS IS AN "A" PICK, A GUY WE
THOUGHT HAD A CHANCE TO GO THE
END OF THE FIRST ROUND, START OF
THE SECOND ROUND, THIS IS AN "A"
PICK.
>> INTERESTING.
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS, LOADING UP
ON THE FRONT SEVEN.
AND THEIR ONLY OTHER PICK IS THE
GUY THEY HOPE IS NAPPING TO
TREVOR LAWRENCE FOR YEARS TO
COME.
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS, 24th
AGAINST THE RUN.
THEY'RE HOPING THAT CHANGES.
QUICK MESSAGE FROM OUR FRIENDS
AT ROCKET MORTGAGE.
>>> LET'S GO TO CONNOR'S BIG
BOARD AND TAKE A LOOK AT
CHICAGO, ON THE CLOCK RIGHT NOW.
NAKOBE DEAN IS SOMEHOW STILL
THERE.
>> IT'S MEDICAL.
>> TRAVIS, WHERE A DO YOU MEAN?
>> THERE'S A LOT GOING ON ON
TWITTER, HE'S BEAT UP.
NAKOBE DEAN, HE'S A HELL OF A
PLAYER.
>> IS IT MOSTLY SHOULDER.
>> I THINK IT'S SHOULDER, I SAW
I BELIEVE ALBERT GREER SAID
THERE'S A THOUGHT HE MIGHT NEED
PECK SURGERY AFTER HIS ROOKIE
YEAR AND I TALKED TO SOMEBODY
INSIDE THE GEORGIA FACILITY A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO SAID HE'S HAD A
SLEEVE AND A BRACE ON HIS KNEE A
LONG TIME.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A GUY HE
PLAYED A LOT OF GOOD FOOTBALL
BUT MAN HE PLAYED A LOT OF CAR
CRASH, TOUGH GUY FOOTBALL.
>> THEY ATE HIM UP.
>> I HOPE HE CAN GET RIGHT.
AT THIS POINT, LET ME SAY THIS
ABOUT NAKOBE DEAN, IF YOU HAVE
MEDICAL KSHS THAT ARE SHORT
TERM, HE'S WORTH EVERY BIT OF
THIS.
SO I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHERE HE
GOES.
>> BEARS HAVE GONE SECONDARY
WITH FIRST TWO PICKS, KYLER
GORDON, AND JAQUAN BRISKER.
WHEN WILL THEY HELP OUT JUSTIN
FIELDS IN THE OFFENSE, THE
OFFENSIVE LINE, A POSSIBLE
WEAPON.
I KNOW THERE'S JAMARI SOLYER OUT
THERE, DEPTH ON THE INTERIOR.
WE'LL WAIT AND SEE FOR THE --
AND THERE'S THE VALUE, THE WIDE
RECEIVER, VILAS JONES, FOR THE
CHICAGO BEARS, GETTING A WEAPON
FOR JUSTIN FIELDS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS KID?
>> GIVES DAY THREE PLAYER AND HE
GOES INTO DAY TWO.
WITH VILAS JONES.
REMINDS ME OF ANTONIO CALLAWAY.
I THINK THERE WAS MORE MEAT ON
THE BONE FOR HIM.
DIDN'T GET HIM THE BALL ENOUGH
IN COLLEGE.
EXCELLENT SPECIAL TEAMS PLAYER.
QUICK THROW TO ALLOW HIM TO
CATCH AND RUN.
DEEP WIDE RECEIVER CLASS BUT
ONCE AGAIN I REALLY, REALLY LIKE
HIM.
WIDE RECEIVER, KICK RETURNER,
PUNT RETURNER, TRANSFER FROM
USC, HIGH LEVEL ATHLETE, ALMOST
A NINE AS A RELATIVE ATHLETIC
SCORE, .431 FORTY.
HE BROUGHT BACK A KICK FOR A
TOUCHDOWN, AVERAGED OVER 15
YARDS ON PUNT RETURNS, HE PLAYS
INSIDE AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
IF YOU CAN GET HIM THE SHORT
UNDERNEATH THROWS TO GIVE HIM
SPACE TO RUN WITH THE BALL IN
HIS HANDS.
HE MAKES THINGS HAPPEN.
LAST ONE I LIKE, GUYS, THREE
DROPS ON 68 CATCHABLE TARGETS.
I'VE BEEN SCREAMING FOR THE
BEARS TO HELP OUT JUSTIN FIELDS.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO BE A BETTER
NFL PLAYER AS A WIDE RECEIVER,
NOT JUST A SPECIAL TEAMER THAN
HE WAS AT TENNESSEE.
AN A MINUS FOR ME.
I LOVE VILAS JONES.
>> REALLY GOOD FOOTBALL PLAYER,
CONSTANT SWITCHING QUARTERBACK
SITUATION TO GO BETWEEN MILTON
AND HOOKER.
THIS IS A "B" PLUS, IT'S A GUY
WE SEE BLOSSOM AT THE NEXT
LEVEL.
GETTING HIM THE FOOTBALL, AND
GETTING THE FOOTBALL IN SPACE.
>> AMAN ROB, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF VILAS JONES COMING TO YOUR
NFC NORTH DIVISION?
>> HE'S ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
RECEIVERS IN HIS CLASS.
I PLAYED WITH HIM MY FRESHMAN
YEAR AT USC, HE WAS ALWAYS A
BURNER, WE ALL KNEW THAT.
ALL OF US AT USC, HE'S BEEN THAT
BURNER.
FOR HIM, SPECIAL TEAMS IS HUGE
FOR HIM AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
KICK RETURN, PUNT RETURN, MOSTLY
KICK RETURN, HE DID THAT SINCE I
CAN REMEMBER WHEN I WAS A
FRESHMAN, BEAST ON KICK RETURN.
DID IT AT TENNESSEE.
I DON'T THINK HE GOT A LOT OF
LOOKS AT TENNESSEE, LIKE YOU
GUYS SAID EARLIER, I THINK HE
COULD RUN ROUTES, GO DEEP, HE
CAN CATCH THE BALL, SO I THINK
HE'S GOING TO BE BETTER PRO THAN
HE IS IN COLLEGE.
BUT I'M EXCITED FOR HIM, AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT HE DOES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING, RIGHT NOW
THEIR KICK RETURNER IS KHALIL
HERBERTS.
THEY COULD DEFINITELY USE SPEED
AND LET KHALIL HERBERT BE THE
BACK THAT COMES IN TO REPRIEVE
DAVID MONTGOMERY.
>> BECAUSE THERE'S THE VALUE
THAT'S DIMINISHED AT KICK
RETURNER, THAT'S AN INTERESTING
KICK, THE VALUE IS DIMINISHED
KICK RETURNER, HE'S AN EXCELLENT
PUNT RETURNER, SUPER VALUABLE.
>> ABE LUCAS.
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
SEATTLE SEAHAWKS AVOIDED
SEEMINGLY FOREVER.
72 OUT OF WASHINGTON STATE, ABE
LUCAS.
>> A LITTLE EARLY.
PLAYER 147 # FOR ME.
DID A GREAT JOB.
I TOLD YOU EARLIER, DIDN'T THINK
THEY WERE DONE ON THE OFFENSIVE
LINE.
I WOULD HAVE TAKEN BERNARD
RAYMOND.
I'M SURPRISED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SIMILAR
OFFENSIVE TACKLES.
MORE FINESSE STYLE.
HE REMINDS ME OF JAKE FISHER, A
PLAYER THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE BEST
NFL CAREER.
>> THE KID IS AN ATHLETE.
>> HE'S A REALLY GOOD ATHLETE.
I DON'T SEE THE PHYSICALITY
THAT'S DEMANDED AT THE TACKLE
POSITION AT THE NFL LEVEL.
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING SEATTLE
WITH THEIR COACHING STAFF.
HE SAID HE GETS IN THE WAY.
AND I THINK YOU CAN DO THAT IN
THE PAC-12, DUH BYU NOT NFC.
THIS IS A "C."
I LIKE THAT THEY'RE INVESTING
THIS THEIR OFFENSIVE LINE.
I LOVE CHARLES CROSS.
IT'S ALL THERE ATHLETICALLY.
>> CHARLES CROSS WILL HAVE TO
PLAY.
JAKE KERHAN IS THEIR RIGHT
TACKLE.
HE WAS AN UNDRAFTED FREE AGENT
BUT ME FINISHED THE SEASON WITH
FIVE STRONG STARTS.
Y
I DON'T THINK LUCAS IS GOING TO
HAVE TO PLAY RIGHT AWAY.
IT COULD BE A BATTLE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS GUY?
>> I LIKE HIM.
HE NEEDS THE MEAN STREAK.
I'M GOING TO GIVE THIS A C PLUS.
ON THE STRENGTH OF THE FACT THAT
I THINK THAT THE SEAHAWKS HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PULL THAT OUT OF
HIM.
THAT'S THE KEY.
AND IT DOESN'T HELP THE
OFFENSIVE HE PLAYED IN, IN
COLLEGE, A LOT OF IT WAS ALL HE
HAD TO DO WAS GET THE BALL AND
GET IN THE WAY.
SO OUCH MANY OF WHAT THEY DID
WAS KICK HITTERS IN THE RUN GAME
AND PASS GAME.
A LOT THREE STEP.
THROW, THROW, OR DRAWS WHERE ALL
YOU HAVE TO DO IS GET IN THE
WAY.
DRAW THE GUY UPFIELD AND THEY
RUN UNDERNEATH YOU.
THAT IS -- THAT'S PART OF WHAT
HE BROUGHT TO THE TABLE WAS THE
ABILITY TO PLAY -- HE'S A
FUNCTION OF THE OFFENSE THAT HE
PLAYED IN.
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO IN A
IN SEATTLE.
NOT GOING TO LET HIM DO THAT IN
SEATTLE.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN THAT IN
SEATTLE.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> TWO OF THE NEXT FIVE PICKS
ARE THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS AND
THEY START OFF WITH JELANI WOODS
AT PICK NUMBER 73, TIGHT END OUT
OF VIRGINIA.
THIS IS THE GUY I WAS THINKING
ABOUT EARLIER, THIS IS A TEAM
THAT JACK DOYLE RETIRED.
THEY LOVE MULTIPLE TIGHT END
SETS.
THEY SIGN COX, BUT THEY NEED
ANOTHER TIGHT END.
FELTER LOVES HIM.
>> I'LL TAKE IT.
I'LL GO FIRST.
JELANI WOODS IS A TRANSFORMER.
6'7", 260 POUNDS, AND HE STILL
CAN FIGURE OUT A WAY -- HIM AND
MEALY COX ZBLSH IT'S BUCK WILD.
HE'S THE SAME SIZE AT LeBRON
JAMES.
>> LeBRON IN PADS, YEAH.
>> THIS IS CRAZY.
HE WAS UNDERUTILIZED.
HE DID -- THEY MADE HIM BROCK
AND HE FOUND A WAY TO GET THAT
BUTT DOWN AND GO MAKE PLAYS.
I'M GIVING THIS THING AN "A."
HE'S SOMEONE THAT HAS -- ONE OF
THOSE GUYS THAT HAS A BETTER NFL
CAREER THAN A COLLEGE CAREER.
THE 44 RECEPTIONS, WHEN YOU
WATCH HIM AND GO THROUGH AND
PULL OUT THE CATCHES, A LOT OF
THOSE ARE BIG PLAYS, HIM BEING A
GIRAFFE, ESSENTIALLY, RUNNING
DOWN THE SEAM.
>> 70% OF HIS CATCHES WERE FIRST
DOWNS OR TOUCHDOWNS.
>> BINGO.
>> YES, SCORED A TOUCHDOWN IN
EIGHT OF 11 GAMES AND ZERO
BLOCKING PENALTIES FOR A GUY
THEY MADE BLOCK A LOT.
>> MY COMPARISON IS CJUZA MA.
>> HE WAS A FORMER BASKETBALL
PLAYER TOO.
>> MONSTER TIGHT END.
EXPLOSIVE ATHLETICISM.
HE HAS THE HIGHEST RELATIVE
ATHLETIC SCORE FOR A TIGHT END
EVER.
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
HAVE YOUR ATHLETICISM COMPARED
TO BODY COMPOSITION.
AT THAT SIZE, HE'S AN INSANE
ATHLETE.
NOW, I LOOK AT HIM, THE BLOCKING
HAS POTENTIAL, LIKE FELTER SAID,
LEVERAGE IS GOING TO BE TOUGH AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
THERE'S GOING TO BE BULLIES THAT
GET UNDERNEATH HIM.
HE'S HIGH CUT FOR ME.
THE HANDS ARE NOT NATURAL.
BUT IT'S GOOD ENOUGH.
HE'S THAT BIG.
AND STRONG.
>> WHEN YOU SEE LeBRON RUNNING
THE SEAM, DO YOU WANT TO COME
DOWN AND TACKLE HIM?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I LOOK AT JELANI WOODS, AND
THINK THAT ATHLETICISM AND SIZE
IS WORTH BETTING ON.
THIS IS A "B" FOR ME.
I THINK HE HAS MORE AS A PASS
CATCHER IF HE COULD JUST DIAL IT
IN A LITTLE BIT WITH MORE
NATURAL HANDS AND THE BLOCKING
IS GOING TO BE FINE.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING TOO, WITH
MATT RYAN GOING THERE, YOU GET
ALEC PIERCE, AN ATHLETIC
SPEEDSTER, THE JUMP BALL GUY,
AND THEN YOU GET JELANI WOODS,
THE TIGHT END.
THEY'RE GOING THE FALCONS --
>> YEAH, YOU STILL HAVE MIKE
PITMAN ZBLSH THE OTHER GUY IS A
HIGH POINTER.
>> THE INDIANAPOLIS COLTS RIGHT
NOW BUT I'M TELLING YOU, FRANK
REICH IS A MULTIPLE TIGHT END
GUY, AND JELANI WOODS WITH COX
IS A -- THE LOOK FOR THAT.
>> SPEAKING OF THE FALCONS, THEY
HAVE MADE THEIR SELECTION.
AND IT IS GOING TO BE DESMOND
RIDDER, OUR SECOND QUARTERBACK
OFF THE BOARD, AND SHOCKINGLY IT
IS NOT MALIK WILLIS.
BUT DESMOND RIDDER, THE
QUARTERBACK NOW THAT WILL GO
THERE BEHIND MARCUS MARIOTA.
DESMOND RIDDER, THIRD ROUND,
74th OVERALL, CONNOR, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> HE'S MY 68th OVERALL PLAYER.
I'M GLAD THIS IS WHERE HE CAME
OFF THE BOARD.
INSTEAD OF RIDICULOUS FIRST
ROUND EXPECTATIONS.
GOOD ENOUGH ARM, NOT AN ELITE
ARM.
MY QUESTION IS WITH RIDDER, HE
PLAYS A LITTLE SLOW.
AND THE ACCURACY COMES AND GOES,
HE THROWS THE BALL HIGH, ONCE
AGAIN HE HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
IN THE OFFENSE.
YOU SEE HIM DOING THAT, THE
RUNNING, I WANT TO SEE HIM DO
MORE OF THAT FOR THE KIND OF
ATHLETE HE IS.
MY BIGGEST GRIPE WITH THIS PICK,
I LIKE THE UPSIDE OF MALIK
WILLIS, THE VALUE, 68th OVERALL
PLAYER, 74th PICK RIGHT FOR FOR
RIDDER, THIS IS THE KIND OF GUY
YOU DEVELOP MIND MARCUS MARIOTA.
HE SHOULD NOT PLAY THIS YEAR.
HE'S PLAYED A LOT OF COLLEGE
FOOTBALL.
I WANT TO SEE DEVELOPMENT IN
TERMS OF GAME SPEED.
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE A LITTLE
TOUGHER AT THAT NEXT LEVEL FOR
HIM.
I GIVE THIS A "B" MINUS.
I WOULD HAVE TAKEN MALIK WILLIS.
RIDDER, THE VALUE CHECKS OUT
HERE.
>> 43 AND 6 AS A STARTER.
NEVER LOST A GAME AT HOME.
26-0.
AND LAST YEAR A 38 TOUCHDOWN
INTERCEPTION RATIO.
>> HE'S GOOD, HE'S GOOD.
HE MAKES LAYERED THROWS.
I LIKE HIS ABILITY TO MAKE
LAYERED THROWS.
HE CAN DO IT BECAUSE HE'S TALL
BUT NOT AFRAID TO THROW THE BALL
BETWEEN THE HASHES.
THAT'S A QUESTION MARK WITH
OTHER QUARTERBACKS, HE'S GOT THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT.
HIS ARM, I WONDER ABOUT
CONSISTENCY.
FOR ME, I'M GOING TO GIVE IT AN
A MINUS.
IF THIS IS THE GUY THAT YOU
LIKED AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO GET
HIM IN THE FIRST ROUND.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU DIDN'T HAVE TO GET HIM IN
THE SECOND ROUND.
>> AND YOU HAD TWO PICKS IN THE
SECOND ROUND.
>> YOU STILL GET HIM THIRD
ROUND.
>> THEY NEEDED PLAYERS, NOW YOU
CAN AFFORD THIS LUXURY.
>> IF THIS IS THE ONE THEY
LIKED, THIS IS TELLING ME THIS
IS THE GUY THEY LIKED.
>> THEY DID LIKE HIM.
>> THIS IS THE GUY THEY LIKE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO GIVE-UP
ANYTHING TO GET HIM.
>> JASON KELCE, ANOTHER BEARCAT,
DESMOND RIDDER, WHAT DO YOU
THINK ABOUT HIM IN THE NFL?
>> I MEAN, WHO KNOWS, OBVIOUSLY,
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
SITUATION FOR HIRM, THOUGH, HE
IS THE PRODIGAL SON OF
CINCINNATI, LOCAL KID.
BEST QUARTERBACK IN CINCINNATI
HISTORY.
WITH RESPECT TO TONY PIKE AND
ZACH KALAROS, MY FORMER
TEAMMATES.
12,419 YARDS WAS HIS COLLEGE
CAREER.
THIS IS A KID THAT IS POISED AND
COMPOSED AT ALL TIMES.
I LOVE HIS ATTITUDE.
I LOVE HIS TEMPERAMENT.
I LOVE HOW HE CARRIES HIMSELF AS
THE LEADER OF A TEAM IN A UNIT.
HE HAS ISSUES WITH ACCURACY, BUT
HE'S GOING TO A GREAT PLACE.
CINCINNATI NEVER USES
ATHLETICISM FOR SOME REASON AS
MUCH AS THEY -- OBVIOUSLY NOW
AFTER HE WENT AND BLEW UP THE
COMBINE, THEY SHOULD HAVE.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
INTANGIBLE TRAITS, THAT I THINK
A LOT OF COACHES ARE EXCITED TO
WORK WITH.
AND TO BE THERE WITH MARCUS
MARIOTA, THEY'LL BE ABLE TO RUN
SIMILAR SYSTEMS, SIMILAR TYPE OF
GUYS.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK OUT
GREAT FOR THEM.
EXCITED.
>> PHENOMENAL POINT, KELSEY.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE WAY THAT
ARTHUR SMITH WAS USING RYAN
TANNEHILL, AND HIS ATHLETICISM,
AND THE LACK OF PRESSURE THAT
WILL BE ON DESMOND RIDDER RIGHT
AWAY IS PRETTY DARN GOOD.
THE TEXANS JUST MOVED UP WITH
THE DENVER BRONCOS PICK, AND
TOOK LINEBACKER CHRISTIAN
HARRIS.
SO THE TEXANS NOW MOVING UP AND
GETTING A LITTLE AGGRESSIVE.
THEY HAD GONE A CORNER BACK, A
SAFETY, A WIDE RECEIVER AND AN
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
THEY NEEDED TO GET A LINEBACKER,
ESPECIALLY FOR THAT TAMPA II
DEFENSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
CHRISTIAN HARRIS FITTING INTO
THAT ROLE?
>> THIS IS THE RIGHT RANGE.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A GREAT
ATHLETE.
IT FELT LIKE HE WAS PUT IN A BAD
SPOT AT TIMES THAT WAS OUT OF
HIS CONTROL.
HE GOT LOST IN TRAFFIC.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS TRYING TO
MAKE UP FOR SOMEBODY ELSE NOT
DINING THEIR JOB BUT IT LOOKED
LIKE THINGS WERE FALLING APART
AT TIMES.
EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS GUY WAS
FIRST ROUND.
THE FACT HE'S GOING HERE, HE'S
AN EXCELLENT ATHLETE.
NOT THAT FAR DIFFERENT, A LITTLE
BIGGER, A LITTLE THICKER THAN
ASAMOAH WHO ALREADY WENT OFF THE
BOARD.
SPEED ON THE FIELD ON THIRD AND
FOURTH DOWNS AND YOU'RE THINKING
HE CAN BULK MORE AND DEVELOP FOR
EARLIER DOWNS OVER TIME.
116 ON MY BOARD.
THE VALUE IS PRETTY EVEN.
REMINDS ME OF PATRICK QUEEN.
I LOVED HIM COMING OUT OF THE
DRAFT.
HE STRUGGLED WITH BALTIMORE, BUT
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF TIME.
THIS IS A "B" MINUS FOR
CHRISTIAN HARRIS, THIS IS THE
KIND OF BACKER YOU NEED.
LEO CHENAL, A BETTER PLAYER, BUT
THEY REALLY VALUED THE SPEED.
>> SIDELINE TO SIDELINE ABILITY
THAT HE BRINGS, YOU PLAY HIM IN
POSITION, ASKING HIM TO WORK IN
THE DEEP MIDDLE AND CARRY GUYS
ACROSS THE FIELD.
THAT'S WHERE YOU'VE GOT A GOOD
PLAYER.
I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE
THIS AN A MINUS.
>> GOOD SCHEME FIT.
>> YES, AND I DON'T WANT HIM TO
DO WHAT HE DID AT ALABAMA.
>> I AGREE.
>> I DON'T WANT HIM TO DO WHAT
THEY ASKED HIM AT ALABAMA.
>> THIS COULD ACTUALLY FLIP IT.
>> HE BECOMES A BETTER PLAYER
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO ASK HIM
TO RUN THE SHOOUT.
HE CAN RUN IS CHUTE.
ASK HIM TO RUN THE CHUTE AND
CHASE BEHIND.
>> PAIR HIM UP WITH CHRISTIAN
KIRKSY.
LET HIM HANDLE THAT.
I LIKE WHEN TEAMS DRAFT FOR
THEIR SCHEME.
THE RAVENS ARE NOW UP NEXT.
SO THIS IS THE LAST PIC THAT WE
JUST DID.
THE BALTIMORE RAVENS ARE NEXT AT
76, AS THE DRAFT IS STARTING TO
REALLY FLY.
BALTIMORE RAVENS WENT KYLE
HAMILTON AT SAFETY.
TYLER LINDERBAUM AT CENTER.
AND JABO AT EDGE.
THEY WENT THREE GUYS FIRST ROUND
GRACE ON, AND NOW WE'RE SITTING
HERE AND GOING INTERIOR, IF THEY
GET --
>> TRAVIS JONES, THE THIRD
ROUND --
>> INSANITY.
>> IF THEY GET TRAVIS JONES, IF
THEY GET -- YOU JUST TALKED
ABOUT NAKOBE DEAN.
>> THE MEDICALS WITH DEAN,
THAT'S FINE.
>> ONLY TWO FIRST ROUND PLAYERS
I HAVE LEFT RIGHT NOW.
>> THEY COULD -- I MEAN,
REALISTICALLY, THEY COULD GET,
IF THEY WANT TO GO OFFENSIVE
LINE, THEY COULD GO KENNARD.
>> THEY CAN GO RAYMOND.
>> THEY COULD GO RAYMOND OR M
MYJAI SANDERS.
>> I WOULDN'T FIND JALEN
TOLBERT.
A GUY THAT WINS OFF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
HE CAN WIN ALL THREE LEVELS OF
THE FIELD.
HE'S A LITTLE MORE ROUNDED.
>> LET'S SEE IF WE WERE
ACCURATE.
AND THE PICK IS --
>> THERE WE GO.
>> TRAVIS JONES.
>> THAT'S THE ONE RIGHT THERE.
>> WOW, WOW.
>> BALTIMORE, JUST -- THEY'RE
LAPPING EVERYONE IN THIS DRAFT
RIGHT NOW.
LET'S MAKE THAT CLEAR.
>> THE QUESTION IS, WHEN DO THEY
NOT?
TRAVIS JONES, TEAM CAPTAIN FOR
YUKON.
HARDEST WORKER, WORKED HARD TO
SHAPE HIS BODY.
LOST 30 POUNDS SINCE HE GOT TO
YUKON.
HE HAS A LOT OF PUNDS.
6'4", 326 # WITH A SUB-5 FORTY.
THIS IS A BALTIMORE RAVENS TEAM.
THEY'VE GOT CAMP WELL IN THE
MIDDLE BUT THEY LOVE SIZE FOR
THAT SCHEME.
>> IT REMINDS ME OF MARCELL
DARIUS.
A TEAM CAPTAIN.
HE'S VERY ATHLETIC FOR A 325
POUND PLAYER, AND I'VE WATCHED
HIM AT THE SENIOR BOWL AND I'M
ON THE FIELD AND LOOKING AT HIM
AND THINKING, ALL THE TAPE I
WATCHED, I KEPT THINKING GAP
PLUGGING NOSE TACKLE.
WITH ONE ON ONES WITH THAT HEAVY
WEIGHT FIGHTER HE DE-TROYED
PEOPLE IN THE PASS RUSH TRAILS.
HE'S WELL ROUNDED, HE'S A BIG
TIME PLAYER, TRUE NOSE, SHADE,
ZERO, HEAD TO HEAD WITH THE
CENTER, HE IS A SCARY MAN TO
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
HE CAN STACK AND SHED.
TEACH TAPE AGAINST THE RUN.
STACK, GET OFF THE BLOCK, MAKE
THE PLAY AT THE LINE OF SCRAM
IMAGINE.
THIS IS AN "A" PLUS, AND
BALTIMORE, THEY'RE JUST RUNNING
LAPS AROUND EVERYONE IN THIS
DRAFT.
YOU'VE GOT TYLER LINDERBAUM,
KYLE HAMILTON, BOTH TOP TEN
PLAYERS FOR ME.
ONE OF TWO PLAYERS LEFT WITH
FIRST ROUND.
NAKOBE DEAN.
WITH --
>> THEY GOT AJO -- THEY'RE GOING
TO BE INSANE IN.
>> THEY'RE RESETTING THE
DEFENSE.
>> DO WE THINK HE LASTED THIS
LONG BECAUSE HE DOESN'T FIT INTO
ALL SCHEMES?
>> SURE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT BEFORE WITH
JORDAN DAVIS.
THAT'S WHY HE'S LASTED THAT
LONG.
THIS GUY AS A PLAYER, I LOVE THE
WAY THAT HE BUTTS AND PRESSES,
COMING OFF THE LINE.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IT RIGHT
HERE.
BUTT, PRESS, GET EXTENSION,
SHED, GO MAKE THE TACKLE.
WHAT I MEAN BY BUTT AND PRESS IS
FIRE OFF THE BALL, ENENGAGE, GET
FULL EXTENSION, AND GO MAKE A CK
TACKLE.
HE GIVES AN INITIAL SHOCK, GETS
THE EXTENSION, HE CAN CLEAR,
KEEP THAT OUTSIDE ARM FREE, OR
THE INSIDE ARM FREE, DEPENDS
WHERE HIS LEVERAGE IS COMING
FROM AND HE GOES AND MAKES A
PLAY.
TO ME, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
YOU HAVE TO GIVE A HIGH GRADE
TO, BOTH BECAUSE OF WHO HE IS AS
A PLAYER AND ALSO WHERE THEY GOT
HIM, I AM ECHOING CONNOR WITH
THE "A" PLUS.
BUT WHEN YOU FIRE OFF THE BALL,
YOU BUTT, YOU PRESS, AND THEN
YOU EITHER KEEP ONE ARM FREE, OR
YOU GET RID OF THE GUY, AND THEN
GO MAKE A TACKLE, HE CAN DO
THOSE THINGS.
>> THE ATHLETIC EDGE GUYS
THEY'VE GOT NOW, THEY'RE SEEING
ONE ON ONES, TRAVIS JONES, TAKES
UP HALF THE FIELD.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT OF JABO AND --
>> INSANITY.
>> THE RHIN BACKERS.
>> THE ADVANTAGE OF USING
POSITIONS THAT OTHER TEAMS DON'T
USE.
BECAUSE THE VALUE THAT YOU CAN
GET WHEN OTHER TEAMS AREN'T
LOOKING FOR THEM.
>> YEAH.
>> I THINK THERE WAS A NUMBER OF
TEAMS THAT WE THOUGHT COULD FIX
THEIR ENTIRE RUN ISSUES WITH
THIS GUY.
IT'S A PERFECT FIT FOR
BALTIMORE.
SURPRISED HE LASTED THIS LONG.
>> WE'RE ALL SURPRISED.
EVERYONE SHOULD BE SURPRISED.
THE FACT THAT YOU GET A GUY THAT
CAN EAT TWO BLOCKS, IF HE HAS
TO, HE CAN EAT TWO.
ON RUNDOWNS, EAT TWO.
EAT TWO, HAVE YOUR FIVE
TECHNIQUE SQUEEZE AND NOW ALL
THE SUDDEN WHAT YOU'VE DONE IS
CREATE THAT PINCH AND THAT PINCH
LEADS TO YOUR OUTSIDE
LINEBACKER, FUNNELING, THOSE
GUYS COME OUT CLEAN AND THEY GO
MAKE TACKLES.
>> UNBELIEVABLE.
>> INDIANAPOLIS COLTS ARE ON THE
COLT, OFFENSE, OFFENSE, ALEC
PIERCE, WIDE RECEIVER, JELANI
WOODS.
TIGHT END.
OTHER NEEDS.
OFFENSIVE LINE.
EDGE RUSHER, I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYBODY LEFT.
>> MYJAI SANDERS, MALONE, THREE
FAVORITE PLAYERS.
>> AND THEN ALSO MAYBE CORNER
BACK.
>> COBY BRYANT.
>> THEY TRADED -- MOVING ON FROM
XAVIER ROADS.
OF ALL THE NAMES YOU'VE SAID,
WHICH ONE DO YOU THINK IS THE
HIGHEST ON YOUR BOARD THAT YOU
THINK YOU'D LIKE FOR THEM HERE?
>> I THINK RAYMOND, THEY HAVE A
REALLY DIRE NEED AT TACKLE RIGHT
NOW, AND YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP MATT
RYAN CLEAN.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT LEFT
TACKLE.
>> RAIMANN, SOFT SHOULDER, GUYS
GET HIM TO THE OUTSIDE.
FORMER TIGHT END.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE HIM, THAT'S
OKAY.
ATHLETIC RUN BLOCKER.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE WHETHER THEY
GO.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD PLAYERS
THAT FIT WHAT THEY WANT.
AND THEN I SAID COBY BRYANT AT
CORNER.
THEY HAVE AN ARM LENGTH
THRESHOLD I DON'T THINK HE'D
PASS.
INTERESTING.
>> LET'S CHECK TWITTER.
I NEED SOME BACKGROUND ON WHY
MALIK WILLIS HAS CONTINUED TO
SLIDE.
RICHARD SHERMAN, EATING THE
ONION RINGS AND SENDING OUT
TWEETS.
RICHARD SHERMAN, YOU'RE SHOCKED
LIKE US, WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
MALIK WILLIS?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
I MEAN, WE THOUGHT, HOW -- I
GUESS WE LET -- I FELL VICTIM TO
THE DRAFT ANALYSTS AND
EVERYBODY'S MOCKS AND THOUGHT HE
WOULD BE GOING IN THE FIRST DAY.
AND I THOUGHT AT WORST HE'D BE
GOING, YOU KNOW, EARLY TO
MIDSECOND ROUND.
AND HERE WE ARE IN THE THIRD
ROUND, AND, YOU KNOW, I'M NOT
FEELING CONFIDENT IN ANY TEAM,
THAT'S, HEY, HE'S ABOUT TO GO TO
THIS TEAM OR THAT TEAM.
IT'S KIND OF FALLING TO THE BACK
OF YOUR MINDS.
THIS GUY WAS PROJECTED BY MANY
AS THE FIRST QUARTERBACK TO GO.
NOW WE'VE GONE A REALLY LONG
TIME, A SECOND QUARTERBACK
DIDN'T GO TO THE THIRD ROUND AND
WE HAVEN'T SEEN HIS NAME CALLED.
I WANT TO KNOW.
IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING GOING ON.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S AN INJURY
OR BACKGROUND, OR IF THERE'S A
PENDING SUSPENSION, OR WHATEVER
IT IS, BUT IT SEEMS ODD THAT
NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT ANYTHING
LIKE THAT AND THIS GUY HAS
CONTINUED TO SLIDE.
>> IT SEEMS BEYOND ODD.
I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HONEST
WILL.
THOOIM I'M LOOKING AT OBLI
TEAMS.
AT 81, MAYBE THE GIANTS WANT TO
BE CRAZY.
AND FALCONS TOOK THEIR GUY.
I'M NOT SAYING THE STEELERS TAKE
BOTH QUARTERBACKS AND LET THEM
BATTLE IT OUT.
>> GOOD CONTENT.
>> GREAT CONTENT, IT'S NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
PATRIOTS AREN'T GOING TO DO IT.
CARDINALS AREN'T GOING TO DO IT.
COWBOYS AREN'T GOING TO DO IT.
BUFFALO.
TENNESSEE.
>> THAT'S THE ONE I LIKE.
>> BEHIND TANNEHILL.
>> IS HE GOING TO MAKE IT TO
CAROLINA, NEXT PICK?
>> HERE IS THE ONE WE SAID WAS A
POSSIBILITY.
BERNHARD RAIMANN OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN FOR THE COLTS, BACK TO
BACK BALTIMORE AND INDY.
YOU REALIZE CERTAIN TEAMS ARE
GOOD AT BEING PATIENT.
BERNHARD RAIMANN.
ALLOWED ONE CAREER SACK AT
MISSOURI.
TRANSITION FROM TIGHT END TO
TACKLE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
SINCE MARCH 2020 THE DUDE PUT ON
60 POUNDS.
COULD HE BE THE FUTURE LEFT
TACKLE.
>> ERIC FISHER WAS THE COMP FOR
HIM.
THIS IS A PLAYER THAT FITS WHAT
THEY LIKE TO DO.
HE'S SOMEBODY THAT'S STILL
GETTING BETTER.
DESPITE BEING AN OLDER PROSPECT.
AS I SAID EARLIER ON THE SHOW.
NECESSARY MILITARY STFS AND THEN
GOT TO COLLEGE.
TIGHT END, TACKLE.
GREAT FEET, GOOD ATHLETICISM.
NEEDS TO GET BETTER ON THAT
OUTSIDE SHOULDER, NOT LETTING
GUYS BEAT HIM TO THE OUTSIDE AND
FLATTEN THE POCKET.
I LOVE THE VALUE HERE.
TOP 50 PLAYER.
THIS IS AN "A," BERNHARD
RAIMANN.
>> THE GUY CAN PLAY.
PATIENT FEET.
DOESN'T OVEREXTEND HIMSELF.
HE'S STILL LEARNING FOOTBALL,
THAT'S A POSITIVE.
DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF BAD
HABITS.
IT'S A "B" PLUS.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS IN TERMS
OF HIS ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO
GROW IN THE GAME.
>> KELSEY, YOU SAW A TIGHT END
TURNED TACKLE IN TERMS OF LANE
JOHNSON.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF BERNHARD
RAIMANN AND HIS POTENTIAL WITH
THE COLTS.
>> IN JEB, I'M A HUGE FAN OF
FORMER SKILLED GUYS CONVERTED TO
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
THIS KID HAS THE METRICS.
NINE NINE BROAD, HIS SHORT
SHUTTLE IS .432.
THOSE DON'T TELL YOU -- STILL
GOT TO WATCH THE TAPE BUT THESE
ARE ALL THE LIMITING FACTORS.
HE'S GOT THE ATHLETICISM, HE'S
STILL IN AND OUT POSITION.
STILL LEARNING IT.
AND HE'S ONLY GOING TO GET
BETTER.
HE NEEDS TO PUT ON SOME WEIGHT.
HE'S A LITTLE LIGHT BUT PUTTING
ON WEIGHT WILL HELP WITH THAT
SOFT SHOULDER THAT CONNOR'S
TALKING ABOUT, AS WELL AS JUST
GETTING MORE FAMILIAR WITH THE
POSITION.
BUT I THINK THIS KID HAS A TON
OF UPSIDE, I THINK IT'S A GREAT
PICK IN THE THIRD ROUND.
AND I THINK HE'LL FIT IN WELL IN
INDY WITH THE OFFENSIVE LINE
THEY HAVE.
>> ANOTHER GREAT PICK FOR THE
INDIANAPOLIS COLTS.
PICK NUMBER 78 IS IN.
THE CLEVELAND BROWNS HAVE
SELECTED AL-ALEX WRIGHT WITH THE
78th PICK DOWN THERE IN
CLEVELAND.
WHAT DO WE THINK?
>> I LIKE THIS GUY A LOT.
TOP 100 PLAYER FOR ME, STANDUP
KEJ.
INSANE LENGTH FOR THE POSITION.
HE CAME IN AROUND 6'5", 6'6",
WINS IN A VARIETY OF WAYS, HE
PLAYED AGAINST TENNESSEE AND
LOOKED REALLY GOOD AGAINST THEM.
SWIPES, PUSH/PULL, SPEED TO
POWER.
THE OUTSIDE SPEED AND A REALLY
NICE INSIDE MOVE, AND GUYS, WHEN
YOU GET PAID FOR SACKING THE
QUARTERBACK, HE'S GOT THESE
INSANE STRIDES, TO CLOSE ON THE
QUARTERBACK.
SO ALEX WRIGHT IS GOING TO GIVE
THEM THE EDGE HELP THEY NEEDED,
HE'S GOT INSANE LENGTH, HE CAN
REALLY GET AFTER THE QUARTERBACK
AND I THINK HE'S GOT ENOUGH
AGAINST THE RUN TO STAY ON THE
FIELD.
THIS IS A "B" PLUS FOR ME FOR
BROWNS, THIS IS A NEED, THE
VALUE MAKES SENSE, UNDERRATED OR
UNDERDISCUSSED PLAYERS IN THE
DRAFT, AND FELTER, YOU'VE SEEN A
LOT.
>> THIS GUY CAN PLAY.
HE IS SO LONG, THAT YOU DON'T
REALIZE HE'S CARRYING AROUND 271
POUNDS.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, HE
DOESN'T LOOK IT AT ALL.
>> HE DIDN'T LOOK IT WHEN HE WAS
GOING TO THE PODIUM.
THIS IS A GUY THAT CARRIES CRAZY
LENGTH, HE'S GOT THE ABILITY TO
MAKE THE PLAYS.
I LIKE THE FACT HE'S NOT AFRAID
TO PLAY DOWN A LITTLE INSIDE.
GIVES YOU VERSATILITY TO YOUR
SCHEME, IF YOU WANT TO PUT
SOMEBODY SMALLER OUTSIDE OF HIM.
I'M GOING WITH AN "A" ON THIS
PICK.
BECAUSE UAB.
I LOVE THE FACT THIS GUY GETS
AFTER THE QUARTERBACK, GETS THE
JOB DONE.
HE'S A PACKAGE PLAYER EARLY, AND
THEN HE CAN GROW INTO PROBABLY A
FIVE TECHNIQUE, THE BIG THING
I'M LOOKING FOR OUT OF HIM, A
LITTLE MORE UP TOP STRENGTH.
HE'S GOT MORE BODY STRENGTH.
>> HE'S GOING WITH MILES
GARRETT.
AS LONG AS THEY WORK OUT
TOGETHER, HE'LL BE FINE.
SEE IF HE CAN BE THE GUY ON
THIRD DOWN THAT GETS AFTER THE
REALLY GOOD QUARTERBACKS IN THE
AFC NORTH.
CHARGERS PICK IS IN.
TEAMS GOING FOR A SUPER BOWL
RUN.
>> WE'RE FLYING.
>> THEY ARE NOW GOING WITH IS
J.T. WOODS.
J.T. WOODS, THE PICK AT 79 TO
THE CHARGERS.
CONNOR, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> SUPER ALTHOUGH LETTIC PLAYER,
OBVIOUSLY FROM A BAYLOR
TESTIFIES THAT THEY HAD A TON OF
GUYS, NOT ONLY TEST WELL, BUT
PLAY WELL.
AND DARNELL SAVAGE KIND OF
PLAYER.
6'2".
HE GOT THAT CONE ON SATURDAY.
INSANE ATHLETE.
NINE PICKS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
BALL SKILLS, FLUIDITY IN
COVERAGE.
NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU AS MUCH AS
A RUN DEFENDER RIGHT NOW BUT IF
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A GUY WITH
RANGE OVER THE TOP AND CAN EVEN
PLAY MAN COVERING.
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES.
HE FINDS THE FOOTBALL.
SKY HIGH FOR THE FOOTBALL.
THE TACKLING NEEDS WORK BUT
ATHLETIC WITH BALL SKILLS, THE
CHARGEST LOVE GUYS LIKE THIS.
J.T. WOODS, I WANT TO COME UP
WITH A PLAYER COMP TOO BEFORE WE
GIVE THIS ONE A GRADE.
DARNELL SAVAGE.
SO THIS ONE FOR ME, THE VALUE,
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OFF.
THEY NEEDED A COVERAGE PLAYER
WITH DERWIN JAMES.
>> I LOVE THIS KID.
I'M GOING TO GIVE MY GRADE
REALLY QUICK BEFORE THEN.
I WANT TO SAY, I LOVE THAT HE'S
A ROAMER IN THE BACK END.
I HAD A COUPLE OFFEER GUYS RATED
HIGHER UH BY LOVE THE FACT HE
THE ROAM IN THE BACK.
SO FOR ME, IF YOU WANT TO BRING
IT BACK.
THIS GUY IS GOING TO STEAL THE
FOOTBALL AWAY FROM FOLKS, HE IS
INCREDIBLY PERCEPTIVE, AND I'M
GOING TO GO "B" PLUS SO WE CAN
GET TO RICHARD SHERMAN.
>> THIS IS A SECONDARY THAT
ADDED JC JACKSON, THEY HAVE
DERWIN JAMES, MICHAEL DAVIS,
SANEHILL JR., IT'S TOUGH.
BUT AT THE SAME POINT IT'S A
LUXURY.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF THIS KID AND
WHAT HE'S DOING WITH ONE OF THE
BEST SECONDARIES IN THE NFL,
RICHARD?
>> IT'S GOING TO BE FUN FOR HIM.
BRANDON STALEY ISN'T GOING TO
HAVE TO RUSH TO GET HIM OUT
THERE.
BRANDON STALEY HAS DONE A GREAT
JOB WITH THE PIECES HE HAS BUT
THEY STILL STRUGGLED A TON IN
RUN DEFENSE.
THEY KEPT DBs ON THE FIELD.
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE NFC
WEST -- I MEAN THE AFC WEST IS
GOING TO.
YOU'VE GOT RUSSELL WILSON NOW,
DAY TAE ADAMS NOW, A LOT OF
RECEIVERS TO DEAL WITH.
THEY'RE MAKING SURE THEY HAVE
SECURITY.
SAMUEL JR. IS SOMEONE THEY'RE
HAPPY WITH.
JC JACKSON IS A TURNOVER MACHINE
AND ANOTHER TURNOVER MACHINE,
THE PERFECT GUY TO LEARN FROM.
17 INTERCEPTIONS IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
HE'S -- THEY'VE GOT HIM FOR A
STEAL IN L.A., BUT I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A REAL FUN SECONDARY
TO WATCH, ESPECIALLY AGAINST
KANSAS CITY, AGAINST THE
RAIDERS.
>> TOTALLY.
>> AGAINST --
>> BRONCOS.
>> THE WHOLE DIVISION.
DENVER, YEAH, IT'S GOING TO BE
FUN.
>> THEY DID HAVE STRUGGLES
STOPPING THE RUN AND THEY WENT
AND GOT AUSTIN JOHNSON,
SEBASTIAN, JOSEPH DAY AND KHALIL
MACK, BUT ANOTHER ATHLETE.
BRONCOS, GOING WITH A TIGHT END.
GREG DOLCIC, THEY LOST NOAH FANT
IN THE TRADE TO THE SEAHAWKS SO
THIS COULD BE A NEW TIGHT END
FOR RUSSELL WILSON.
CAN HE PLAY AND HAVE SUCCESS
RIGHT AWAY GOING OUT THERE WITH
ALBERT OH?
>> A VERY DEFINED ROLE FOR
DOLCIC.
A BIG SLOT PASS CATCHER, HE CAN
CATCH AND RUN.
I JUST DON'T REALLY SEE A LOT OF
LONG TERM DEVELOPMENT AS A
BLOCKER.
THAT'S NOT EVER WHO HE'LL BE.
IF YOU WANTED TO DRAFT A BIG
WIDE RECEIVER, A MOVE TIGHT END,
GET HIM OFF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE, HE CAN DO THAT.
ROSS HAS WORKED WITH GUYS LIKE
THAT BEFORE.
FOR DULCICH, HE'S A DECENT
ATHLETE.
TRUE MOVE TIGHT END.
THIS ONE FOR ME IS A C PLUS.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
VALUE.
>> HACKETT HAD SUCCESS WITH
ROBERT -- NOW WITH DULCICH.
BUT ALBERT AKWABONAM.
WITH THE SPEED AND TALENT YOU
HAVE AT WIDE RECEIVER.
COR LYNN SUTTON, JIM PATRICK.
JERRY JEUDY.
GOOD GROUP.
THEY WANT TO SPREAD YOU OUT AND
LET RUSSELL GO TO WORK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I LOVE DULCICH.
HE'S A REALLY GOOD PLAYER.
A FORMER WALK-ON, WHO GRADUATED
INTO THIS MASSIVE ROLE FOR UCLA,
SOMEONE THAT FOUND A WAY TO
CATCH 40 SOMETHING BALLS, LOOK
AT THE YARDS PER CATCH.
17.#.
HE'S A BIG PLAY -- HE'S A BIG
GAME HUNTER, THE BIG THING FOR
ME WITH HIM, I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND GIVE THIS A "B" PLUS,
HE'S GOING TO FIND WAYS TO GET
OPEN.
THIS IS ON PLAY CALLERS.
I THINK THAT'S THE KEY.
IT'S ON THE PLAY CALLERS.
IF YOU CAN'T USE HIM IN A
SIMILAR WAY.
IF YOU'RE NOT RUNNING ROUTES
WHERE HE'S HIDING, SNEAKING.
HE NEEDS TO BE NUMBER THREE.
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS YOU HAVE
YOUR OUTSIDE RECEIVER.
>> YUP.
>> YOU HAVE YOUR SLOT, AND THEN
YOU HAVE HIM AS YOUR "F" -- I
DON'T WANT HIM IN LINE.
I DON'T WANT SOMEBODY TO GET A
CHANCE TO CHUCK HIM.
A FIVE TECHNIQUE, OR A SAND
LINEBACKER OVER TOP OF HIM.
I WANT HIM OFF THE LINE AS THAT
NUMBER THREE.
AND THEN GIVE ME A SLANT.
GIVER ME A BEND.
AND THEN SNEAK HIM OUT AND
AROUND INTO THE VOID AND LET HIM
CATCH THE FOOTBALL.
THAT'S WHY IT'S A "B" PLUS.
>> SIX CATCHES, THREE CAREER
TOUCHDOWNS OF 50 OR MORE YARDS.
AND CHAMPIONSHIP KELLY SAID, HIS
WORK ETHIC IS OFF THE CHARTS.
THEY NEEDED THAT WEAPON AT THE
TIGHT END SPOT.
WE SAW RUSSELL WILSON AND JIMMY
GRAHAM A FEW YEARS AGO.
PICK 81.
THE GIANTS ARE SELECTING CORDELL
FLOTT, WHICH, MAN, THAT SOUNDS
LIKE A SOUND.
CORDELL FLOTT, WHAT DO WE THINK,
CONNOR.
>> TALL SKINNY CORNER.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT FLOTT, THIS IS
A TRUE DEVELOPMENT AGO CORNER,
175 POUNDS, YOU'RE NOT PLAYING
CORNER IN THE NFL AT 175 POUNDS.
I KNOW HE'S BEEN A SLOT FOR L,
SURKS, DECENT TESTER.
HE'S A BEEN A SLOT CORNER,
EXTREMELY SLENDER BUT HE
COMPETES, PLAYS REALLY, REALLY
HARD.
I HAD HIM MORE TOWARDS THE FIFTH
ROUND RANGE, SIXTH ROUND BECAUSE
I THINK HE NEEDS TO GAIN WEIGHT.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
AND ONCE AGAIN FOR THE GIANTS
THEY HAVE SLOT GUYS SO I THINK
THEY'RE THINKING THAT.
IT FEELS A LITTLE EARLY FOR
CORDELL FLOTT.
I'LL SAY THIS.
I LOVE MARCUS JONES IN THIS
DRAFT IF YOU WANT A SLOT CORNER
AND I KNOW THEY NEED SPECIAL
TEAMS.
>> YOU MENTIONED COBY BRYANT.
>> OUTSIDE CORNER.
THAT KILLS ME WITH THIS ONE.
EARLY FOR THE GIANTS HERE, THIS
IS A "C."
>> I'M GOING TO ECHO CONNOR.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT OF A REACH.
IT'S A C PLUS, THOUGH, BECAUSE
HE IS SOMEONE THAT'S GOING TO
STICK HIS NOSE IN IT.
>> HE'S 175.
>> HE STUCK HIS HOME -- HE'S
GOING TO GIVE YOU EFFORT.
THE BIG THING FOR ME WITH FLOTT
IS THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE WITH
A LOT OF LSUDBs OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS, AND PROBABLY NEXT
YEAR.
WHAT IS HE WILLING TO DO?
THAT'S GOING TO BE THE KEY.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
>> THIS IS A TEAM, THOSE GUYS
WERE UNWILLING TO PLAY ZONE
COVERAGE WHEN BO POLINI WAS
THERE.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN UNWILLING?
>> THEY DIDN'T DO IT.
>> HE WOULD SAY PLAY ZONE, AND
THEY WOULD GO, NAH.
>> THE DEFENSE THEY WERE
INSTALLING, IT'S A ZONE BASED
DEFENSE.
FLEX ZONE.
>> IS THIS AN EGO THING?
>> THEY DIDN'T GO TO LSU TO PLAY
ZONE.
WHAT YOU END UP WITH, NOT OF
KNOCK ON THE PLAYERS, ED ORGERON
SAID IT, SOME GUYS OVER HERE
PLAYING MAN, GUYS OVER HERE
PLAYING THE ZONE.
AND SO THAT'S THE BIG THING.
THEY WEREN'T PLAYING WHAT WAS
CALLED, THEY WERE PLAYING THEIR
OWN DEFENSE.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO SEE THE
CONVERSION TO PLAY MORE ZONE.
>> SPEAKING OF THE GUY THAT
PLAYED ZONE.
RICHARD, WHAT DO YOU THINK WHEN
YOU HEAR ALL THAT, AND WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF CORDELL FLOTT?
>> I THINK, YOU KNOW, ANYTIME
YOU GET A GUY WHO'S PLAYED SEC
FOOTBALL AT LSU, IT'S GOOD
COACHING.
CONCERNING SIZE.
HE'S GOING TO BE AN OUTSIDE
CORNER.
HE HAS THE SPEED AND THE ARM
LENGTH.
HE HAS THE INSTINCTS TO PLAY
OUTSIDE CORNER BUT HE'S
INCONSISTENT.
HE'S INCONSISTENT IN ZONE, HE'S
INCONSISTENT IN MAN.
HE'S A GOOD EFFORT TACKLER.
YOU CAN SEE HE PUTS HIS NOSE IN
THERE.
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE CONSISTENT
DISCIPLINE, IN THE COVERAGE.
LIKE YOU SEE A FEW BUSTS IN
THERE, YOU SEE AT TIMES WHERE HE
GUESSES BUT I THINK THE GIANTS
FEEL LIKE DEVELOP HIM AND HAVE
TIME.
THEY HAVE A YOUNG STAFF, BUT I
FELT LIKE IF HE WOULD HAVE WENT
TO A TEAM THAT DEVELOPS GUYS.
IF HE WOULD HAVE WENT TO
BALTIMORE I'D FEEL GOOD ABOUT
IT.
IF HE WENT TO THE BILLS, I'D
FEEL GOOD.
CERTAIN TEAMS, I FEEL LIKE HE'D
HAVE TIME TO DEVELOP BEHIND GOOD
VETERAN, WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE
VETERANS YOU DON'T DEVELOP
PROPERLY BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW TO DEVELOP.
HOW TO PREBARE FOR GAMES.
IT'S YOUNG GUYS TEACHING YOUNG
GUYS.
IT MAKES IT TOUGH.
>> WE HENT OFF AND DEVELOPED
QUICKLY.
ESPECIALLY IF JAMES BRADBURY
DOES LEAVE.
MALONE, THE EDGE RUSHER,
FINISHED HIS CAREER WITH 42
CONSECUTIVE STARTS.
OVER SIX TACKLES PER GAME.
D'ANGELO MALONE.
>> THIS WAS A GUY I WAS
EXTREMELY HIGHER ON THAN
EVERYBODY ELSE.
HE'S THE BEST BENDER IN THE
CLASS, TO ME, THAT'S WHAT I LOOK
AT IT WITH MALONE, FLEXIBILITY,
THE ABILITY TO BEND THE EDGE.
PLAY FAST.
IS HE GOING TO BE THE STALL WART
RUN DEFENDER?
THAT'S NOT WHO HE IS.
HAY NEED TO RUSH THE PASSER.
TWO EDGES FOR ME, TOP 50
PLAYERS, WHEN THAT YEAR --
DOUBLE DIGIT SACKS, THAT'S WHAT
MALONE LOOKS-LIKE ON TAPE.
SO QUICK ON THE OUTSIDE
SHOULDER, CAN TURN INTO THE
POCKET.
I SAW HIM COUNTER INSIDE ENOUGH.
I LOVE THIS PLAYER.
THE FALCONS HAD NOTHING AT EDGE
PASS RUSH BEFORE TODAY, NOW
THEY'VE GOT TWO OF MY FAVORITES,
"A" PLUS PICK.
>> I LOVE IT.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING BEFORE
I GIVE MY GRADE.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENT BETWEEN HIM
AND NICK --
>> NOTHING FOR ME.
THEY NEED A PLAN FOR IT.
NASCAR PACKAGE, KEEP HIM CLEAN,
GET ONE ON ONES WITH THE
TACKLES, GET OFF THE FIELD.
THAT MATTERS.
EVERYBODY'S GOING ON FOURTH DOWN
RIGHT NOW.
IT MATTERS SO MUCH.
HE'S AWESOME, BEEN PRODUCTIVE
FOR THREE YEARS.
2019 FILM IS TREMENDOUS.
>> LISTEN, THAT'S WHY I'M GIVING
IT AN "A."
I LOVE HIM TOO.
I WATCH A TON OF -- I LOVE THE
FACT HE'S WILLING TO PUT HIS
HAND IN THE GROUND, BUT HE'S
BETTER, I THINK, STANDING UMM.
NOT AFRAID TO FIGHT DOWN INSIDE.
LE WILL GET AFTER THE
QUARTERBACK.
HE'LL BEND THE EDGE.
I LOVE THE WAY HE'S ABLE TO DIP.
A COUPLE OTHER PASS RUSHERS, NOT
ABLE TO DIP, RUN THE EDGE.
HE CAN DO THAT AND HE WILL DO
THAT AND HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE
TO GROW HIS SPEED.
ABSOLUTELY, PART OF THAT
PACKAGE.
I LOVE THAT.
SLOONGS YOU GET HIM IN A GOOD
PACKAGE.
HE'S SOMEONE THAT'S PRODUCTIVE
FOR YOU.
HE FINDS A WAY TO GET TO THE
QUARTERBACK.
>> SOUNDS LIKE A GREAT PICK FOR
THE --
>> WHEN YOU TAKE OUTLIERS,
SMALLER RUSHERS, THEY'VE GOT TO
BE PREMIUM ATHLETES.
HE'S AN ELITE ATHLETE TO ME.
THAT'S WHAT MATTERS SO MUCH.
>> ALL RIGHT, ARE YOU LOVING
THIS DRAFT COVERAGE?
YEAH, OUR DRAFT COVERAGE IS
BROUGHT TO YOU BY ROCKET
MORTGAGE.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR AN EDGE IN
HOME BUYING MARKET.
GO WITH ROCKET MORTGAGE.
THEIR VERIFIED APPROVAL CAN HELP
YOU COMPETE IN A CROWDED MARK.
GIVE YOU THE EDGE YOU NEED.
WHY AM I RUSHING, THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES ARE ON THE
CLOCK.
IS THE PICK IN?
WE'RE AHEAD OF THE BROADCAST.
THEY'RE IN A COMMERCIAL FOR
PROGRESSIVE.
JASON KELCE IS JOINING ME ON
CAMERA.
THEY'VE GONE A.J. BROWN, THEY'VE
GONE JORDAN DAVIS.
THEY'VE GOT CAM JERGENS.
THE PICK IS IN.
I'M NOT LOOKING.
WHAT POSITION DO WE WANT HERE,
KELSEY?
>> BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE.
>> GREAT ANSWER.
>> GOOD ANSWER.
>> WHO IS THE BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE?
I MEAN, NAKOBE BEAN.
>> THE NEXT BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE IS MALIK WILLIS.
>> NOT HIM.
>> COULD YOU IMAGINE --
>> THE NEXT BEST DISH.
>> WE'RE TALKING LEO CHENAL.
>> JEREMY RUCKER.
>> MY FAULT.
>> A BUNCH OF OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
>> MARCUS JONES OUT OF HOUSTON.
>> HE'S ONE OF THE MOST FUN
PLAYERS --
>> HOLD ON A SECOND.
YOU SEE THAT?
YOU SEE WHO THE PICK IS, JASON,
NAKOBE DEAN OUT OF GEORGIA.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> IT'S GO TIME.
>> EAGLES.
>> THAT'S WHO'S AVAILABLE.
>> ALWAYS LOOKING FOR A
LINEBACKER AND THEY NEVER GET IT
AND THEY GET NAKOBE DEAN, IN THE
THIRD ROUND.
JASON KELCE.
HOW WE FEELING?
>> I FEEL GREAT.
HE'S THE BEST PLAYER AVAILABLE,
NAKOBE DEAN.
LINEBACKER, A POSITION THAT'S
HIGHLY IMPORTANT, EVERY DEFENSE,
BUT IN PARTICULAR JONATHAN
GAME'S DEFENSE.
TRACK RECORD, WHERE HE'S BEEN,
WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO, YOU RUN
A LOT OF SHELL.
THE LINEBACKER HAS TO BE ABLE TO
FLY AND RUN AROUND.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO FMIX UP
COVERAGES, YOU'RE ASKING A LOT
OF THESE GUYS.
CLOSED MIDDLE FIELD.
OPEN, IS IT FOUR OR TWO, YOU
KNOW, I MEAN, THIS GUY OFFERS
THAT ABILITY.
SO I'M EXCITED.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT PICK.
>> WE JUST GOT JORDAN DAVIS, AND
THEN NAKOBE DEAN, WHICH IS
INCREDIBLE.
I'LL READ THIS.
HE IS CALLED THE UNQUESTIONED
LEADER OF THE NATIONAL TITLE
TEAM.
HE GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL WITH A
4.3 GPA AND STUDIED MEDICAL
ENGINEERING AT GEORGIA WITH A
3.55.
HIS COACHES DESCRIBE HIM AS A
CULTURE CHANGER.
THE AWARD BINNER, SNAMS ALL
AMERICAN, AND MOST IMPORTANT I
WILL FIELDER GUY.
THAT IS YOUR FAVORITE PLAYER IN
THE DRAFT.
AND THE FELDER GUY IN THE THIRD
ROUND GOING TO THE PHILADELPHIA
EAGLES.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE HIM.
YOU WILL ABSOLUTELY LOVE THIS
GUY.
HE'S AMAZING.
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS, RIGHT,
HE'S THE SMARTEST PLAYER IN THE
DRAFT, BAR NONE, NOT CLOSE.
THE SMARTEST PLAYER IN THE
DRAFT.
DLIP CLIPS FROM THE MICHIGAN
GAME.
HE'S CALLING OUT THEIR PLAYS.
HE NOWS EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO.
CLEMSON GAME, THIS STANDS OUT TO
ME.
CLEMSON GAME, GAME ONE OF THIS
YEAR, PAST SEASON.
HE'S WRECKING, TAKING DOWN DJ --
6'6", 250.
IF HE DOESN'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH HIM.
WHO'S HE GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH?
HE CAN GET THE JOB DONE.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT YOU
MENTIONED UNQUESTIONED LEADER
AND HIS ACADEMIC TRACK RECORD.
THIS GUY KNEW WHAT HE WANTED TO
DO.
HE UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT WAS GOING
TO TAKE.
HE DOES TWO THINGS.
HE WATCHES FILM.
AND HE GOES TO SCHOOL.
THAT'S IT.
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS HE
DOES.
AND NOW THAT FOOTBALL IS HIS
JOB, HE'S JUST GOING TO WATCH
FOOTBALL, EAT, SLEEP AND BREATHE
FOOTBALL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT.
I UNDERSTAND WE'RE WORRIED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE MEDICAL.
THAT'S WHY HE GOES A LITTLE BIT
LATER.
BUT THE REALITY OF IT IS WHEN
YOU WATCH NAKOBE DEAN PLAY.
TWO PLAYERS THAT STAND OUT.
THE PICK SIX IN THE HIGHLIGHT
PACKAGE WHEN KELSEY WAS TALKING.
THE PICK SIX, WE SEE THIS GUY
LINED UP OUTSIDE, AS HE'S LINED
UP OUTSIDE HE GETS A PICK SIX.
LINED OCCUPY AN A RUNNING BACK,
AND MAN COVERAGE OUTSIDE THE
HASH, AND HE'S COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH TO BREAK ON THE BALL.
AND MAKE THE PICK SIX.
MOST LINEBACKERS SUT ON THEIR
HEELS AND WAIT FOR IT AND GET A
NICE TACKLE.
THE OTHER PLAY THAT STANDS OUT
TO ME, MICHIGAN, ME GETS A SACK
ON CADE McIN A MARA.
WE GET AN ORBIT MOTION.
CALLS OUT THE ORBIT MOTION,
OVER, OVER, OVER, AND HE SAYS
BLITZ STILL ON.
HE KNOWS THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO
MOTION HIM ACROSS.
HE SAID WE'RE GOING TO TRADE
THIS AND I'M GOING TO KEEP THE
BLISS BLITZ ON.
TRADE THIS, INSTANT SACK.
THEY DID AN ACCOUNT FOR HIM.
THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO
FOOL HIM.
IN THE NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME, GOAL LINE SITUATION, NICE
PLAY, ALABAMA SETS UP A NICE
PLAY, A LITTLE PLAY ACTION,
NAKOBE DEAN COVERS FOR HIM TO
BREAK UP A PASS.
BREAKS UP A BASS TO THE TIGHT
END, CAMERON LAYTU, THE FIRST
THING HE DOES AFTER HE BREAKS
THE PASS UP, GET UP AND GET IN
HIS FACE AND SAY, YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE, WHAT ARE
YOU DOING?
DO YOUR JOB.
DON'T DO MY JOB DORKS YOUR JOB,
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS?
NEXT PLAY.
TYNDALL, BRICE YOUNG, GAME OVER.
>> YOU'RE GIVING THIS WHAT
GRADE?
>> "A" PLUS.
I'M SWEATING.
>> WOW.
>> I FEEL LIKE THE BAND COMING
OFF AFTER LED ZEPPELIN LEFT THE
STAGE.
I'LL GIVE THIS AN "A" PLUS.
MOCK DRAFT TO THE EAGLES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN IN THE FIRST
ROUND FOR MONTHS.
EAGLES FANS SCREAMED AT ME AND
SAID HOWIE WILL NEVER TAKE A
LINEBACKER.
HE'S LAVONNE DAY DAVID, A
SPECIAL PLAYER, A SPECIAL
LEADER.
AWESOME, AWESOME PICK.
AND WE'RE ROOTING FOR NAKOBE
DEAN TO STAY HEALTHY.
>> YOU WENT ON THIS RANT LOU THE
RAVENS ARE DRAFTING CIRCLES
AROUND PEOPLE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, LOOK AT THE
EAGLES.
THE EAGLES HAVE CAM JERGENS,
NAKOBE DEAN, JORDAN DAVIS AND
A.J. BROWN.
>>> THE STEELERS, THAT'S A
STEELERS PICK RIGHT THERE.
DeMAR VIN LEAL, DEFENSIVE
LINEMAN, GOING TO THE STEELERS,
HE WAS A SECOND TEAM ALL
AMERICAN, FIRST TEAM ALL SEC, HE
LED TACKLES FOR LOSSES AND
SACKLES, GOING TO A STEELERS
TEAM THAT'S BEEN NEEDING DEPTH
ON THIS D LINE.
FRANKLY THEY'RE GETTING OLDER,
CAM HEYWARD, HE GOT DRAFTED,
SAME YEAR AS RICHARD SHERMAN AND
JASON KELCE.
I LOVE THEM ALL.
TUETT.
TYSON LIEU LA LIEU.
WHAT DO WE THINK?
>> 76th OVERALL PLAYER.
IS HE A 3 TECH OR 5 TECH.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO WITH
HIM?
HE'S SOMEBODY THAT'S A FINESSE
RUSHER.
WE'VE SEEN HIM USE THE EXCELLENT
SPIN MOVE WHICH IS NOT COMMON
FOR A MAN THAT'S 285 POUNDS.
REMINDED ME OF MALIK JACKSON.
FIGURING IT OUT AGAINST THE RUN.
THE PASS RUSH UPSIDE IS THERE
FOR HIM.
LEAL, A "B" FOR ME.
SOMETHING THE STEELERS NEEDED.
THE VALUE CHECKS OUT.
CAN YOU UNLOCK THIS GREAT PASS
RUSH TALENT WE'VE ALWAYS
EXPECTED FROM HIM THAT WE DIDN'T
SEE HIM TAKE THAT NEXT STEP IN
COLLEGE.
>> I LOVE THIS KID.
HE'S REALLY GOOD.
SUPER TALENTED.
I WANT TO SEE HIM PLAY WITH MORE
POWER, UNLOCK THAT POWER, AND
WHERE BETTER TO GO, THAN P
PITTSBURGH.
I'M GOING WITH A "B" PLUS, HE'S
SOMEONE I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR WHAT
JASON KELCE THINKS ABOUT HIM.
WHEN YOU WATCH HIM PLAY HE
BRINGS A LOT OF TALENT AND
MEASURE BLS.
HOW DOES IT PLAY OUT ON THE
FIELD?
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, KELSEY?
>> I THINK HE'LL A REALLY GOOD
PASS RUSHER, HE FINDS A WAY TO
GET TO THE QUARTERBACK, USES HIS
LENGTH WELL.
HE IS A KIND OF A TWEENER, KIND
OF MOVES ALL OVER.
AND THESE 3/4 TEAMS WILL VALUE
THAT.
HE PLAYS HIGH OCCASIONALLY ON
RUNDOWNS AND CAN GET DRIVEN OFF
THE BALL.
IF THERE'S A GREAT PLACE FOR HIM
TO GO, IT'S PITTSBURGH.
THE DEFENSIVE LINEMEN THEY'VE
HAD.
THEY HAVE A KNACK FOR DRAFTING
GUYS THAT FIT THEIR SYSTEM AND
CAN EXCEL IN IT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, IT'S -- FOR A
GUY THAT I WAS KIND OF UNSURE
ABOUT, I THINK HIM GOING TO
PITTSBURGH MAKES ME FEEL BETTER
ABOUT THIS PICK.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
HE'S A PITTSBURGH GUY AND THEN
THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS COME
BACK AND THEY GET A PATRIOTS
GUY.
MARCUS JONES, ELITE RETURN
SKILLS, NINE CAREER SPECIAL
TEAMS TOUCHDOWNS, HE IS A HECK
OF A CORNER, PAUL HORNING AWARD
WINNER, CONSENSUS ALL AMERICAN,
YOU GET THE PAUL HORNING AWARD
WHEN YOU DO A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERYTHING.
THEY DID LOSE JC JACKSON, ONE
LITTLE THING.
HE HAS A RAT NAMED ELLIOTT JAY,
AND HE DROPPED AN ALBUM CALLED
COMPLICATIONS IN SEPTEMBER.
>> THIS ISN'T A COMPLICATED
PICK.
HE'S AWESOME, MAN, FIVE PICKS,
12 PASS BREAKUPS THIS YEAR, A
LEGENDARY RETURNER.
HE WAS DONTE HALL OF COLLEGE.
>> HE'LL BE THE BETHEL JOHNSON
FOR THE PATRIOTS.
>> HE'S UNBELIEVABLE.
AN INCREDIBLE SPECIAL TEAMS
PLAYER, A LEGITIMATE STARTING
SLOT CORNER, THE VALUE FITS
HERE.
>> WHICH IS WHAT JC JACKSON
PLAYED.
>> A LITTLE BIT OUTSIDE TOO.
MARCUS, YOU'RE STRICTLY A SLOT.
THAT'S OKAY.
ATHLETICISM FOR MAN COVERAGE.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS,
HE'S ONE OF THE BEST RETURNERS,
PUNT AND KICKS I'VE EVER SEEN IN
MY ENTIRE LIFE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EVERY TIME
THE BALL IS IN HIS HANDS.
YOU COULD BLINK AND HE'S IN THE
END ZONE.
TERRIFYING.
I LOVE MARCUS JONES.
I THINK THIS IS THE FIRST GOOD
PATRIOTS PICK OF THIS DRAFT SO
FAR, ONE THAT HE'LL BE THERE FOR
A LONG TIME.
THIS FOR ME IS A "B" PLUS HERE.
ELECTRIC SPECIAL TEAMS AND HE
CAN BE THE ANSWER AS A SLOT
CORNER.
>> I LOVE HIM.
HE'S REALLY SPECIAL.
I LIKE HIM AS A CORNER.
THIS GUY WILL CLIMB A TREE AND
HE WILL GO GET IT DONE.
I'M GIVING HIM AN "A."
HOW TENACIOUS HE IS AT THE
QUARTERBACK SPOT AND YOU ADD IN
THE RETURN STUFF.
THAT'S THE BOAT.
BUT I LOVE THE MEAT THAT'S ON
THE BONE OF HIM PLAYING THE
CORNERBACK POSITION.
>> GET BACK ON CAMERA, IT IS
TIME TO HAVE A MOMENT.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING THE
TELEVISION BROADCAST RIGHT NOW,
YOU'RE SEEING PICTURES OF
FOUNTAINS.
YOU'RE SEEING NOTHING, AND WE
ARE GOING TO BREAK THIS NEWS TO
YOU, BECAUSE THE TENNESSEE
TITANS ARE UP, AND THE TENNESSEE
TITANS HAVE OFFICIALLY SELECTED
MALIK WILLIS WITH THE 86th PICK.
RYAN TANNEHILL IS THERE IN
TENNESSEE, BUT NOW YOU HAVE THE
MOBILE QUARTERBACK OF THIS
DRAFT, WHO MANY BELIEVE WAS THE
NUMBER ONE QUARTERBACK IN THIS
DRAFT, GOING TO TENNESSEE, HE
COULD BE THE FUTURE OF THIS
TEAM.
BOWL GAME MVP, BOBBY BOWDEN
AWARD WINNER, A CAREER TOUCHDOWN
INTERCEPTION RATIO OF 48-18.
LED LIBERTY TO ITS FIRST TOP 25
RANKING, A WIN OVER AN ACC
OPPONENT, HE IS COACHABLE, HE IS
OBSERVANT, AND HE LED THE NATION
IN RUSHING.
TO GET HIM HERE AT PICK NUMBER
86, CONNOR.
>> TREMENDOUS, 33rd OVERALL
PLAYER AND I'M GLAD TO SAY THAT
ASBESTOSIS A QUARTERBACK IN THE
DRAFT.
FOR HOW MUCH CRITICISM THIS
QUARTERBACK CLASS HAS TAKEN.
MALIK WILLIS HAS BEEN AN AWESOME
RISER.
GOES TO LIBERTY.
I WENT TO THE SENIOR BOWL.
BEST GUY ON THE FIELD.
HE HAS EXCELLENT VISION TA
RUNNER, WHICH IS REALLY, REALLY
SPECIAL, HE'S GOT A ROCKET ARM.
HE WAS VERY ACCURATE IN
PRACTICES, NOW, IS THERE GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENCE
GAME SPEED AT THE NEXT LEVEL?
OF COURSE THERE IS WHERE YOU'RE
GOING TO WANT TO LET HIM
MARINATE.
HE'S GOING TO GET TO SIT BEHIND
RYAN TANNEHILL.
I DIDN'T WANT HIM THROWN INTO
THE FIRE.
HE NEEDS TO SEASON A LITTLE BIT.
GET USED TO A PRO OFFENSE AND
HE'S RUN A LOT OF PLAY ACTION AT
THE COLLEGE LEVEL.
HE'S GOOD AT THAT AND THAT'S
GOING TO WORK FOR TENNESSEE.
HE'S GOING TO PUSH THE BALL
VERTICALLY DOWN THE FIELD.
WE MIGHT NOT SEE HIM UNTIL 2023,
BUT THERE'S A RED ZONE PACKAGE
FOR HIM BECAUSE OF THE TYPE OF
ATHLETE HE IS AND HOW SMART OF A
THROWER HE CAN BE IN THAT RED
ZONE AREA.
IT'S AN "A" PLUS FOR ME.
I'M INTRIGUED BY THE LONG-TERM
POTENTIAL MALIK WILLIS, AND HE
HAS LONG TERM COACHING TO DO
THAT.
>> IT'S SIMPLE TO CALL THIS AN
"A" PLUS.
THE REALITY IS, HE'S A GUY THAT
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT HE MIGHT
FRIDAY UP AT FIVE.
IT'S AN "A" PLUS, INSTEAD, HE
KEEPS DROPPING, KEEPS DROPPING,
I FEEL FOR HIM.
IT'S A ROUGH SPOT TO BE IN WHEN
YOU'RE SIT TLG AND YOU'VE GOT
YOUR SUIT ON AND YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO BE THE GUY.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY HE'S
IN A BETTER SITUATION.
HE'S WITH A TEAM THAT DOESN'T
NEED HIM TO PLAY RIGHT NOW.
WITH A TEAM THAT CAN LET HIM
GROW AS A PERSON AND A PLAYER.
A TEAM THAT CAN LET HIM LEARN
HOW TO BE A PROFESSIONAL IN THE
NFL WITHOUT THE WEIGHT AND
PRESSURE OF CARRYING A CITY ON
YOUR BACK, WHICH THE MEANS HE
CAN GROW INTO THIS OFFENSE, THIS
SCHEME, AND TURN INTO A PLAYER
THAT NOT JUST A CONTRIBUTOR, BUT
A LONG TIME STARTER IN THE NFL,
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
WEIGHT OF BEING A TOP TEN PICK,
OR THE WEIGHT OF BEING SOMEONE'S
FRANCHISE QUARTERBACK
IMMEDIATELY.
>> LET'S SIT ON THIS FOR A
SECOND BEFORE WE MOVE TO THE
NEXT PICK.
WE BOTH GIVE HIM AN "A" PLUS,
YOU'RE DRAFTING HIM WITH TREYLON
BURKS, THEY'RE COMING IN
TOGETHER TO ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP.
NUMBER TWO, THIS IS A TEAM THAT
THEY HAVE ROBERT WOODS.
HE'S GOING TO BE AROUND SOME
PROFESSIONALS TOO.
TANNEHILL, HIM, THEY CAN BOTH DO
THE SAME THING BUT I THINK ABOUT
THE EXCITEMENT OF THIS KID'S
LEGS IF HE WERE TO FAKE THE
HANDOFF, TO DEREK HENRY.
>> YEAH.
>> WITH THE AMOUNT OF ATTENTION
HE TAKES AND TO BE ABLE TO ROLL
OUT THAT WAY.
THAT'S WHERE IT GETS REALLY
EXCITING.
>> AND HE -- SO MUCH PLAY ACTION
IN HIS COLLEGE OFFENSE.
ALMOST HALF THE TIME.
WAS PLAY ACTION.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME, YOU'RE
GOING TO ROLL MALIK WILLIS OUT,
AND CREATE LEVELS OF THE FIELD.
>> A TREYLON BURKS LEVEL, A
ROBERT WOODS LEVEL.
>> YES.
>> ALL LEVELS OF FIELD, WHERE HE
CAN PUSH THE BALL 60 YARDS ON A
SPIRAL.
HE CAN ALSO CHALLENGE YOU WITH
HIS LEGS.
WHERE LINEBACKERS.
>> PUT SOMEBODY IN CONFLICT.
>> CONFLICT, EXACTLY.
THE FORCE PLAYER, THE CONFLICT.
IS HE GOING TO HAVE TO COME UP,
AND MAKE THE INTERMEDIATE THROW.
CUTTING THE FIELD IN HALF IS SO
KEY TO DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS THE RIGHT OFFENSE FOR
HIM.
I KNOW MALIK WILLIS, WITH A
GREAT PERSONALITY, HE'S NOT
DISAPPOINTED BUT INTERNALLY YOU
HAVE TO BE.
THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING FIRST
ROUND FOR MONTHS IN THE MOCK
DRAFTS, THIS IS THE RIGHT
SITUATION FOR HIM.
I THINK THIS GIVES HIM THE BEST
CHANCE OF ANYONE IN THIS
QUARTERBACK CLASS TO BE A
SUPERSTAR DOWN THE LINE.
>> WOW, THAT WORKED OUT PRETTY
WELL.
CAM THOMAS, THE PICK FOR
ARIZONA, HERE AT 87 #.
CAM THOMAS, A NAME WE'VE BEEN
WAITING TO HEAR FOR A LITTLE BIT
HERE.
CAM THOMAS, EDGE RUSHER OUT OF
SAN DIEGO STATE.
6'4", 267 #, WHAT DO WE THINK AT
87.
>> THEY MOVED HIM ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
FIVE TECH, THREE TECH.
>> ARIZONA LOVES THOSE GUYS.
>> 87th OVERALL PLAYER.
THIS IS RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
REMINDED ME OF DEREK BARNETT.
INTERIOR PASS RUSH IS THE NAME
OF HIS GAME.
I'LL SAY THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE A DOWNER
HERE, BUT MASSIVE PRODUCTION.
A LOT OF IT IS COVERAGE SACKS,
STUNTS, TWISTS.
>> IT MIGHT NOT BE REPLACING
CHANDLER JONES THAT EASILY.
>> I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THE MASSIVE PRODUCTION THERE,
IT'S A LITTLE MISLEADING, HE'S
NOT VERY FLEXIBLE OR TWITCHY.
IT'S THE CLICHE.
HE PLAYS EXTREMELY HARD.
THERE'S A LOT OF COVERAGE SACKS
THERE, COULDN'T PARTICIPATE IN
THE SENIOR BOWL.
>> 99.
>> THEY ALREADY HAVE JJ WATT.
>> HE'S SMB THAT CAN COME AND
GIVE YOU HIGH EFFORT RUSHER.
HE DID HAVE A LOT OF SUCCESS OFF
STUNTS AND TWISTS.
THIS IS A "B" FOR ME.
RIGHT WHERE HE SHOULD HAVE GONE,
DID THEY NEED THE HELP IN THE
TRENCHES ON THE "D" LINE.
>> I LIKE HIM, WATCHING MOUNTAIN
WEST, HE WAS PRODUCTIVE, AND HE
WAS PRODUCTIVE ON SLANTS, ON
TWISTS, AND ON MISMATCHES.
THE OTHER THING, MISMATCHES, IF
YOU GET HIM LINE ON THE TIGHT
END, HE'S GOING TO WHIP THAT
TIGHT END'S GOOIND BEHIND.
"A" MINUS, HE HAS THE ABILITY TO
MAKE THE PLAY.
THE BIG KEY IS HOW YOU USE HIM.
BETTER AT RUSHING, I THINK,
SLANTING TOWARDS THE INSIDE.
THAN HE IS WINNING AROUND THE
EDGE, AGAINST THE TACKLE.
>> THE PICK IS IN FOR THE DALLAS
COWBOYS AT PICK NUMBER 88.
JALIN TOLBERT, THE COWBOYS HAVE
TRADED AMARI COOPER.
THEY'VE LOST CEDRICK WILSON.
THEY SIGNED JAMES WASHINGTON,
BUT THE PICK THAT THEY GO WITH
HERE AT PICK NUMBER 88, JALEN
TOLBERT OUT OF SOUTH ALABAMA.
>> I'M A BIG FAN OF THIS SPOT
HERE FOR THE COWBOYS.
THIS GIVES THEMS THE DEPTH THEY
NEEDED AT WIDE RECEIVER.
65th OVERALL PLAYER FOR ME, I
SAID EARLIER REMINDS ME OF VAN
JEFFERSON.
TOLBERT, NOT THE BIGGEST GUY,
BUT HE'S GOT ENOUGH SIZE.
PHYSICAL PLAYER.
THE QUARTERBACK PLAY WAS NOT
GREAT.
HE WAS GIVEN CHANCE ON 50/50
OPPORTUNITIES, FOOTBALL CHANCES
WERE EVEN LOWER THAN THAT.
GOOD DOUBLE MOVE TO WIN
VERTICALLY.
DALLAS IS GOING TO LIKE TO SEE
GREAT RELEASES OFF THE LINE OF
SCRIMMAGE.
WASTES NO TIME GETTING INTO HIS
ROUTES.
HE'S READY TO GO.
I'M EXCITED FOR THIS ONE.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR DALLAS, GREAT
VALUE AT A POSITION THEY'VE BEEN
ALL OVER GOING BACK TO ROUND
ONE.
>> NOT GREAT QUARTERBACK PLAY
YET.
HE SET A SCHOOL RECORD WITH 178
CAREER CATCHES, 22 BEING
TOUCHDOWNS.
FIRST PLAYER IN SCHOOL HISTORY
TO GET A THOUSAND YARDS IN A
SEASON, AND THEY DID IT TWICE.
YOUR FINGER IS ON THE GRADE, IS
IT HIGH?
J.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW HIGH?
>> "A."
>> PUT IT UP THERE.
>> BOOM.
LISTEN, WATCHING THIS GUY ADJUST
TO THE BALL, IT HELPED HIM, THE
BAD QUARTERBACK PLAY --
>> TO BE FAIR, IT STARTS WITH
BAD OFFENSIVE LINE PLAY.
QUARTERBACKS ARE THROWING THE
FALLING DOWN.
HE ADJUSTS EXCEPTIONALLY WELL.
IT WILL HELP HIM INCREASE HIS
CATCH RADIUS.
>> ST. BROWN IS GOING TO THE
COWBOYS.
HOW DOES HE FIT IN?
>> I THINK IT'S AN AWESOME FIT.
YOU KNOW, PLAYING THE SIDES.
TD LAM, WON'T HAVE TOO MUCH
PRESSURE ON HIM.
WATCH THE TAPE.
HE PUTS TOGETHER A LOT OF
THINGS.
REMINDS ME OF MARVIN JONES, CAN
DO A LOFT THINGS, CAN GO DEEP,
RUB A CURL ROUTE.
HAS PRETTY GOOD HANDS.
SO, REMINDS ME A LOT OF HIM.
LIKE YOU SAID, QUARTERBACK PLAY
WASN'T THE BEST BUT HE ADJUSTED
TO IT, AND MADE THE DEEP BALL.
CAUGHT ALMOST -- YOU KNOW, ALL
THE DEEP BALLS THROWN TO HIM.
SO HE REMINDS ME OF MARVIN
JONES.
I'M EXCITED FOR HIM.
GREAT FOR DALLAS.
>> MAN --
>> GOOD PLAYER COMP.
>> YEAH.
>> JALEN TOLBERT, HE WILL GET
SOME TIME WIDE RECEIVERS PLAY IN
DALLAS.
>>> BUFFALO BILLS ARE UP, AND
THEY ARE SELECTING LINEBACKER,
TYREL BERNARD, THE PICK FOR
BUFFALO, HE'S GOING TO SLIP INTO
A SITUATION WHERE YOU KIND OF
LOOK AT THE LINE BACKING CORE,
EVANS, HOW DOES HE FIT?
WHAT KIND OF STYLE OF LINEBACKER
ARE THE BILLS GETTING?
>> MONEY BACKER, A GUY THAT'S
6'1", 225 POUNDS, BUILT LIKE A
STRONG SAFETY.
ANOTHER GUY AT BAYLOR THAT'S A
PRETTY GOOD TESTER.
PLAYS FAST AND CLEARLY THIS WAS
THE KIND OF PLAYER THEY WANTED.
BECAUSE THERE ARE MUCH BETTER
LINE BACKERS ON THE BOARD.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A LEO CHENAL
TYPE OF PLAYER.
A LOT OF GUYS.
THEY WANTED AN ATHLETE.
I VALUED HIM AS A DAY THREE
PLAYER.
AT BEST AS A PACKAGE PLAYER, FOR
THE BILLS, MY 204th PLAYER, I
CAN'T GIVE EVERYONE A GRADE.
"C" MINUS FOR ME.
IT'S A REACH.
>> I LIKE HIM.
I LIKE BAYLOR'S DEFENSE, THOUGH,
THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF GUYS I
LIKE.
HE'S A GOOD RUN AND CATCH
LINEBACKER.
HE'LL TRACK YOU DOWN FROM
BEHIND.
INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE.
THIS IS A "B" PLUS.
IF THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR, THIS IS THE GUY FOR THE
JOB.
HE'S GOING TO DO IT AND HE'S
KIND OF -- HE'S GOT BUMP AND RUN
IN HIS GAME.
WHEN HE GETS INTO TRAFFIC, HE
CAN MAKE HIMSELF NOT BE --
BASICALLY, HE DOESN'T LET THEM
PUT HANDS ON HIM.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT HE'S GOD AT.
TO GET HIM HERE, IS GOOD, I FEEL
LIKE THAT'S STILL GOOD VALUE.
I KNOW YOU HAD HIM LOWER.
IF WE WERE JUST GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE SAME THING WITH
CHRISTIAN HARRIS, HE FITS INTO
THAT SAME MOLD.
AS A GUY WHO, IF THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO ASK HIM TO DO,
HE'S GOING TO DO IT REALLY,
REALLY WELL.
IF YOU WANTED TICK BUTKUS, YOU
MESSED.
BUT IF YOU WANT A GUY THAT'S
GOING TO RUN AND CHASE.
>> THE TWO GUYS FOR ME, JEREMIAH
GIMABLE, AND JO JO DUNN, I COULD
HAVE TAKEN.
>> CAN YOU IMAGINE IN DICK
BUTKUS, A NAME IN THE TWITTER
AREA.
>> IT IS SMOKE MONDAY IN THIS
DRAFT.
>> EVERY MONDAY.
>> IT IS NOW TIME FOR THE FIRST
PICK AND THE RAIDERS, COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FRANCHISE.
DAVANTE ADAMS.
JONES IS THERE, JOSH McDANIELS
IS THEIR COACH.
THE FIRST THING I THOUGHT IS
THEY NEED TO AFFIX THIS RIGHT
SIDE OF THE OFFENSIVE LINE.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
SAY --
>> IT IS NOT GOOD AND THEY'RE
GOING WITH DYLAN PARHAM.
>> PARHAM?
>> DYLAN PARHAM.
>> THEY NEEDED AN OFFENSIVE.
>> ARE YOU A PIRATE.
>> IT'S NOT TRAY PITKINS, BUT
IT'S DYLAN PARHAM.
CAN HE REPLACE ALEX LEATHERWOOD.
>> >> GIVE LEATHERWOOD A CHANCE.
REALLY GOOD ATHLETE, ENOUGH
LENGTH.
EXCELLENT FORTY.
FOUR YEAR STARTER AT GUARD,
EXPECTED TO PLAY CENTER AT THE
NEXT LEVEL AND HE REMINDED ME OF
A FORMER RAIDER, RODNEY HUDSON.
I LOOKED AT DYLAN PARHAM AND
SHOULD HAVE GONE WELL ABOVE LUKE
PORT NEAR.
DAY TWO PLAYER, STARTING CALIBER
PLAYER, MOVEMENT SKILLS, PUT ON
A LOT OF WEIGHT OVER HIS TIME AS
A FOUR YEAR STARTER AND NOW NFL
READY.
SWEET PICK BY THE RAIDERS.
THIS IS GOOD VALUE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT PARHAM, HE'S MY 84th RANKED
PLAYER, WE'RE AT THAT POINT IN
THE DRAFT.
THIS IS AN AMINUS.
GLAD THEY DIDN'T GET THE TYPE OF
GUY THEY NEEDED TO DRAFT, JUST
TOOK THE BEST PLAYER.
>> JASON KELCE, DO YOU LOVE
THIS.
>> I LOVE IT.
LISTEN, LET'S JUST LET KELSEY
TALK ABOUT IT.
>> WE LIKE THIS ONE.
>> I'M GOING "B" PLUS.
HE'S A GOOD FOOTBALL PLAYER,
BLOCKED FOR A LOT OF SUCCESSFUL
RUNNING BACKS AT MEMPHIS.
>> YOU'RE DAMN RIGHT.
>> LET'S GET TO KELSEY.
>> THE FIRST PICK IN THE DAVE
ZIEGLER ERA.
WHAT DID YOU THINK WHEN YOU
WATCHED PARHAM ON TAPE.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
I THINK HE'S A GUY WITH
VERSATILITY.
A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT POSITIONS,
EVERYTHING FROM TACKLE.
OBVIOUSLY NEXT LEVEL IT'S GUARD
OR CENTER, IN PARTICULAR, MORE
OF A CENTER.
MOVES REALLY WELL.
GREAT ATHLETE.
YOU SEE HIM OUT ON THE RUN.
YOU SEE HIM COME DOWNHILL.
BUT I'VE WATCHED HIM IN THE
SENIOR BOWL.
WHEN THEY MOVED HIM TO CENTER TO
SEE WHAT HE COULD DO AND HE
REMINDS ME, AND LIKE THE WAY HIS
HIPS AND THE WAY HE SINKS, AND
THE WAY HE USES HIS LEVERAGE,
KIND OF IN A SIMILAR ROLE, LIKE
A BRIAN ALLEN FOR L.A.
>> INTERESTING.
>> I JUST LIKE THE KID A LOT.
I THINK HE'S A GOOD PLAYER.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A
REALLY GOOD CENTER, AT SOME
POINT.
>> ALL RIGHT, INTERIOR OFFENSIVE
LINEMAN FOR THE LRGS RAIDERS.
>>> AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE
TAMPA BAY BUCS GOING WITH RASHAD
WHITE.
THEY STARTED OFF WITH LOGAN
HALL, THEN LUKE DECKY, AND NOW
RASHAD WHITE.
>> THEY NEEDED A RUNNING BACK,
AND RASHAD WHITE, SOLID PLAYER,
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD
RUNNING BACKS.
HE REMINDS ME OF KENYON DRAKE.
HE CAN CUT IN THE OPEN FIELD.
GET THE OPEN FIELD.
I THINK IT'S EARLY FOR HIM.
BUT WE KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS
FOR HIM.
HE TESTED REALLY, REALLY WELL.
THERE IS ATHLETICISM ON THE FILM
BUT ONCE AGAIN I VALUE DAMIAN
WEERS, THESE ARE POWER BACKS,
DAMEON PIERCE, BRIAN ROBINSON
JUNIOR, AND THEY'RE WAY BETTER
PLAYERS.
FOR ME, THIS IS A "C" PLUS RIGHT
HERE.
>> I LIKE THIS KID.
BECAUSE HE -- 43 CATCHES LAST
YEAR.
I THINK THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
HERE.
THE GUYS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT HAVE BETTER -- THOSE ARE
GUYS THAT DON'T MAKE CATCHES
LIKE THAT.
>> TAKE KAI RON WILLIAMS.
>> SEE WHERE I'M GOING?
>> GOOD POINT.
BUT THE MOST OF THE REST, THEY
DON'T HAVE THAT PASS CATCHING
PRODUCTION.
>> BETTER ATHLETE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO "B" PLUS.
I THINK HE'S A BETH ATHLETE.
IS THIS A GUY YOU THINK CAN PLAY
IN THE SLOTS?
>> I DO THINK SO.
>> THEY ADDS VALUE.
>> KYREN WILLIAMS IS PROBABLY A
BETTER RUNNING BACK BUT YOU
DON'T GET THAT ADDITIONAL VALUE.
WITH RESPECT TO TRYING TO MAKE A
RUN RIGHT NOW.
HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF A PIECE,
A SAFETY VALVE, AND ALL THOSE
THINGS, YOU GET THAT WITH HIM.
HE DESERVES A LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> DON'T GO ON, LET ME ASK AS A
FOLLOW-UP.
BETTER THAN GIOVANNI BERNARD,
BECAUSE HE CAN BE MORE OF A
RUNNING THREAT?
>> HE JUST OFFERS MORE
EXPLOSIVENESS.
>> WHAT FELDER JUST SAID, I
THOUGHT OF JAMES WHITE.
AND WHEN I THINK OF TOM BRADY,
HE NEEDS THAT YOUNG PASS
CATCHING RUNNING BACK TO REALLY
STRETCH A DEFENSE.
>> I THINK WHITE'S FLAWLESS IN
PASS PRO, AND I DON'T THINK
RACHAAD WHITE IS THERE.
>> WHAT ROOKIE RUNNING BACKS
EVER ARE.
>> THE GREEN BAY PACKERS ARE UP.
LAST TIME THEY TOOK CHRISTIAN
WATSON OUT OF NORTH DAKOTA
STATE.
OFFENSE OR DEFENSE, AND IT IS
GOING TO BE SEAN RYAN WITH THE
90 SECOND PICK.
FELDER --
>> IN A GOOD WAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST GUARD
PROSPECTS.
>> LOVE THE HAIR.
>> HE PLAYED TACKLE IN COLLEGE,
HE HAD SOME STRUCKLESS IN PASS
PROTECTION AT TACKLE IN COLLEGE
BUT I THINK THAT'S ALL GOING TO
BE FIXED AT GUARD WHERE FOR ME
IT'S LESS THINKING FOR THE KIND
OF PLAYER HE IS.
I THINK I LIKE HIS FEET AT GUARD
BERTD.
IT REMINDED ME OF A HEAVIER
VERSION OF CAESAR RUIZ.
I LIKE HOW NASTY HE CAN BE AS A
RUN BLOCKER.
HE'S GOT ENOUGH JUICE TO PULL AS
A GUARD.
FOR SEAN RYAN HERE, THE
PACKERS -- I KNOW I WAS HARD ON
THEM LAST NIGHT.
THEY ARE PHENOMENAL AT DRAFTING
DAY TWO OFFENSIVE LINEMEN.
THEY'VE TAKEN SOME OF MY
FAVORITES.
ELTON JENKINS, HE'S BEEN A
DYNAMITE PLAYER FOR THEM.
>> DAVID BAKTIARI.
>> A DECADE.
SEAN RYAN, "B" PLUS, IT GIVES
THEM DEPTH AND IT WILL HELP
THEIR INTERIOR.
>> HE COULD SLIDE IN THAT GUARD
SPOT WITH JENKINS AND JOSH
MEYER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS
KID?
>> I WAS LIKE, DON'T PICK THE
ONE I WAS GOING TO PICK.
BUT I WAS GOING TO GO "B" PLUS,
WHEN YOU THROW OUT THE
PROPOSITION OF HIM MOVING
INSIDE.
BEING PROTECTED TO HIS OUTSIDE.
THAT'S A HUGE PLUS FOR HIM
BECAUSE HE CAN'T GET ALL THE WAY
UPFIELD.
BUT I DO THINK HE WAS HELPED
TREMENDOUSLY BY PLAYING IN CHIP
KELLY'S SYSTEM WHERE THEY WERE
RUN HEAVY.
HE REALLY GOT TO SHOW OFF HIS
CHOPS AS A RUN BLOCKER.
>> 31 CONSECUTIVE STARTS, ONLY
ALLOWED TWO SACKS IN ALL OF
THOSE STARTS, WAS THE NUMBER TWO
RANKED GUARD IN THAT 2019
RECRUITING CLASS.
HE MIGHT END UP BACK THERE, AND
HE WAS A RUGBY PLAYER GROWING
UP.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS, RUGBY
FEELS TOUGHER THAN FOOTBALL
SOMETIMES.
>> WELL, LESS PADS.
>> NO PADS, NO HELMET.
>>> WE ARE NOW TWO PICKS AHEAD
OF TELEVISION.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE.
ARE WE DOING SOME ROCKET
MORTGAGE FIRST?
LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FWRENDS AT
ROCKET MORTGAGE, BECAUSE WE'RE
AHEAD.
>>> HERE THE LAST TEN PICKS, IN
A NAKOBE DEAN, EYE EEPER.
HIM AND MARCUS JONES.
MALIK WILLIS IS THE BIG STORY
HERE, GOING TO TENNESSEE.
NAKOBE DEAN GOING TO THE EAGLES.
AND IT JUST MAKES YOU JUST WANT
TO TAKE YOUR SHOES OFF AND JUST
GO --
[ WHISTLING ]
>> NAKOBE DEAN IS ON THE EAGLES.
FEELS GREAT.
MALIK WILLIS.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE WHAT I JUST
WITNESSED.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT DOWN WITH
SALEH, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
>> SAN FRANCISCO 49ers ARE ON
THE CLOCK, THEY'VE TAKEN ONE
PLAYER IN THIS DRAFT AND IT'S
DRAKE JACKSON, THE DEFENSIVE
END, OUT OF USC.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH DEEBO SAMUEL.
ALEX MACK, A CHANCE HE COULD
RETIRE.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A CENTER
OUT THERE THAT MAKES SENSE THAT
FITS IN KYLE SHANAHAN'S SYSTEM.
>> I LOOK MORE WITH SAFETY.
>> SOMEONE OPPOSITE OF JIMMY
WARD.
SEE WHAT THEY GO WITH.
>> PUT IT ON THE BOARD.
DO WE HAVE SAFETY?
SURVEY SAYS -- LSU RUNNING BACK
TY DAVIS PRICE.
THERE'S NOT ONE POSITION THAT I
THINK KYLE SHANAHAN HAS HIT LESS
ON IN THESE LAST FEW YEARS THAN
A MIDDLE ROUND RUNNING BACK.
MICHAEL FELDER JUST SAID WHO.
>> I SAID WHY.
>> I SAID WHAT.
>> RUNNING BACK OUT OF LSU, DOES
HE FIT THAT KYLE SHANAHAN
SCHEME.
>> NOT AT ALL.
NORTH SOUTH RUNNER, POWER, NOT
CREATIVE, IN MY EYES, HAD SOME
MAMMOTH GAMES, AND YOU'RE SEEING
ONE HERE AGAINST FLORIDA, WHERE
HIS OFFENSIVE LINE GAME BROKE
TACKLES SECOND LEVEL.
THIS TO ME SAYS THEY SAW THE
TESTING NUMBERS AND SAID YOU FIT
THE WIDE ZONE.
I DON'T THINK HE PLAYS LIKE
THAT.
HIGHWAYS PLAYER 193 FOR ME.
I DID NOT THINK THEY NEEDED
RUNNING BACK HELP.
RUNNING WAC HELP OR MAYBE
DEPENDING WHAN WHAT HAPPENS WITH
THEIR STAR RECEIVER.
CAPITALIZE ON THE WIDE RECEIVER
DRAFT HERE AND GET AHEAD.
I DON'T LIKE THIS WICK AT ALL.
EVEN IF TY DAVIS-PRICE IS AN
AVERAGE PLAYER OR A GOOD PLAYER.
I DON'T THINK HE'S A GOOD FIT.
THIS IS A "D."
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS AT ALL.
DID KYLE SHANAHAN HAVE TO HAVE A
RUNNING BACK AND DID HE HAVE TO
HAVE ONE HERE, AND THERE'S EIGHT
BETTER RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T GET IT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS TO TY
DAVIS-PRICE.
YOUR LIFE A ABOUT TO CHANGE.
I'M GIVING THIS A "C" MINUS.
"C'S" GET DEGREES.
HE'S A DOWNHILL RUNNER.
HE IS -- HE'S LIKE GREAT VALUE
LEONARD FOURNETTE.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT IN
THIS.
>> NO.
>> CAN WE WRAP THIS ONE UP?
THAT'S ALL.
THAT, TO ME --
>> THE ONLY NOTE I WANT TO SAY
IS, IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
THAT TWO YEARS IN A ROW, IN THE
THIRD ROUND, A RUNNING BACK IS
TAKEN BY THE 49ers, THAT WE
DON'T THINK FITS THEIR SCHEME,
AND LAST YEAR WE GAVE THEM -- WE
GAVE THEM THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT.
WE LOOKED, AND WE SAID IT'S KYLE
SHANE HA HAN, AND HE COULDN'T
GET ON THE FIELD IN PRE-SEASON
AND NOW THEY TAKE TY
DAVIS-POLICE AND WE'RE GOING, I
KNOW THAT YOU GUYS, THESE ARE
THE RUNNING BACKS TAKEN.
>> LISTEN, WHEN YOU WATCH TY
DAVIS-POLICE OR TREY SERMON.
WE SEE LEAD BLOCKING PLACE, LIKE
WE'RE WATCHING LEAD BLOCKERS
PULL AND LEAD THEM THROUGH THE
HOLE AND THEY RUN THROUGH THAT.
WE'RE NOT SEEING WIDE ZONE,
STRETCH ZONE, OUTSIDE ZONE.
>> WHO IS THE GUY NAMED JOE THAT
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers TOOK
LIKE THREE OR FOUR YEARS AGO?
>> FROM UTAH.
>> YES.
>> JOE -- WAS THE LAST NAME
SMITH.
>> TO WASHINGTON.
>> EITHER WAY.
THEY HAVE ELIJAH MITCHELL, MY
BIGGEST POINT HERE, I THOUGHT
ELIJAH MITCHELL --
>> ALSO JEFF WILSON.
BUT MY THING IS, WHEN YOU RUN
SHANE THAN'S SYSTEM I THOUGHT
THE WHOLE ADVANTAGE WAS YOU
COULD PUT ANYBODY IN THERE AND
IT WORKS.
WHY ARE WE USING DRAFT PICKS ON
RUNNING BACKS.
>> YOU CAN'T PUT ANYBODY IN
THERE --
>> THE PANTHERS TRADE UP AND
TAKE MATT CORRAL.
CHRIS SIMMS IS SMILING.
QUARTERBACK MATT CORRAL OUT OF
OLE MISS.
6'2", 212.
ONLY FBS PLAYERS.
500 RUSHING YARDS THE LAST TWO
SEASONS, RESPONSIBLE FOR 75
TOUCHDOWNS IN 37 GAMES, PLAYED,
THE COACH THERE SAYS KIDS
GRAVITATE TOWARDS HIM, AND HE'S
THE SON OF A MARINE.
FIXES INTERCEPTIONS, 20-5
TOUCHDOWN INTERCEPTION RATIO
LAST YEAR.
EVERYTHING I HEAR ABOUT HIM IS
THAT THE BALL SNAPS AND HE'S
GOING TO BE COMPETING WITH SAM
DARNOLD.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU, CONNOR,
WHEN THEY GO TO TRAINING CAMP IS
HE GOING TO LOOK BETTER THAN SAM
DARNOLD?
>> PHYSICALLY, THROWING THE
FOOTBALL, HE HAS A BETTER ARM.
HE NEEDS TIME AS WELL.
RECKLESS AT TIMES IN COLLEGE
WITH THE FOOTBALL.
HE PLAYED IN A SYSTEM WHERE
EVERYTHING WAS VERY DEFINED FOR
HIM.
HE KNEW WHERE HE WAS GOING WITH
THE FOOTBALL.
IF IT DID NOT LOOK GOOD.
IT WAS, OKAY, I WILL RUN WITH
THE FOOTBALL.
HE'S A TRUE KIND OF ONE READ
COLLEGE QUARTERBACK.
IN TRAINING CAMP, IN JUST
PASSING DRILLS, HE'S GOING TO
IMPRESS, LEFKOE.
I THINK WHEN THE BULLETS ARE
FLYING A LITTLE BIT AND THINGS
ARE GOING REALLY FAST IT'S GOING
TO TAKE SOME TIME FOR MATT
CORRAL.
I'M FASCINATED BY THIS DRAFT
PICK, BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD THE
LAST 24 HOURS THEY WERE
CONSIDERING MAKING A TRADE FOR
BAKER MAYFIELD.
DOES THAT TAKE THIS OFF THE
TABLE?
>> INTERESTING.
>> VERY INTERESTING.
MATT CORRAL, SAM DARNOLD.
YOU HAVE DARNOLD WHO CAN PLAY.
MATT CORRAL WAS MY 49th OVERALL.
I LIKE THE VALUE FOR DOOR LIE IN
A.
GOT THE BEST PLAYER IN THE DRAFT
IN ICKEY EKWONU.
HE'S GOT A LOT OF ATHLETICISM.
BUT BEING A PRO QUARTERBACK,
HE'S FAR FROM THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT MATT
CORRAL?
>> PICK NUMBER 94.
>> YES.
>> "A" PLUS.
>> WHOA.
>> AT 94, "A" PLUS.
>> WHERE WOULD IT HAVE BEEN AT
PICK 49 #?
>> "B" PLUS.
>> WHY "A" PLUS.
>> HE DOESN'T HAVE TO PLAY THIS
UPCOMING YEAR.
HE CAN PLAY.
I LOVE WHAT HE BRINGS TO THE
TABLE.
THIS IS A GUY THAT HAS TRUE
FAITH IN HIS ARM.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
QUARTERBACK THAT HAS A
COMPLETELY ERODED SENSE OF
CONFIDENCE, THAT'S SAM DARNOLD.
>> AND THIS IS THE OPPOSITE.
>> THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE.
HE BELIEVES --
>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE SAM
DARNOLD AND MATT CORRAL, BEING
WHAT UP, BRUH.
>> WELL PUT.
>> I LIKE IT.
>> HE BELIEVED -- THIS GUY, HE
HAS A BRETT FAVRIAN BELIEF IN
HIS ARM.
IT'S WORKED FOR HIM PRETTY WELL.
WATCHING HIM, WHEN HE WAS
COMMITTED TO USC, I DON'T CARE
THAT THE SAFETY IS OVER THE TOP
AND I'M STARING DOWN MY
RECEIVER, I CAN PUNCH IT IN
THERE BECAUSE I'M SPECIAL.
HE HAS THAT ABOUT HIM.
WATCHING HIM PLAY HAS BEEN
REALLY FUN, GROWING TO GO FROM
THE GOLDEN BOY THAT WAS SUPPOSED
TO GO TO USC FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
TO OLE MISS, TO GET TO OLE MISS
AND REALLY KICK -- THEY WERE ONE
OF THE MOST FUN TEAMS TO WATCH
IF YOU LIKE OFFENSE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY BROUGHT TO THE
TABLE.
FOR ME, I LOOK AT HIM, THIS IS
AN "A" PLUS IF YOU GET HIM AT
94.
FOR THE PANTHERS, DON'T KNOW
THAT YOU HIT YOUR WAGON TO HIM
FULLY, BUT I KNOW YOU GIVE HIM A
CHANCE TO COMPETE RIGHT NOW AND
THEN GO FROM THERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
FUN.
JUST GOING TO BE -- THEY'RE
GOING TO -- LISTEN, A LOT OF
FOLKS DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS.
SMALL MARKET, BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE THE CARDIAC CATS AGAIN.
TELLING YOU, BABY.
>> TWO BIG STORY LINES COME WITH
THIS DRAFT PICK.
THESE ARE THE DRAFT THREE CAP,
CAN HE PICK IT, THE ONLY ONE TO
GO IN THE FIRST ROUND, AND THEN
WE HAD THREE QUARTERBACKS GO IN
THE THIRD ROUND.
DESMOND RIDDER, MALIK WILLIS,
AND MATT CORRAL.
AND LET ME GET TO THIS POINT.
MATT CORRAL'S DRAFT PICK DOES
TWO THINGS FOR HE MAINE.
NUMBER ONE, IT RAISE IT IS
QUESTION, SO WHERE IS BAKER
GOING TO GO?
IT LESSENS THE AMOUNT OF TEAMS
THAT HE CAN GET TRADED TO.
AND NOW SUDDENLY YOU'RE GOING,
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO KEEP HIM IN
THE SAME LOCKER ROOM AS DESHAUN
WATSON, ARE YOU?
THE SECOND THING IS, WHAT DOES
THIS DO TO MATT RHULE'S TIMELINE
S.A.T. COACH FOR THE CAROLINA
PANTHERS.
HE'S GOING IT'S A THIRD ROUND
QUARTERBACK, THAT'S NOT MY GUY.
YOU'RE HITCHED.
HOW YOU DEVELOP MATT CORRAL WILL
BE DEFINITIVE TO THE AMOUNT OF
DURATION YOU HAVE WITH THE
CAROLINA PANTHERS.
>> THIRD ROUNDER DOESN'T MATTER
THAT MUCH.
YOU'RE RIGHT, HERE'S MY
QUESTION.
OR MY FEAR, NOT TO BE THE GLASS
HALF EMPTY GUY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> SAM DARNOLD GOES FULL SAM
DARNOLD AGAIN THIS YEAR AND YOU
HAVE PEOPLE IN THE STANDS
CHEERING FOR MATT CORRAL TO COME
IN, BECAUSE THEY NEED A SPARK.
HE CAN CAN GIVE YOU A SPARK, I
DON'T KNOW THAT'S THE BEST FOR
MATT CORRAL'S DEVELOPMENT.
IF THAT TEAM ERODES IS THAT THE
END OF THE MATT RHULE ERA?
>> WIDE RECEIVER ROOM IS
EXCITING.
IF CHRISTIAN McCAFFREY IS
HEALTHY.
IT'S GOING TO BE UN.
IF YOU'VE GOT A FRANCHISE TACKLE
NOW.
AND THAT DEFENSE IS YOUNG, AND
IF THEY'RE HEALTHY, COULD MAKE A
RUN.
BUT IFS IT IS INTERESTING THAT
MATT CORRAL IS THE ULTIMATE,
GIVE HIM TIME TO DEVELOP, GUY,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
THROW HIM OUT THERE AND HE HAS
SUCCESS.
HE'S SO MUCH FUN, THAT IT'S
HARD.
>> BINGO.
>> THAT'S WHAT'S SO FASCINATING
ABOUT THIS IS, IN PRE-SEASON --
>> YEAH, YOU NAILED IT.
>> THE BACKUP ALWAYS GETS MORE
TIME THAN THE STARTER.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> IF HE STARTS GOING HA, HA,
HA -- AND THEN DAVID TEPPER IS
GOING TO BE THERE, AND HE'S
GOING TO BE SITTING THERE, LET'S
PLAY CORRAL.
ZACH CARTER, TO THE BENGALS.
AT PICK NUMBER 95 AS -- YOU KNOW
WHAT, NOW THAT WE'VE GOT THE
QUARTERBACKS OFF THE BOARD,
IT'S -- A LITTLE BIT MORE CALM
HERE BUT DEFENSIVE LINEMAN OUT
OF FLORIDA, 6'4", 282, DO WE
LIKE THE VALUE HERE?
>> I LIKE THE VALUE HERE.
HE'S MY 99th OVERALL PLAYER.
FOR ZACHARY CARTER, STEADY EDDY.
SETS A HARD EDGE.
GIVES YOU EFFORT AS A PASS
RUSHER, TOUGH IN THE TRENCHES,
SEE HIM TAKE ON BLOCKS, WORK OFF
THE BLOCKS, STACK AND SHED, MAKE
PLAYS AGAINST THE RUN.
HIGH EFFORT AGAINST THE PASS.
OBVIOUSLY HITS LIKE A MADMAN.
I LOVE THE FIRE HE PLAYS WITH, A
TRUE FIVE TECH KIND OF PLAYER.
AT THAT SIZE.
AND YOU CAN KICK HIM IN ON
PASSING DOWNS.
>> THAT WAS MY QUESTION.
>> HE'S A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
RUN DEFENDER AS WELL.
SO I LIKE ZACH CARTER HERE FOR A
FRONT THAT NEEDED DEPTH.
HE'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO ROTATE
IN RIGHT AWAY.
THE VALUE IS RIGHT ON.
THIS IS A "B" FOR ME FOR THE
BENGALS.
>> YEAH, LISTEN, HE'S WHAT HE
IS, AND I'M GLAD YOU -- STEADY
EDDY.
I LOVE IT.
THIS IS A GUY WHO'S GOING TO
SHOW UP TO WORK EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET YOU A TON
OF SACKS.
>> NO.
>> DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> BUT YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S ALSO
NOT GOING TO DO.
NOT GIVING UP FIVE YARDS PER
RUN.
HE'S GOING TO BE SITTING THERE
TACKLING.
SET THE HARD EDGE.
LINEBACKERS WILL HAVE TO DO
THEIR JOB NOW.
NICE CLUB TO GET TO THE
INTERIOR.
LOVE TO SEE THAT.
HE'S GOT A MOVE.
THERE ARE SOME MOVES IN HIS
REPERTOIRE.
HE'S AT HIS BEST LINED UP RIGHT
THERE OVER TOP OF THAT TACKLE SO
HE CAN SET THE HARD EDGE.
BUT WHEN YOU GET HIM LIKE THIS.
LOOK AT THE STRENGTH.
>> THAT'S NICE.
>> YOU SEE THAT?
>> WRITING IN HIS BOOK.
>> WAS IT NICE?
>> LONG ARM, WALKED THE GUY BACK
INTO THE CORE BACK, IT WAS
BEAUTIFUL.
THIS GUY IS A PURE POWER PLAYER.
HIS PASS RUSH MOVES WHERE WE WE
THINK ABOUT SWIM OR SWING.
THE LONG ARM THAT WALKED BACK BE
THAT GUY INTO THE QUARTERBACK.
THE SWIPE.
HE CAN -- IF HE HITS YOU ON YOUR
OUTSIDE SHOULDER, YOU'RE FALLING
BACK INTO THE INSIDE, AND HE'S
WALKING.
I'VE GOT TO GET MY GRADE.
"B" PLUS.
>> TREY HENDRICKSON IS A GUY
THAT'S LIKE THAT, DJ READER IS A
GUY LIKE THAT.
THAT'S A MONSTER D LINE, WHEN
YOU'RE UP AGAINST THE STEELERS
AND RAVENS, MAKES SENSE.
COLTS ARE UP, THEY'RE TAKING
SAFETY NICK CROSS OUT OF
MARYLAND.
6'0", 212.
FLUID MOVER.
EXCELLENT BLISSER.
DOWNSIDE.
AVERAGE EYES.
WHAT DO WE THINK OF NICK CROSS
GOING TO THE COLTS.
>> INSANE ATHLETE.
I COMPARE HIM TO RON LANDRY.
HE CAN ABSOLUTELY FLY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HIM ON TAPE.
EVERYTHING'S STILL COMING
TOGETHER IN TERMS OF FIGURING IT
OUT AT THE POSITION.
BUT HE'S GOT SUCH GREAT BURSTS
AND SPEED THAT IT MAKES UP FOR
THE LACK OF INSTINCTS AT TIMES,
HE CAN COME DOWNHILL, FLY, MAKE
BIG-TIME TACKLES.
I LIKE HIS UPSIDE AND COVERAGE.
IF YOU WANT TO KWLOOUZ USE HIM
AS A TWO HIGH KIND OF SAFETY,
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IT HERE.
TRACKED THE BALL.
HUNG IN THE AIR.
GET THE BALL SIDELINE TO
SIDELINE RANGE.
NICK CROSS, THIS IS A SWING FOR
THE FENCES THIRD-ROUND PICK.
A LOT OF SAFETIES GO OFF THE
BOARD THERE.
GOOD BOX SAFETIES.
SURE FIRE TACKLER.
NICK CROSS, IT'S A HAIL MARY
KIND OF PICK OF K CAN YOU MAKE
BIG TIME PLAYS ON THE FOOTBALL.
FOR THAT IT'S A "B" PLUS FOR ME,
THIS IS THE TIME OF THE DRAFT
THAT YOU DO THAT.
AND I'M ACTUALLY A LITTLE
SURPRISED HE'S HERE.
I HEARD RUMBLINGS HE CAN GO
SECOND ROUND.
>> STEPHON GILMORE WILL BE THE
CORNER THERE.
THIS IS A GUS BRADLEY SYSTEM.
SO IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF THE
RICHARD SHERMAN COVER THREE
PRESS BAIL.
>> YEAH.
>> AND IF YOU'VE GOT A RANGY
SAFETY, WHICH IS WHAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE HE IS, IT COULD BE
EXCITING.
>> I LOVE THIS DUDE.
HE'S A PLAYER.
>> YEAH?
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE IT AN "A."
NICK CROSS CAN MOVE.
HE'S ABLE TO MOVE SIDELINE TO
SIDELINE.
I LOVE WHEN THEY PUT HIM ON A
STRING.
UP AND DOWN, UP AND DOWN.
THE WAY THEY TRAIN WITH MOTION,
THIS IS A GUY THAT IN THE FIRST
ZBLSH .43.
>> AT 212 POUNDS.
>> WOW.
>> 212, .43.
COME GET DOWNHILL, MAKE A
TACKLE.
I LOVE THAT.
WHEN YOU PUT HIM ON THE
STRAIGHT.
YOU GO, I GO.
HE MAKES TACKLESS BEHIND THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
HE CAN MAKE BAD STEPS.
I'VE SEEN HIM TAKE BAD STEPS AND
THEN STILL REDIRECT AND MAKE A
PBU.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO DO?
FIX THE EYES.
YOU HAVE TO FIX THE EYES.
IF YOU FIX THOSE EYES AND YOU
COMBINE EYES THAT ARE GOOD WITH
43 SPEED.
NOW YOU'VE GOT A SUPERMAN BACK
THERE TO SAVE EVERYTHING.
>> WHEN I THINK OF A 4.3 SPEED
SAFETY FOR THE COLTS, I THINK
WHAT MALIK HOOKER COULD HAVE
BEEN WITH HIS INJURIES AND ALL
THAT STUFF.
WE'LL SEE, NOW'S A GREAT TIME TO
TAKE A CHANCE ON AN ATHLETE LIKE
THIS.
IF IT HITS, YOU LOOK LIKE A
GENIUS.
>> THIS IS THE TIME TO DO IT.
I'M A BIG FAN.
>> WE'RE IN THE COMPENSATORY
PICKS OF THE THIRD ROUND.
NEXT UMM, THE DETROIT LIONS.
WE HAVE THE PICK.
KIRBY JOSEPH.
TO THE LIONS, OUR GUY JORDAN
SCHULTZ BRAEJS, A DUBL FIST PUMP
FROM OUR MICHAEL FELDER, ANOTHER
SAFETY.
BACK TO BACK SAFETY.
38 1/2 -- ILLINOIS, THE VALUE.
>> COVERAGE SAFETY.
125 ON THE BOARD.
VALUE CHECKS OUT FOR HIM.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT.
HE'S MADE A LOT OF PLAYS IN
COVERAGE.
THE TACKLING WAS JUST OKAY.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU'RE USING
HIM FOR, FOR HIS RANGE AND OVER
THE TOP, THE ABILITY TO GO UP
AND WIN THE FOOTBALL.
I LIKE KIRBY JOSEPH FOR A VERY
DEFINED ROLE.
USE HIM AS A THIRD SAFETY AND
ALLOW ONE OF OUR NORMAL
SAFETIES.
ECAN HANDLE EVERYTHING OVER THE
TOP.
HE'S GOT REALLY GOOD RANGE.
IF YOU NEEDED A SAFETY, THEY'RE
GOING HOT AND HEAVY RIGHT NOW.
>> REAL, REAL FAST.
ESPECIALLY A COVERAGE ONE LIKE
KIRBY JOSEPH.
THIS IS A "B" PLUS PICK.
>> JUST A LITTLE BIT OF HOW THIS
DEFERS FITS BEFORE YOU GO, TRACY
WALKER IS THE LEADER OF THIS
DEFENSE ON THE BACK END.
AND THEY HAVE WILL HARRIS.
WILL HARRIS, LAES YEAR, HAD TO
PLAY SLOT CORNER, AND SAFETY.
BUT THEY REALLY WANT HIM AT SLOT
CORNER.
THE HOPE HERE LIKELY IS YOU
THROW KIRBY IN THE BACK AND YOUR
WHOLE SECONDARY IS FILLED OUT
AND YOU GET TWO POSITIONS FOR
THE PICK.
>> WALKER CAN PLAY CLOSER TO THE
LINE OF SCRIMMAGE.
THE RIGHT MOLD.
>> HE'S GREAT SINGLE HIGH.
I'M GIVING IT AN AMINUS.
I THINK HE'S BETTER AS A PLAYER,
BETTER INSTINCTS.
HERE'S THE REALITY WHEN IT COMES
TO KIRBY JOSEPH.
THE BEST PLAY HE HAD WAS AGAINST
IOWA.
IT'S AGAINST IOWA AND THEY MADE
A MOTION, AND YOU'RE GOING TO
GET A RUN ACTION, YOU'RE GOING
TO GET -- RUNNING BACK GIVE, THE
RUNNING BACK PITCHES IT.
IT'S A PHILLY SPECIAL,
ESSENTIALLY.
AND EVERY -- IT'S WASHED OUT.
COMPLETELY.
EVERYONE BITES ON IT.
AND KIRBY JOSEPH SAYS NO, SIR,
NOT ME.
I GOT THE SPEED TO GET ON MY
HORSE.
I'M TRACKING THIS ONE DOWN.
BREAKS UP THE PASS.
A GREAT TOUCHDOWN SAVING PLAY.
BUT THAT'S THE EPITOME OF WHAT
HE CAN DO.
HE'S GREAT AT GETTING OUT OF THE
MILD OF THE FIELD TO GET TO THE
SIDELINE.
>> RICHARD SHERMAN, AARON GLEN'S
DEFENSE.
HOW DOES KIRBY JOSEPH FIT INTO
IT.
>> I THINK HE'S RANGY.
I THINK HE'S INSTINCTIVE.
HE NEEDS MORE REPS.
I THINK HE JUST NEEDS MORE REPS.
IT'S HIS FIRST YEAR AS A
FULL-TIME STARTER.
AT TIMES IT LOOKED LIKE IT.
LIKE HE WAS A BIT RUSTY OUT
THERE.
A BIT INDECISIVE.
HE MAKES BIG PLAYS, HIGH POINTS
THE FOOTBALL.
ANYTIME YOU GET YOUR HANDS ON A
FOOTBALL.
FIVE INTERCEPTIONS, YOU CAN
APPRECIATE THAT.
COMES DOWNHILL.
MAKES THE BIG TACKLES.
PLAYS THE POSITION LIKE YOU WANT
IT TO BE PLAYED.
HE NEEDS MORE REPS.
IN DWROIT THEY DON'T HAVE A TON
OF DEPTH IN THEIR SECONDARY.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME RIGHT IN,
GET A LOT OF REPS, LEARN ON THE
FLY.
AND HE'LL BE A GOOD PLAYER FOR
THEM.
HE NEEDS MORE TIME, YOU KNOW,
ONE YEAR AS A START, FULL-TIME
STARTER, USUALLY ISN'T ENOUGH.
AND SO I EXPECT HIM TO GET MORE
TIME AND MORE REPS AND BE A GOOD
PLAYER.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE ARE NOW ON TO
THE WASHINGTON COMMANDERS, THEY
HAD JAHAN DOTSON.
WASHINGTON NOW WITH THEIR THIRD
PICK, PICK 98 IN THIS DRAFT.
WHAT ARE WE THINKING HERE?
>> MAN, BUT SEA THEM GO D LINE
ALREADY, RIGHT, STACK UP THE D
LINE, AND THERE IT IS, I LOVE
THIS PICK.
>> DO YOU REALLY?
>> BIG BRUISER.
GREAT -- WE'LL GET INTO IT.
BRIAN ROBINSON.
>> A BIG BRUISER, A TRAIN
ROLLING DOWN THE TRACKS AND YOU
DON'T WANT TO BE IN HIS TRACK.
ENOUGH WIGGLE.
>> 245.
>> ALABAMA LIKES THEIR RUNNING
BACKS.
HE WAS PATIENT AND WAITED A LONG
TIME TO PLAY.
SOFT HANDS.
GET UP FIELD.
THE BIG FRAME TO ROIN THROUGH --
SO RELIABLE IN PASS PROTECTION.
NO ROLE THIS GUY COULD NOT
HANDLE.
THE FACT HE'S GOT THAT KIND OF
MOVEMENT WITH HIS FEET AT 225
POUNDS, 6'2", HE WEARS DOWN
DEFENSES, THAT'S WHAT IT IS WITH
HIM.
FOR WASHINGTON, YOU GET --
ANTONIO GIBSON, OBVIOUSLY.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THERE?
HE WAS A LITTLE BIT BANGED UP
LAST YEAR.
>> ONCE AGAIN, YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR GUYS THAT CAN CLOSE OUT
FOOTBALL GAMES, WEAR DOWN
DEFENSES, THAT'S WHAT BRIAN
ROBINSON DOES, HE'S MY 83rd
OVERALL PLAYER, A GUY NOBODY
WANTS TO TACKLE, WEARS YOU OUT,
THIS IS AN AWESOME PICK FOR
WASHINGTON, AND THIS IS A THREE
DOWN RUNNER, TRULY IS.
DON'T GET MIXED UP BY THE SIZE.
HE'S GOT ENOUGH BURST.
>> HE'S GOOD, HE'S REALLY GOOD
AND DID WAIT A LONG TIME.
LISTEN, TO TALK ABOUT HOW LONG
HE WAITED, I'M GOING TO READ
NUMBERS FOR YOU, LEFKOE, 2017,
24 -- EXCUSE ME, 2017, 24
CARRIES, IT'S AN "A" PICK FOR
ME.
2018, WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A GUY
WITH 63 CARRIES, # 2019, 96
CARRIES, 2020, 91 CARRIES, AND
2021 WHEN HE FINALLY GOT THE
ROCK, 271 CARRIES.
THIS IS A GUY, HE DOESN'T HAVE
AS MANY CARRIES AS --
>> HE'S PATIENT.
HE DID HIS JOB.
HE DID EVERYTHING THAT NICK
SABAN ASKED HIM TO DO.
WAITING PATIENTLY BEHIND THE
OTHER RUNNING BACKS.
NAJEE, THE KID THAT WENT TO THE
RAIDERS.
DAMIAN HARRIS, ALL THESE GUYS TO
WAIT BEHIND TO GET HIS TURN.
WHEN HE GOT HIS TURN, HE CAN
CATCH THE BALL IN THE BACKFIELD.
I MacLOT IN PASS PROTECTION.
HE'S REMARKABLE.
DURING THE PHASE WHEN ALABAMA
TRANSITIONED INTO BECOMING
PASSING OFFENSE.
VERY GOOD IN PASS PROTECTION AND
CATCHING THE BALL IN THE
BACKFIELD AND DOING THE
TRADITIONAL THINGS YOU EXPECT
ALABAMA TO DO, STRONG, WILLING
TO FIGHT.
HE ALWAYS FALLS FORWARD.
GREAT PICKUP FOR THEM.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SHOULD COME
IN, AND BE A STARTER, IF HE HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY, YOU GIVE HIM AN
INCH, HE'LL TAKE A MILE FROM
YOU.
>> NICE.
891 YARDS AFTER CONTACT, FIFTH
IN POWER FIVE.
THE CLEVELAND BROWNS ARE UP.
MARTIN EMERSON, THE CORNER BACK,
THE FIRST PICK, THEY WENT ALEX
WRIGHT.
THE EDGE PLAYER AND NOW AT PICK
NUMBER 99, THE CLEVELAND BROWNS.
>> NO WIDE RECEIVER.
>> SELECTING.
>> THERE IT IS.
>> DAVID BELL, PURDUE, THE WIDE
RECEIVER AT 99.
DAVID BELL COMES IN, FIRST TEAM
ALL AMERICAN, TWO-TIME FIRST
TEAM, ALL BIG TEN, SET THE
PURDUE RECORD WITH 17 100 YARD
RECEIVING GAMES IN JUST 29 #
GAMES.
AVERAGED OVER 100 YARDS
RECEIVING EVERY GAME, ONLY
DROPPED THE BALL 4.7% OF THE
TIME.
AND THE COACHES SAY HE PLAYED
THROUGH A LOT OF MINOR INJURIES,
YOU LIKE THIS GUY?
>> I DO LIKE HIM.
HE HAD A TOUGH PROCESS.
THE FILM IS SO GOOD.
SUPER PRODUCTIVE ALL THREE
SEASONS, FRESHMAN, SOPHOMORE,
JUNIOR YEARS, NOT THE BEST SPRIT
SEPARATOR.
HE'LL GET YOU FROM POINT "A" TO
"B."
NO FLASH HERE.
THE 4.65 FORTY.
IT REMINDS ME OF JA CO BUY
MYERS.
EVERYBODY LOOKS AT THE
MEASURABLES, THE TESTING, YOU
SIT THERE AND GO WIDE RECEIVERS
ARE MORE DYNAMIC THAN THIS.
>> ALSO THE GUY THEY JUST LOST.
JARVIS LANDRY.
>> PUT ON THE TAPE, POSSESSION
RECEIVER, REALLY SOLID ONE.
FOR ME, THIS IS A "B" FOR DAVID
BELL.
HE'S ONE OF THE BETTER WIDE
RECEIVERS ON THE BOARD.
SURE, HE'S NOT EXPLOSIVE.
HE'LL BE THAT CHECK DOWN KIND OF
PIECE FOR DE'SHAWN.
>> A NICE PIECE FOR DE'SHAWN.
>> HE IS INCREDIBLY GOOD AT
MAKING CONTESTED CATCHES.
THAT PART REMINDS ME OF D.J.
MOORE COMING OUT OF MARYLAND.
HE WAS A GUY NOT SEPARATED
FULLY.
I'LL GIVE IT AN "A" MINUS.
HE'S WILLING TO MAKE CONTESTED
CATCHES.
FIGHT THROUGH CONTACT TO PLAY
THROUGH THE FOOTBALL AND HE DOES
SOMETHING THAT I LOVE, LEFKOE.
HE DOESN'T LOOK AT THE REFS AND
ASK FOR HELP.
HE'S A GUY THAT PUTS IT ON --
THE ONUS IS ON HIM TO MAKE THE
CATCH.
HE'S NOT ASKING FOR HELP, AND I
LOVE THE FACT HE'S WILLING TO
PLAY THROUGH CONTACT.
>> I LOVE THE MAKEUP OF THESE
WIDE RECEIVING CORE.
AMARI COOPER.
CAN -- DONOVAN JONES, YOUR
BIG -- AND THEN DAVID BELL IS
YOUR I CAN TRUST HIM WITH A BIG
CATCH ON THE THIRD DOWN BECAUSE
HE'S NOT GOING TO DROP IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF -- DAVID
BELL AND ALL THE ANALYSIS YOU'RE
HEARING FROM US.
>> YOU KNOW, I LOVE THIS PICK.
I WATCHED HIM A LOT OF PURDUE.
I THINK WHAT STANDS OUT MOST
ABOUT HIS GAME IS HIS HANDS.
I THINK HE HAS ONE OF THE BEST
HANDS IN THIS CLASS AND IT'S
BODY CONTROL.
I FORGET WHAT GAME IT IS.
RIDICULOUS DEEP BALL.
I LOVE HIS HANDS AND BODY
CONTROL.
AFTER THE CATCH I THINK HE'S
REALLY GOOD TOO.
NOT THE FASTEST, AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT HURT HIM IN THIS
DRAFT BUT I THINK HE WILL BE AN
AWESOME PRO.
HE'S GOING TO FIND HIS NICHE IN
THIS LEAGUE.
BUT I THINK HIS HANDS AND HIS
BODY CONTROL IS WHAT STANDS OUT
MOST WHEN I WATCH HIM PLAY.
>> AND THERE'S A CHANCE JARVIS
LANDRY CAN COME BACK TO THIS
TEAM BUT THIS 4.6 SPEED IS NOT
EVERYTHING.
AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT, HOW DO
YOU PLAY WITH PADS?
NEXT PICK IS IN.
ARIZONA WENT EDGE AND THEN EDGE
AGAIN.
MY AI SANDERS, 13 PASSES
DEFENDED OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS.
KNOWS HOW TO GET IS HANDS UP.
NOT ONLY THAT, 13.5 SACKS, AND
ANOTHER CINCINNATI GUY OFF THE
BOARD FOR ARIZONA CARDINALS.
>> ONE OF MY BEST PLAYERS
AVAILABLE RIGHT HERE, THIS MIGHT
BE LOFTY PRAISE BUT A LOT OF
RANDY GREGORY ON FILM.
A TALL, SLENDER GUY THAT KNOWS
HOW TO WIN WITH GETTING OFF THE
SNAP.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
WITH MYJAI SANDERS, HE GETS OFF
THE FOOTBALL AND PUTS HIMSELF IN
ADVANTAGEOUS POSITIONS AGAINST
THE TACKLE.
THEY'RE A STEP BEHIND HIM.
THAT'S WHAT'S SPECIAL ABOUT HIM.
THE SACK PRODUCTION IS NOT
INSANE.
HE FOUND WAYS TO DISRUPT PLAYS.
I LOVE THE OUTSIDE SPEED RUSH.
ARIZONA NEEDED PASS RUSH HELP.
>> CAM THOMAS, AND MYJAI
SANDERS.
>> SANDERS IS BETTER THAN
THOMAS.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR ME.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A
SERIOUS CONTRIBUTOR.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE QUICK.
>> I LOVE HIM.
THIS GUY CAN PLAY.
HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S AN "A" PLUS FOR ME.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT HIS SACK
PRODUCTION.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY
ASKED HIM TO DO IN CINCINNATI.
>> NO.
>> THIS IS A SCHEME THAT ASKED
HIM TO GO UPFIELD, BE DISRUPTIVE
AND WE'RE GOING TO LET BEAVERS,
LET DUBLONCO, THEY'LL CLEAN UP
THE MESS.
BE DISRUPTIVE.
MAKE THE QUARTERBACK STEP INTO
THE POCKET.
MAKE THE GUY GET OFF HIS MARK.
MAKE THE QUARTERBACK GET OUT OF
HIS RHYTHM.
OUR CORNERS ARE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OF EVERYTHING AND THEN THE
LINE BACKERS ARE GOING TO CLEAN
IT UP FOR YOU.
ARE WE TALKING CINCINNATI WITH
KELSEY?
>> WE'RE NOT.
>> I WAS GOING TO KEEP IT SHORT:
NOW I CAN GO LONGER.
>> YES, YOU CAN.
>> IN THE NFL HE'S GOT AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE A VERY SPECIAL
GUY BECAUSE NOW HE GETS TO RUSH
UNDER PARTICULAR CONTROL.
>> YES.
>> NOW HE GETS TO BEND THE EDGE
AND NOT GET ON TOP OF THE
QUARTERBACK.
NOW HE CAN TAKE A MORE DIRECT
ROUTE TO THE QUARTERBACK INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO PLAY WITH HIS HAIR
ON FIRE AND PUSH THE GUY OFF THE
POINT SO THAT HELPS THE REST OF
THE TEAM.
NOW AT THIS LEVEL, WITH THIS
APPROACH THAT THEY'LL BRING TO
THE TABLE.
THEY DO WANT HIM TO GET SACKS.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A DIFFERENCE
IN THE SYSTEM THE PLAYED IN
COLLEGE COMPARED TO NOW.
>> I LIKE THAT THEY'RE DOUBLE
DEALERSHIPING TO STRIE AND
REPLACE CHANDLER JONES TO SEE IF
THEY CAN FIND SOMETHING.
>> THE FALCONS DID A NICE JOB
CAPITALIZING ON THE STRONGEST
EDGE RUSH CLASSES I'VE EVER
SEEN.
>> AND JUST GETTING PIECES.
>> THE NEW YORK JETS, GOT A
GREAT CORNER AND WIDE RECEIVER,
GREAT PASS RUSHER AND A GREAT
RUNNING BACK.
GOTTEN ARGUABLY ONE OF THE TOP
GUYS AT EVERY SINGLE POSITION.
ONLY THING I HAVEN'T SEEN IS AN
OFFENSIVE LINEMAN.
IS THERE A PLAYER OR PICK YOU'RE
HOPING FOR HERE OR DO YOU IN
FACT KNOW WHO THEY'RE TAKING.
>> THEY TOOK THE BEST PLAYER
AVAILABLE ON MY BOARD,
IRONICALLY.
IF YOU WANTED TO GO OFFENSIVE
LINE ROUTE.
DANIEL FAALELE WOULD HAVE BEEN.
>> RIGHT INTO IT.
>> JEREMY RUCKERT.
EXCELLENT BLOCKING TIGHT END.
UNDER UTILIZED.
>> OUTSIDE CJUZAMA.
THIS GIVES YOU -- TWO TIGHT
ENDS.
RUCKERT.
SO GOOD BLOCKING ON THE MOVE AND
OHIO STATE.
THEY DIDN'T NEED TO THROUGH HIM
THE BALL A LOT.
HE COULD BE A POSSESSION GUY.
BIG CATCH RADIUS IN THE RED
ZONE, THAT'S BIG FOR ZACH
WILSON.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A GUY THAT
COULD DO THAT LAST YEAR.
>> ISN'T HE FROM NEW YORK?
>> FROM LONG ISLAND.
I'M SURE THE RUCKERT FAMILY,
COOL MOMENT.
>> THEY ARE LOSING THEIR MINDS.
>> HIS DAD IS A HUGE JETS FANS.
THIS IS A REALLY COOL MOMENT.
I WOULD IMAGINE HE WANTED TO
COME HOME.
THIS IS AN AWESOME.
53rd OVERALL PLAYER, THIS IS AN
"A."
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE MORE
PRODUCTIVE AS A RECEIVER.
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, NEVER HAD
MORE THAN 57 YARDS IN A GAME BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT WAS HIS
FAULT.
>> NO.
>> WHEN YOU HAVE GARRETT WILSON
AND CHRIS OLAVE.
>> ON AND ON.
>> AND COME ON, AND YOU HAVE THE
RUNNING BACKS, TO GET THE BALL
TO AS WELL.
YOU LOSE PRODUCTION.
FOR ME WITH HIM, WATCHING THE
WAY HE'S ABLE TO USE THAT
ATHLETICISM.
HE'S STRONG TOO.
THAT'S THE OTHER PART.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S ATHLETIC, HE'S
NOT GREG DULCICH.
HE'S A FULL BODY TIGHT END.
THAT'S HARD TO TACKLE FOR
SAFETIES.
TURN A 5 YARD CATCH INTO A FIRST
DOWN.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU WANT YOUR
TIGHT END TO BE ABLE TO DO.
WING, COME BACK ACROSS, THE
FORMATION, OPTION, TURN INTO A
BLOCKER, HELP YOUR QUARTERBACK
GET A FIRST DOWN.
RUCKERT, WHEN I LOOK AT HIM,
THIS IS AN "A" PLUS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT HE MIGHT
BE A FIRST-ROUND PICK.
>> REALLY?
>> AS A TIGHT END.
HE WAS BEING PROJECTED OVER TRAY
McBRIDE, FOR SOME PEOPLE,
BECAUSE HE HAD BIG GAME
POTENTIAL AND HE HAD THE BODY OF
AN ACTUAL TIGHT END.
>> HE'S GOT A BIGGER BODY.
THICK FRAME.
YOU COULD SEE HIM, I MEAN, YOU
SEE IT ALL THE TIME.
THE BIGGEST THING WITH JEREMY
RUCKERT THAT I WALKED AWAY AND
SAID, WOW, HOW HOE HANDLED
GEORGE KARLAFTIS.
>> HE'S HELPING OUT.
IF YOU GUYS, THINK HE COULD HAVE
BEEN THE TOP TIGHT END IN HIS
CLASS, YOU COULD MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT THEY GOT THE
NUMBER ONE PLAYER AT ALL OF
THOSE POSITIONS.
>> YEAH.
>> RUNNING BACK, TIGHT END, WIDE
RECEIVER, PASS RUSHER AND
QUARTERBACK.
THAT'S DARN GOOD FOR JOE
DOUGLAS.
>> OHIO STATE PLAYING AT
RUTGERS.
HELPED OUT OUR BOY.
>> YEAH, CONNOR GOT EVERYTHING.
CONNOR GOT TO SCOUT EVERYBODY.
WE ARE NOW AT THE FIRST PICK OF
THE DRAFT FOR THE MIAMI
DOLPHINS.
WHY?
BUZZ THEY GAVE UP FIVE DRAFT
PICKS FOR TYREEK HILL.
BIG OFFSEASON.
TRADE FOR TYREEK HILLS.
SIGNED CEDRICK WILSON, THEY
COULD GO A LOT OF PLACES.
IT'S THEIR FIRST PICK.
I FEEL LIKE YOU KNOW WHO IT IS.
>> I DON'T.
I WOULD THINK OFFENSIVE LINE.
I'VE HEARD THEM LOOKING AT THE
OFFENSIVE LINE CLASS.
I LOOK AT ZACH TOM FROM WAKE
FOREST.
HE'S GOING TO MOVE INSIDE TO
CENTER AT THE NEXT LEVEL.
THAT WOULD BE THE BEST ATHLETE
OF THE OFFENSIVE LINEMEN LEFT ON
THE BOARD.
I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHERE THEY
GO.
>> THEY'RE NOT HAPPY WITH --
>> DEEDER IS IN A CONTRACT, HE'S
A FREE AGENT AFTER THIS YEAR.
>> THAT OFFENSIVE LINE IS GOING
TO GET A HOME MAKEOVER.
THEY'VE GOT ARMSTEAD, THEY DON'T
HAVE THE CAPITAL TO DO IT.
THEY HAD TO WAIT UNTIL OUTSIDE
THE TOP 100.
WE'LL SEE WHERE THE SELECTION
GOES.
>> WHAT IF IT'S BOSTON COLLEGE'S
ALEX LINDSTROM, WHO PLAYED FOR
THE O LINE COACH MICHAEL
APPLEBALM IN COLLEGE.
>> IT'S CHANNING TYNDALL.
>> THAT'S A GOOD PICK.
>> THEY NEEDED SOMEBODY DCHLT
THEY GOOD OF OF THE OF
ATHLETICISM.
>> THE NEW LINE BACKER IF
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR JOSH
BOYAR, CHANNING TINDALL.
>> MY PLAYER COMP WAS JEROME
BAKER.
I LOVE THE RUN AND CHASE.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S KEPT CLEAN, A
GEORGIA DEFENSIVE LINE LOADED
WITH TALENT.
HE'S EXCELLENT AT THAT.
GOT EXCELLENT SEE BALL, GET BALL
ABILITY.
THAT WILL HELP WITH COVERAGE.
>> A TON OF SPECIAL TEAMS.
>> HE COULD DO IT ALL.
HE WAITED HIS TURN TO PLAY.
THIS GUY IS RUNNING.
IT'S A GOOD "A" GAP PLITSING
MACHINE.
I LIKE TINDALL'S VALUE.
I DIDN'T THINK THE DOLPHINS
WOULD GET THIS GOOD OF A PLAYER.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR ME IN MIAMI.
THIS IS A QUIET NEED FOR HEM IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DEFENSE.
REALLY, REALLY NICE PICK.
>> I LOVE THE JEROME BAKER COMP,
BECAUSE I SEE IT.
BAKER IS A GUY THAT CAME IN AS A
RUNNING BACK IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
CONVERTED.
IT WAS HIM CHASING DOWN THE
PLAY.
TINDALL CHASING DOWN THE PLAY.
ONE OF THOSE GUYS, NAKOBE DEAN
GOT LINED UP.
PLAYING WITH A VETERAN LIKE
BAKER WILL HELP HIM GET LINED
UP.
I'M GOING WITH AN "A" AS WELL.
WE RAGGED ON THE CLAY WALKER
PICK, TOO EARLY.
THIS IS THE OPPOSITE OF THAT,
WE'RE GETTING A GUY WE THOUGHT
MIGHT GO IN THE SECOND ROUND.
EARLIER IN THE THIRD AND NOW IN
THE COMPENSATORY PICKS.
THIS IS A BIG TODAYTIVE FOR THEM
AND HE'S SOMEONE THAT I THINK AT
MINIMUM FOUR QUARTERS BURKS
PROBABLY GOING TO COME IN AND
COMPETE FOR TIME EARLY.
>> I'M SITTING HERE GOING WOW
THAT GEORGIA DEFENSE WAS PRETTY
DARN GOOD.
>> INSANITY.
>> WE HAVE TWO MORE TODAY?
>> TWO MORE WHAT?
>> TWO MORE GET PICKED TODAY?
>> NAKOBE DEAN, TINDALL, AND
KENDRICK.
>> SEE IF ANOTHER ONE GOES.
CHIEFS TAKE WISCONSIN LINE
BACKER LEO CHENAL.
WHO GOES TO THE KANSAS CITY
CHIEFS.
THE LINE BACKER, FIRST TEAM ALL
AMERICAN, FIRST TEAM ALL BIG
TEN, BIG TEN LINE BACKER OF THE
YEAR, LED THE BIG TEN IN TACKLE
FRS LOSS WITH 18 1/2.
HE'S A WORKOUT WARRIOR THAT
BENCHED 420.
CLEANS 385, AND HE WAS ON PUNT
COVERAGE, AND CONNOR'S LICKING
HIS LIPS.
>> LOOK AT THE PLAYER COMP.
TALLER VERSION OF NICK BOW LAND.
>> WHO WAS ON THE TEAM.
>> ON THE TEAM.
YOU GET A SENSE OF WHAT GMs
LIKE, THE KIND OF PLAYER THEY
LIKE.
I LOVE THE VALUE.
THE 55th OVERALL PLAYER FOR ME.
A GREAT ATHLETE COMING DOWNHILL.
THE TESTING WILL TELL YOU HE'S
ONE OF THE FREAKIEST ATHLETES.
I DIDN'T SEE THE LOOSENESS AND
THE FLEXIBILITY.
>> IN GAME PLAY.
>> RUN WITH THE RUNNING BACK,
RUNNING A WHEEL ROUTE OR THINGS
LIKE THAT, OR RUN DOWN THE SEAM
WITH A TIGHT END.
I SAW DOWNHILL SPEED.
A TOUGH GUY.
HE'LL TAKE ON A CONTACT, CAR
CRASHES, HE MAKES TACKLES, HE IS
MAYBE THE BEST BLITZING LINE
BACKER IN THE DRAFT.
LET ALONE THE BEST PASSING RUSH
D -- THE TEMPO.
I LOVE LEO CHANEL.
THIS IS AN "A" PLUS FOR ME.
WELL DONE BY BRETT VEACH TO GET
VALUE OUTSIDE THE TOP 100.
>> HECK OF A BALLPLAYER.
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
BLITZING, THIS THING ABOUT HIM,
HE HOLDS HIS WATER.
HE'S REALLY GOOD, I'LL GO "A"
PLUS AS WELL.
HE HOLDS HIS WATER.
KEEPS THE DISGUISE UP.
KEEPS IT UP.
UNLESS HE'S DOING THAT, HIM
MUGGED UP.
WHEN HE'S MUGGED UP.
HE CAN SHOOT YOUR "A" GAP.
THAT'S NOT A BLITZ.
THAT'S HIM DECIDING TO MAKE A
DECISION ON THE RUN GAP.
BLITZING, COMING FROM DEPTH.
HOLDS HIS WATER, AND THEN HE
GOES.
GREAT AT GREEN DOGGING, WAITING
UNTIL THE RUNNING BACK DECIDES
THE BLOCK.
HE ADDS OF THE RUN FIT AND GOES
AND GETS THE QUARTERBACK.
ALL BEAUTIFUL THINGS.
I LOVE -- I LOVE WHEN HE'S
MUGGED UP.
QUESTION I HAVE, CHANGE OF
DIRECTION.
>> NOT THERE.
>> WHILE HE TESTED WELL, THE
REALITY IS, WHEN YOU WATCH THE
TAPE.
THE CHANGE OF DIRECTION IS NOT
THERE FOR THE ROADWAY DIRECT TO
THE WHEEL.
FOR HIM TO PLAY A PEEL SCHEME.
I QUESTION THAT CHANGE IN
DIRECTION TO PEEL WITH THAT
RUNNING BACK.
WHICH COULD LEAD TO A FREE FIRST
DOWN, FOR AN OFFENSE, BUT AGAIN,
GIVE IT AN "A" PLUS.
THIS GUY IS A REALLY GOOD
LINEBACKER AND WISCONSIN
CONSISTENTLY PRODUCES REALLY
GOOD LINEBACKERS, HE KNOWS WHAT
HE'S DOING.
HE'S BEING TAUGHT AT WISCONSIN.
BY A PRO, SO YOU KNOW THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
>> YEAH, CHIEFS ENTERED -- LAST
YEAR, THEY WERE BOTTOM FIVE IN
PASS DEFENSE.
THEY WERE BOTTOM TEN IN RUSH
DEFENSE.
THEY WERE BOTTOM FIVE IN SACKS
AND YOU GO, MAN, THERE WAS A LOT
OF PRESSURE ON PAT MAHOMES.
GO OUT AND GET A CORNER, A D
LINEMAN, A SAFETY AND A
LINEBACKER.
SO IMPROVE EVERY SINGLE LAYER OF
THE DEFENSE.
THE SUPER BOWL CHAMPION RAMS
HAVE MADE THEIR SELECTION AND
LOOK AT THE PUSH FROM LOGAN
BRUSQUE.
THEY'RE BIG DUDES, 6'5", 309.
LOGAN BRUSS: WHAT ARE WE
THINKING?
>> TACKLE IN COLLEGE, GUARD AT
THE NEXT LEVEL.
91st OVERALL PLAYER.
HAD A THIRD ROUND GREAT ON HIM.
THE RAMS WAITED A LONG TIME.
THEY DID THEIR HOMEWORK OF THE
VALUE OF THE OFFENSIVE LINE
CLASS.
WE SAW THE VIRAL VIDEO OF --
THEY GET A GOOD PLAYER IN LOGAN
BRUSS.
A GOOD ATHLETE.
THAT FITS WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE OF THE
BALL.
HE CAN MOVE SIDELINE TO
SIDELINE.
GOOD CHANGE IN DIRECTION.
HE CAN FIT HIS OWN SCHEME.
HE'S STRONG ENOUGH TO BE A DRIVE
BLOCK E AS WELL.
HE'S GOING TO KICK INSIDE BUT
GUARD PLAY, AND I THINK HE CAN
START FOR THE RAMS.
THIS IS A "B" PLUS FOR ME RIGHT
HERE.
>> AT SEAN McVAY'S HOUSE IS THE
RETIRED ANDREW WHITWORTH.
THERE IS SOME TURNOVER FOR THIS
RAMS OFFENSIVE LINE, THEY ALSO
LOST AUSTIN CORBETT, THE RIGHT
GUARD IN TREE AGENCY, HE WENT TO
CAROLINA.
DO YOU THINK THIS GUY CAN COME
IN RIGHT AWAY?
>> MOVE HIM INSIDE.
CERTAINLY I THINK HE CAN COME
IN.
>> NO MOVEMENT LEFT TACKLE, THAT
MEASURES UP.
>> BUT HE CAN MOVE.
HE'S ATHLETIC ENOUGH TO MOVE.
HE'S GOT TO WORK ON THE STICK TO
IT THAT WE WANT TO SEE.
BUT HE'S A PUSHER, AND YOU WANT
TO SEE A PUSHER, A GUY THAT'S
ABLE TO GO OUT AND MOVE BOODS
AND STAY STUCK ON THE THEM, HE'S
GOT THE ABILITY TO CUT THEM OFF
FROM THE FRONT SIDE OF THE PLAY.
NOW YOU WANT TO GET THIMM OUT OF
THE WAY SO CREATE BIGGER HOLES.
THAT'S THE PART WHERE PLAYING
THE GUARD, HE'S GOING TO GET A
HEAD OF STEAM IF HE'S PULLING OR
OPPORTUNITY TO GET TO THE SECOND
LEVEL.
GIVE THIS THING A GRADE.
I'M GOING WITH A "B."
HE'S GOT A LOT OF TOOLS, IF
QUESTION IS GOING TO BE, HOW
DOES HE DO KICKING DOWN INSIDE.
>> EASIER SAID THAN DO.
GOOD POINT.
>> NOW THE FINAL PICK OF THE
THIRD ROUND, IT IS GOING TO BE
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers.
EVERYTHING WITH DEEBO, THEY ARE
GOING WIDE RECEIVER OUT OF SMU.
IT IS DANNY GRAY.
FROM THE MUSTANGS.
THE SAN FRANCISCO 49ers PICK,
LAST PICK OF THE FIRST ROUND,
WHAT KIND OF KWHIETOUT IS THIS?
>> STRAIGHT GAS.
TURNING UP THE FIELD.
SHALLOW CROSSERS, GET THE BALL
IN HIS HANDS, LET HIM RUN.
>> FORCED IT.
>> STATE CHAMPION 100 METER
RUNNER, BURNER BEFORE AND AFTER
THE CATCH.
HE KILLED TEAMS ON THAT DRAG
ROUTE CATCH AND RUN.
NO ANGLE IS SAFE.
IS IT SAFETY THINKS HE CAN COME
DOWNHILL AND GET HIM.
THE HANDS ARE WILDLY IB
CONSISTENT.
BUT HE'S BETTER THAN TIE KWAN
THORNTON.
I LIKE THAT STRAIGHT LINE GAS
AND THE 9ers SCHBS, YOU'RE GOING
TO GET PLAY ACTION BOOT WORKING,
HE'S THE GUY YOU'RE GOING TO
SEND DOWN THE FIELD.
PLAYER 103 FOR ME.
THE VALUE IS PERFECT AND I LOVE
THE FIT IN THE OFFENSE.
I WAS REALLY HIGH ON DANNY GRAY.
SUPER PRODUCTIVE PLAYER.
THIS IS AN "A" FOR ME.
SHANAHAN IS GOING TO HAVE FUN
WITH THIS ONE.
MUCH BETTER PICK THAN THE
RUNNING BACK SELECTION OF
DAVIS-PRICE.
>> HE'S A BETTER PICK THAN THAT,
FOR SURE.
>> BY A MILE.
>> MY GRADE.
I HAVE TO GO WITH THE "B."
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW IF HE CAN
CATCH.
>> IT'S THAT BAD.
>> IT'S NOT THAT BAD.
IT'S NOT TIE KWAN THORNTON BAD
BUT IT'S A LOT OF BODY CATCHING.
AND AS A DEFENSIVE BACK IF
YOU'RE BODY CATCHING THAT MEANS
I'VE GOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
IN THERE.
THAT'S THE PART THAT'S SCARY,
VERSUS A GUY THAT'S CATCHING THE
BALL OUT HERE AND HE'S GOT -- IT
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S MORE SPACE
HERE.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT IT LOCKED IN
RIGHT HERE, YOU CAN TAKE IT
AWAY, KEEP IT AWAY FROM ME.
BUT IF YOU'RE LETTING IT GET ALL
THE WAY IN, I CAN PUSH IT OUT
THAT WAY.
BIG THING FOR ME.
STATE CAMPON IN TEXAS.
>> A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
MONTANA.
>> THAT MEANS SOMETHING.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK OF WHEN YOU
WATCH DANNY GRAY ON TAPE?
>> YEAH, WATCHING HIS TAPE HE'S
A BURNER.
LIKE YOU GUYS SAID.
LET HIM CATCH THE BALL IS STRIDE
OVER THE MIDDLE.
NO ONE'S CATCHING HIM.
HE HAD A FEW FOCUSED DROPS WHICH
I NOTICED ON TAPE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW GOOD OF A ROUTE
RUNNER HE IS.
HOW POLISHED HE IS.
IF YOU CAN GET HIM IN THE PLAY
ACTION.
HAVE THE LINE BACKERS BITE.
THAT'S HIS BEST BET IN THIS
LEAGUE.
HE DEFINITELY HAS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT.
TURNING ON THE TAPE.
NO ONE'S CATCHING HIM.
ONCE HE GETS FINISHED AND
THERE'S ROOM IN FRONT OF HIM,
HE'S GONE.
I WISH IT WOULD BE MORE PHYSICAL
AT THE POINT OF CONTACT WHEN
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO TACKLE HIM.
I THINK HE CAN WORK ON THAT.
OTHER THAN THAT, HE'S A BURNER
AND YOU GOAT HIM THE BALL WITH
SPACE, IT'S OVER.
>> I LOVE THE FACT THAT WE THINK
THAT KYLE SHANAHAN CAN CREATE
SOME SEPARATION FOR HIM
UNDERNEATH AND THEN YOU BLINK,
AND HE IS GONE.
THAT IS THE FIRST THREE ROUNDS
OF THE DRAFT, IT'S CRAZY THAT WE
FINISHED IT.
I WANT TO SAY GOOD-BYE SO OUR
GUYS THAT HAVE HELD IT DOWN
REMOTELY.
LETS BRING IN AMAN ROSS ST.
BROWN.
A BIG WIDE RECEIVER CLASS.
WE APPRECIATE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JASON KELCE, THE LEGEND, I KNOW
YOU'RE TIRED FROM ALL THE
YELLING.
RICHARD SHERMAN, A HALL OF
FAMER, SO GOOD.
LET'S START OFF WITH RICHARD
SHERMAN, GO DOWN THE LINE.
FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU, GUYS.
BUT RICHARD, WHAT DID YOU THINK
OF THIS DRAFT THE FIRST THREE
ROUNDS?
I KNOW THE QUARTERBACKS HIT
LATE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS CRAZY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE RECORD FOR
TRADES AND MOVEMENT IN A DRAFT
IS, BUT I FELT LIKE THIS WAS ONE
OF THE MOST CRAZY.
THE JETS WERE SO AGGRESSIVE
EARLY.
THEY GOT THE GUYS THEY WANTED.
I WAS RAEP BECAUSE I KNOW ROBERT
S
SALEH.
I DIDN'T SEE RIDDER GETTING
PICKED AS A SECOND QUARTERBACK.
IT WAS DIFFERENT.
I'M HAPPY MALIK WILLIS WENT TO A
GOOD SITUATION IN TENNESSEE.
IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD.
>> MY MAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JASON KELCE, BOY DID I SEE A LOT
OF CINCINNATIBER CATS GETTING
DRAFTED.
BUT OVERALL THE EAGLES HAD A
GREAT DRAFT.
HOW WAS IT FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE?
>> I MEAN, THIS IS AN AWESOME
EXPERIENCE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME OUT HERE AND
HANG OUT WITH YOU GUYS.
REALLY HAPPY FOR ALL MY
BEARCATS, NOW FORMER BEARCATS,
ALONG WITH ME.
WELCOME TO THE NFL.
EXCITED TO JOIN ALL MY TEAMMATES
IN PHILADELPHIA, MY NEW
TEAMMATES.
AND MAN, I DO NOT ENVY YOU GUYS,
AS SOMEONE WHO'S KIND OF JUST
TRYING TO DIP HIS TOE IN AND
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THIS IS FUN
TO DO AND JUST DOING O LINE, D
LINE WHERE I FEEL COMFORTABLE.
IT MAKES WHAT YOU THREE GUYS DO
THAT MUCH MORE IMPRESSIVE.
TO HAVE TO KNOW ALL THESE GUYS
AND YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER DAY LEFT.
GOOD LUCK.
IT'S AN IMPRESSIVE AMOUNT OF
TAPE YOU GUYS HAVE ALL WATCHED
AND PUT IN.
SO WAY TO GO.
>> YOU KNOW, NORMALLY I WOULD
TRY AND BE HUMBLE, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, THANKS, BRO.
NOT ONLY DO WE APPRECIATE IT BUT
WE DESERVE IT.
AND THEN WE'LL END WITH AMAN
ROSS ST. BROWN.
YOU'RE THE YOUNG GUY HERE, YOU
CAME OUT HERE.
YOU'VE PLAYED WITH A BUNCH OF
THESE GUYS.
HAD TO BE COOL TO SEE A BUNCH OF
YOUR FRIENDS GET DRAFTED.
>> TELL ME HE FROZE RIGHT AT
THAT MOMENT.
AMAN ROSS ST. BROWN WAS GREAT.
THANK YOU TO HIM.
JASON KELCE AND RICHARD SHERMAN.
BEFORE WE SAY GOOD-BYE.
YOU GUYS WILL BE HERE TOMORROW.
I WANT TO SAY ONE THING REALLY
QUICK, AND I WANT TO JUST TOOT
OUR OWN HORN REALLY QUICK.
IF YOU GUYS WERE CHECKING OUT
THE TV BROADCAST, WHAT YOU SAW
IN THE THIRD ROUND IS THE ISSUE
WITH THE NFL DRAFT ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
THEY'RE SHOWING MAGIC TRICKS,
SHOWING THE FOUNTAIN LIKE IT
MATTERS.
WE KNOW THAT COMPLETE FRANCHISES
ARE CHANGED IN THE THIRD ROUND
AND THEY DIDN'T CARE.
THEY DON'T CARE.
THEY CARE ABOUT AD DOLLARS.
WE DON'T.
OKAY.
ROBERT MORTGAGE HOOKED US UP TO
THE POINT WHERE WE COULD BREAK
DOWN THESE GUYS AND THESE TWO
LEGENDS, CONNOR LODGERS AND
MICHAEL FELDER, CARE AND THEY
WATCH EVERYTHING AND TOMORROW
WHEN THE NFL NETWORK IS TALKING
ABOUT MO THE CORRAL AND TALKING
ABOUT DESMOND RIDDER, THEY'LL
BREAK DOWN EVERY SINGLE PICK IN
ROUND 4 THROUGH 7.
I'M EXCITED TO WATCH YOU
TOMORROW.
LET'S WRAP UP TONIGHT.
THE PICKS THAT HAVE STUCK WITH
YOU.
NOT WINNERS AND ALL THAT STUFF.
BUT THE PICKS THAT ARE -- YOU
CAN'T GET OUT OF YOUR HEAD RIGHT
NOW, CONNOR.
>> OH, MAN, IT STARTS WITH THE
RAVENS GETTING TRAVIS JONES.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE TO GET
THAT CALIBER OF A FIRST ROUND
PLAYER IN A POSITION OF NEED.
IN A NAKOBE DEAN, I WANT TO SEE
HIM PLAY THE WAY HE PLAYED AT
GEORGIA.
THOSE ARE THE BIG ONES FOR ME.
I WANT TO SEE MALIK WILLIS GROW
SLOWLY IN TENNESSEE.
NOT BE THROWN INTO THE FIRE, NOT
BE THROWN INTO A BAD SITUATION.
HE WAS GIVEN THAT OPPORTUNITY.
THIS IS A BLAST STAKE, THIS IS
WHEN SUPER BOWLS ARE MADE.
>> NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT.
>> FOR ME, I'M GOING TO GO WITH
FOUR CINCINNATI GUYS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN, GO COOK,
WHO I ABSOLUTELY LOVE.
I'VE TALKED ABOUT HIM.
>> GOING TO THE CHIEFS.
>> YEAH, I ABSOLUTELY LOVE WHAT
HE BRINGS TO THE TABLE.
ALEC PIERCE.
A GUY THAT WE DO WONDER HOW --
DOES HE HAVE THE SPEED TO
SEPARATE?
MAYBE IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THIS GUY CAN JUMP.
DESMOND RIDDER.
A QUARTERBACK, KELSEY CALLED HIM
THE BEST QUARTERBACK OF ALL TIME
FROM CINCINNATI.
LISTEN, YOU GET HIM IN THE THIRD
ROUND, THAT'S NOT JUST VALUE.
A GUY A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
WAS FIRST ROUND.
AND MYJAI SANDERS.
WE DIDN'T GET COBY BRYANT.
>> EVERYBODY'S GOING TO TALK
ABOUT GEORGIA FIRST ROUND.
FOUR GUYS GOING DAY TWO, THAT'S
A NICE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
>> I'M EXCITED FOR TOMORROW.
TOMORROW, LIKE LEFKOE SAID, IT'S
ALL ABOUT THE PICKS.
>> IT'S ALL ABOUT THE PICKS,
WHEN THAT CLOCK STARTS, WE'RE
HAVE -- I KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE
EXCITED TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF
THE WIDE RECEIVERS THAT -- ALL
KINDS OF PLAYERS.
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT.
>> WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
PRODUCERS, OUR DIRECTORS, ALL OF
THE TECHNICAL STAFF, THIS IS A
VERY LONG DAY FOR EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PRODUCTION
CREW FOR MAKING THIS POSSIBLE.
THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP DOING THIS
FOR YOU, AND SO THANKS TO
EVERYBODY HERE, THIS HAS BEEN
DRAFT NIGHT EXTRAVAGANZA, DAY
TWO IN THE BOOKS.
DON'T WASTE YOUR TIME WITH
TELEVISION.
THE DAY THREE HAPPENS RIGHT HERE
TOMORROW.
HOPE YOUR TEAMS DRAFTED WHO YOU
WANTED.